foreign
everyone
and welcome to the committee on a house
committee on Health and Human Services
and elderly Affairs we have several
bills to hear this morning and during
the course of the day but first I'd ask
that you join me in the Pledge of
Allegiance
of the United States
one nation under God indivisible with
liberty and justice for all
foreign
thank you everyone
um before I get into the the first bill
and the first set of hearings I just
wanted to thank all the committee
members for getting their reports in
last night I've sent them on to
Christina Dyer and Lindsay ostrike I
believe is oh the name is pronounced so
again thank you all very much
the first bill to um consider this
morning is House Bill 406 and it's
sponsored by representative kovalt who's
a member of our committee
foreign
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee
um this bill I think is uh
quite straightforward in its language
um it asserts that a parent or Guardian
has the right to access their minor
unemancipated child's medical records
with some exceptions and those
exceptions are wherever there is a
specific provision in State Statute or
state law or federal law
that allows for those records to be uh
to be to be kept confidential
or where there is suspected abuse
or in cases where the parent has agreed
in writing to waive the right to access
those records
so you may ask why this is necessary
it's because in state law we don't have
anything that's specifically asserts a
parent's right to access medical records
and in fact some health care providers
have issued letters to
um
to parents I have one in front of me
here which outlines all of the uh all of
the categories of medical records that a
parent would not have access to because
their child turned 12. and so from the
age of 12 to 18
there were certain records that these
there are certain records that Health
Care Providers are choosing to withhold
from parents
so
and that includes for example lab test
results in under State Statute there are
some lab test results and even the fact
that
a lab test was ordered could be withheld
and I'll talk about some of those
examples now so HIV testing for example
is confidential
likewise sexually transmitted diseases
we we would not want
a 17 year old who suspects that may they
may have a sexually transmitted disease
to not seek care and not seek treatment
so there are specific
um there are specific carve-outs like
those
the the bill is actually worded that any
treatment that would require the parents
consent also affords the parent the
right to those medical records so there
are some other things that don't require
parental consent for example a minor age
12 or older May consent to treatment for
drug dependency so if they have
substance abuse problems 12 or older can
consent to treatment without the consent
of a parent or Guardian
um so these and a number of other
categories are covered under both
federal and state law so they would not
be subject to the disclosure uh to to
the uh to the mandatory disclosure
parents under under this bill
um mandatory disclosure is probably not
an accurate way of describing it it's
not that they are required to
proactively disclose it is um it is that
parents have a right to access it upon
request
um so everything else essentially any
medical records relating to any
treatment that requires consent that is
not otherwise
carved out in state or federal law would
be made available to parents if this
bill were to become law
um and I just want to
um
mention that the Constitutional law
asserts that parents
there is a there's a presumption that
parents have the best interest of their
children in mind and this was affirmed
in Parham versus Jr and this was a
Supreme Court case
in which a Georgia couple wanted to
commit their minor child to a mental
facility and the court determined that
this was in fact in the bet that the the
parents were acting in the best interest
of the child and that you know they they
allowed for some sort of follow-up
process to affirm that that process was
being done in good faith but that there
was not a need to have a preemptive
court order to make it happen so the
presumption there in the to quote from
Parham versus Jr the court stated that
the natural bonds of affection lead
parents to act in the best interest of
their children so this is established in
constitutional law it's affirmed by the
U.S Supreme Court and it is the basis
upon which this bill is founded
and with that I will and my testimony
and take questions okay great thank you
representative King
looking at uh thank you Mr chairman and
thank you representative Koval for
taking my question
um I'm looking at lines eight and nine
and I I see the words reasonable
reasonably believes
is it not true that uh if they
reasonably believe that there's uh that
there's domestic violence abuse or
neglect that they would actually have to
report that
that is that is correct yes thank you
other questions
yes representative Weber
thank you Mr chairman and thank you very
much for taking my question
um I'm wondering if you could provide
the committee members with a list both
of uh the things that you were informed
that the doctor would not supply
and also with a list of things that as
this bill is drafted would be supplied
that would be really very helpful in
terms of because I know there's a fairly
large Global Universe out there yes and
I'll be happy to email the committee
copies of of a letter from Elliott
Health to uh to parents this this does
not have any names on it so it doesn't
need to be redacted
um and it is a bit dated it is dated
2012.
um so they may have different policies
in place at this time nevertheless
there's still nothing in State Statute
that prevents them them or other
providers from taking this position so
I'll just list a couple of things
um
parents do not have the the right acts
the access under this letter from
Elliott Health to view lab test results
uh to track ongoing health concerns to
view past office visits or to view
future appointments to cancel
appointments or to refill
prescriptions so
that specific list has to do with
online access but it is accompanying a
letter that essentially says you know
you're you know there there will be
automatic changes for patients turning
years old
um and that that certain
access to certain records will be
um will be limited for parents from that
point forward so I'll be happy to email
that to the committee
representative McLean
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so I'm a little bit
confused
um and maybe you can help me so if if
there is no if there's currently no
right to access
records for the parent once a child gets
over the age of 12 you mentioned that
there are all these carve outs that
exist
why do those carvarks exist and if there
is no right you know what I'm saying so
I wouldn't have to create an exception
to
um not to prevent access if the law
currently does not allow access at all
does that make sense
um it does make sense I I think that
that when
when certain
legislation was passed for example the
RSA 141c 18 and I will provide a copy of
my testimony to to members of the
committee but 141c 18
is is specifically about a minor child
14 years of adult or 14 years of age or
older May voluntarily submit himself
or herself to medical diagnosis and
treatment for a sexually transmitted
disease
and a licensed physician May diagnose
treat or prescribe for the treatment of
a sexually transmitted disease in a
minor 14 years of age or older without
the knowledge or consent of the parent
or legal guardian of such minor so I
believe that that language was added in
order to just affirmatively assert that
in this case
um
if if another bill like the one we're
hearing today were to come along that
the the legislators who who filed that
legislation wanted to affirmatively
assert that this is a situation in which
we would want to maintain Conte
confidentiality and that there is a
compelling State interest in doing so
yeah
um did you want to follow yeah just a
quick follow-up so the the the items
mentioned in your testimony earlier
about the Elliot are those currently
um
are they
are there
restrictions on those things currently
in statute or is that just kind of that
umbrella language that you were talking
about
um there's nothing in State Statute that
says the parents affirmatively have a
right to this information
under HIPAA the apparent acting in local
you know basic or parent or person
acting acting in local parentis has the
um has the right to give consent
on behalf of a minor and has the right
to the miners Health Care records and
again in federal statute there are also
some carve-outs so this bill essentially
says those carve outs remain intact so
again in sexually transmitted diseases
are also covered in federal law Family
Planning is covered in federal law so
there are it's it's actually a fairly
confusing mix of uh of laws and I know
that the the memo that we got uh just a
few minutes ago includes a document that
I think is actually quite useful
um and it contains a table
um so so it's sort of a long document
but if you go to the table which is
well those pages are numbered
um and if it's it's page 10 uh table one
and then page 11 table 2 is is a useful
reference that can outline
which which procedures a a miner would
need to consent to
and what the specific confidentiality
laws are with respect to those I did
speak to an attorney about
um sort of mental health and had a
little bit of a disagreement between
this document and the attorney with whom
I spoke regarding mental health
um and I'm trying to find it right now
there is a case Berg versus Berg which
was a New Hampshire Supreme Court case
in which the the court determined that
a minor child May assert their rights of
sort of privileged communication with a
mental health provider
um under certain at least under certain
circumstances and the circumstances of
that case were that the parents were
getting divorced they were at battle
with each other the the father wanted
access to the mental health records the
the
counselor's notes
um to determine whether there were
parental alienation efforts going on by
the wife in this case the judge
determined that it was not in the best
that that was not done in good faith in
the best interest of the child and
therefore asserted that the the father
did not have a right to access those
records under those situations so the
difference I think is
where some of the some of the opinions
that I have seen assert that that was
sort of a broad
a broad decision some other uh some
other records or some other opinions
that I have seen assert that it no it
was actually quite narrowly defined
um around that best interest of the
child standard
representative Palmer and then
representative Weber
so I'm glad I'm not a pediatrician
because
um so I guess my concern
would be um some of the Lesser issues I
know when my kids got to that age after
the first part of a you know well child
check we would be ushered out of the
room and the pediatrician was talking to
them about risky behaviors so it wasn't
as didn't reach the level of treatment
for an STD as far as I know but it was
more about tobacco drugs alcohol
sex all of those things that they would
not want to maybe talk about in front of
their parents but as a parent I would
like my pediatrician to talk to my kids
about
um and I just want to make sure that
that doesn't get quashed
I mean I guess I'd like you to comment
yeah so so I think that's a very very
valid concern
um I think all of us when we're at that
stage in our lives probably had things
that we didn't want to talk to our
parents about but there were other
trusted adults that we wanted to have
those conversations with
um I actually think there's a simple
answer to this and and that lies in the
bill itself
um
Roman numeral three one of the
exceptions in which a parent's parent
would not have access to medical records
would be if the parent or legal guardian
agrees to a confidential communication
between the minor and a health care
provider so I think again this puts the
power in the hands of the parent to make
that decision I think that the parent
again is presumed to be acting in the
best interest of the child and
um
you know I I ultimately believe that
parents should be in control of of
whether those conversations happen who
has those conversations with their
children
um and and has some awareness that
they're happening
um even if
you know they they choose to
allow that you know someone else may be
the better person to have some of those
confidential conversations
representative Weber and then
representative Seth King
thank you Mr chairman I just wanted to
acknowledge that between the time uh the
last question was asked and the time I
put my hand up I I had discovered the
excellent research that Ms Dyer has
provided us with and I just wanted to
say thank you and that
um relieves you of some of the questions
that I asked earlier but I would still
love to see the the Elliott letter if
you're willing to share it happy to do
that thank you so much
Christina how we always does a great job
representative King thank you chairman
McDonald thank you for taking questions
so you mentioned that
um there are times where the doctors are
refusing to give the information to the
parents and it and it doesn't fit into
one of these three categories
can you can you give me any examples not
just of doctors not giving information
but where maybe it was later found out
that there was some very inappropriate
behavior or abuse or
something happening from the medical
profession towards the children because
I think that's really at the heart of it
what we're really concerned about is hey
the doctors aren't doing what's in the
best interest of the children but do we
have any any real documentation that
that's the case thank you
um I'm gonna I'm gonna actually say
that's that's not my concern I mean my
concern is that parents be informed and
have have a full right to access medical
records I think uh generally speaking
um
I I think that
you know Physicians get into in
healthcare providers in general get into
the field that they get into because
they they want to get into a caring
profession
um my concern is that
in order for parents to do their job
effectively they need to be fully
informed and it concerns me greatly when
I see a form letter with a kind of
blanket statement there's all this
information that you're not going to
have access to and
um
you know I just generally think that we
need to remedy that and a lot of this I
think ultimately is about trust because
when I when I
um when I think about parents rights
issues and this to me is a parental
rights issue
um I think that you know it's about
establishing a a framework for trust and
a foundation for that and I I think that
this does that creating a foundation for
trust does not automatically imply that
there's distrust it it simply says that
you know we need to we need full
communication and fully informed parents
okay thank you other questions
yes representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative couple taking the
question
does this preclude a court I'm not an
attorney so I'm looking at two here on
the committee
is does this preclude a court order from
releasing the information if the court
deems it to be appropriate
um
I would have to consult with an attorney
my intention would be that yes a court
could could order records sealed because
we currently have processes around some
of the carve outs that are or some of
the things that are in uh in in the law
today
um you know for example you know we
require parental notification for
abortion
um
as I understand it there is there is a
process that a minor can go through if
if there are abuse issues or other
concerns that would lead a court to
to allow that process to be to be
accepted so
um so so my my intention and my
understanding is that yes a court could
could order otherwise as they did in the
Berg versus Berg case
which was a New Hampshire Supreme Court
case a follow-up follow-up do we need to
include something in the bill to be
clear that that is in fact the case
I would be happy to work with members of
the committee if you decide you would
like to do that yes
representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um
I'm just thinking as a parent
uh and I and I have heard complaints
from other parents too about this very
problem
um do you see this kind of practice
where there's a blanket policy for not
releasing
um you know the Exempted medical records
to the parents would deter parents or
make them you know think they don't want
to bring their child to the doctor for
care
um
it's interesting that you should ask
that so I I have spoken to parents who
are
reluctant I think there was a comment
earlier about
um you know the the parent is asked to
leave the room I have certainly spoken
to parents who say I'm not comfortable
with that and I don't like that and I
again I believe that the parent acting
in the best interest of their child has
has every right to assert that an
exception would be in the case of
suspected abuse and you know there there
is a scenario included in the bill in
which if there is suspected abuse then
medical records may be withheld I'm not
sure how a physician would handle that
scenario where they're asking the parent
to leave the room and they suspect abuse
but it seems to me that as mandatory
reporters at that point it's time to
call in
um the you know dcyf or or someone who
can who can look into the situation
okay other questions yes representative
Nagle thank you Mr chairman thanks for
taking my question
I'm trying to figure out how to turn
this into a question but it's an
important issue
um I think this bill is very helpful for
um
removing some of the confusion that we
as doctors have so we treat adolescents
like they're quasi adults
um what we're taught in this age group
is that we should give them some freedom
to express themselves without the parent
present I think that what you've seen
from Elliot Hospital is turning that
into a very different issue that the kid
has the right to do this without the
parents being involved
um that's why I'm struggling to turn
this into a question but I think this is
really important to teach doctors that
that yeah this is important to develop
Independence but
we need to have some sort of standard
I'm still struggling to make this a
question yeah
yeah
I'm really
is that would you believe I am
struggling with the issue that yeah
would you believe I'm trying to find the
words for yeah you're right you're
definitely not ready for a parliamentary
no definitely not not but I have three
minutes I was told earlier this morning
so
um chairman
uh uh yes representative Weber point
point of question to the chair this is
our time to receive information from the
person sitting at the chair not give it
and we have chances to talk among
ourselves afterwards and draft among
ourselves afterwards and certainly give
our opinions knowledge and wisdom at the
executive session
well yeah Mr Mr chairman can follow
later
representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question in fact thank you
for
being so thorough and so sensitive to
the
you know what's in law already and
what's not in law and how um complicated
it is because it really is incredibly
complicated so in terms of complications
I see that you've tried and and in Roman
numeral two that you've talked about
um what could be further exceptions
besides what's in law if there was some
kind of danger to the child specifically
domestic violence and the last line on
on line 10
could endanger the child and
um I guess I'm wondering if you've given
any thought to that
that phrase because that phrase is
somewhat subjective especially
um
the mental health field
um when we're talking about not not
necessarily physical danger but you know
what might be
traumatic or be problematic for somebody
who's in therapy for example I don't
have a better phrase to give you but um
I'm wondering if you feel like that may
be still leave things open to a great
deal of subjectivity
I I thank you for for your question and
for pointing that out I I
think that there is potentially room to
to tighten that up my concern is that if
it's tightened up too much it doesn't
give Mental Health Providers the
the decision-making power that they
necessarily need I would say that
um
could endanger the child
to me generally means the the physical
health welfare and well-being of the
child and as soon as I say well-being
we're crossing over into the subjective
territory again I actually believe that
um with this bill in place it's it's
highly likely that people in the mental
health profession would probably
um begin sort of sort of their intake
process might include a waiver of
confidentiality statement uh the parents
would sign that would acknowledge
because if a parent I think is taking
their child to a mental health
professional or consenting to Mental
Health Services from a professional that
it would
um it would be prudent for them to
acknowledge that part of the value of
that relationship is the ability for
that child to have Frank and open
conversations with a trusted adult and
so so I would imagine that that would
potentially become part of a standard
practice
in taking on new patients and that that
would resolve a lot of those kinds of of
concerns
thank you other questions
yes representative McKay
thank you Mr chairman
this is a follow-up on my friend's uh
mental health discussion I I had a
situation that is it a question
representative yes I'm getting a bad
reputation but would you believe that
that
there are some very serious
complications in the mental health field
this this was a situation where the
mother had custody of the child
the parents hadn't got divorced yet but
were in the process of getting a divorce
the the
Sun
that I was seeing
was very torn between both parents
the father came to me and said I want
all of his records
and I said in essence you can go to hell
because you're not getting any records
from me
I had no idea where that could lead to
that
the
situation was extremely difficult
because this man had sued several local
Selectmen and other elected type
individuals
to make a long story short this was
something that I was never trained to
deal with it's not a medical thing it's
a PhD thing and they're very similar
what saved the day for me is that this
fellow turned 18. the day before and
said they're my records he's not getting
them but that from an educational point
of view this presents extremely
complicated issues particularly in the
mental health field
so first of all thank you I want to say
thank you for for standing up for your
patient doing what I think was the right
thing the bird versus bird case was very
very similar to that it was a divorce
case it was a case in which the the
father was serving his own interests not
the the best interest of the child and
the New Hampshire Supreme Court came
down firmly uh in favor of keeping those
medical records private because the the
parent was not requesting them in the
best interest of the child
thank you other questions
yes representative McLean just a just a
quick question just kind of cement my
understanding of the current process So
currently
um you mentioned that um you received a
letter that says we we can't even give
you lab results but it's my
understanding that if a parent wanted to
act something let's say it was hey you
have cancer and so you have to go
forward we want to have surgery so that
would require parental consent I would
assume
so it's not an emergency yes there are
some exceptions if it's an emergency
situation yes so so okay so that's in
that case it already is it would be
disclosed in order to get parental
consent they would have to disclose that
information currently
informed consent would dictate that yes
okay thank you
other questions
seeing no other questions okay thank you
representative profile
also signed up to testify is Paula
minahan from the New Hampshire Hospital
Association
foreign
Mr chairman members of the committee for
the record my name is Paula minnehan
Senior vice president state government
relations with the New Hampshire
Hospital Association representing all
our hospitals throughout the state we
are opposed to House Bill 406 relative
to release of teenagers medical records
to a parent or Guardian this bill is
almost identical to a bill that was
introduced last year House Bill 1345 we
were opposed to that as well and had
many concerns however House Bill 406 was
amended to address some of the concerns
at the health care Community has raised
last year however we continue to believe
that this bill is unnecessary as the
health insurance portability and
accountability act HIPAA already covers
when a Minor's medical records can be
released however if this bill were to
move forward there is another major
concern with the bill before you on line
nine the word and after neglect needs to
be changed to or it should be it should
read
I'm Excuse me
so it goes the CH on line nine the child
has been or may be subjected to domestic
violence comma abuse or neglect comma
and then it says and that the release of
the medical records to the parent or
Guardian shouldn't what could endanger
the child it should be or that was that
was debated last year
um this bill like I said was made it to
the Senate HHS but we um and other
stakeholders that I think are here today
that represent Health Care Providers
requested that the and be changed to or
the bill didn't go forward in the Senate
HHS it was laid on the table but again
that that is our request if in fact the
committee determines it is necessary to
move this bill forward we remain
convinced that this bill is unnecessary
but um
I am not an expert in this area this is
very complex as you have identified and
as representative Cole fault um I think
did a great job trying to explain on
this pretty complicated issue but if you
have questions I'm happy to take them
back and
get you an answer
okay thank you representative Leon thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for being
here today
um I was wondering if you could speak
with Exeter Hospital and see what their
current policy is regarding the release
of miners records so that we can
understand that this is an ongoing issue
today or not
Exeter Hospital
I apologize yeah I I very much doubt
that they are violating any laws because
of HIPAA but I am happy to look into it
I would love if he could confirm that
for us thank you sure
yes representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you uh
Mr Shanahan for taking my question
um I understand you saying that um your
opinion is that this is not necessary
and maybe duplicative
um but I'm wondering if you or the
providers you represent
um
could tell us what problems might occur
because of a a law like this
um let let me get you something in
writing
because again this is a complicated
issue and and I know you appreciate that
so let me get you a thorough response
other questions
representative McLean thank you Mr uh
thank you Miss Manor for taking my
question are you aware of any elements
of this law that is in conflict with
HIPAA and if so you know what is a
normal resolution does HIPAA Trump
in that case
so our state has a more restrictive
HIPAA law than the federal government so
the state HIPAA
privacy laws Trump
um any you can be more restrictive than
uh but not less restrictive than the
federal
um so again not I am not a HIPAA expert
either this is a very very complicated
um uh area of of
um Health policy and law so
um I don't know that I can answer your
question thoroughly follow up so so but
to the best of your knowledge this this
is within the constraints of HIPAA you
believe
um as
representative kofault indicated um
HIPAA is
um contemplated in this bill
um as an exception
um when they would not be able to
release medical records so it's you know
it's it's Roman 3.
um so HIPAA is contemplated
um in this bill again our
concern is well two things one we don't
believe it's necessary second of all
again
um the and should be changed to or
because that is one word but it's uh
it's an important word
um so the and if it read or that the
release of medical records could
endanger the child and I think that
addresses um representative McKay and
other clinicians on the committee's um
concerns
yeah other questions yes representative
Weber
I can't believe I'm actually asking this
but
um as I read it
obviously the or is necessary for to
cover the issue of a child who was not
previously abused or neglected but might
be in the future if the records were
released
but uh doesn't isn't that covered by the
phrase the child has been or may be
subjected
to domestic violence abuse or neglect
does that
change the need for the ore
because it does contemplate future
I'm not sure that it covers thank you
for your question I'm not sure that it
covers every
circumstance potentially
I know that there are others here that
are more expert in this area relative to
mental health so um hopefully they can
raise other
um answer that question more thoroughly
and could I have a follow-up follow-up
as I'm as I keep reading this over and
over uh could the difference be that the
standard in the first half of the
sentence is subjected to domestic
violence or abuse or neglect and the
second part of the sentence
says release of the medical records
could endanger the child and doesn't
specify how so it might be broader yes
okay yes I agree
other questions yes representative
Merchant thank you thank you Mr chair
thank you Ms minnehan for taking the
question
in regards to the HIPAA what I heard was
State HIPAA law is more strict than the
federal but this only
goes back to the quote Federal not to
the state so should we include reference
to the state HIPAA as well as the
federal to ensure that we have the more
stringent one included in the bill
except at the beginning on line six
as directed by federal or specific state
law so it may be covered there
again this is um a small it's a it's a
simple bill it looks like a simple bill
but it's not it's it's really
complicated
um and we just got to make sure that I
we believe we want to make sure that um
uh miners
um over the age of um you know between
13 and 19 I think that's what this yeah
18 excuse me are um protected
um as they um as the law contemplates
but you make a good point maybe it needs
more clarity I just again why do we call
it out in number three HIPAA when we
have online
um
6 that we say both federal and state but
we then refer to HIPAA in line 12.
so I just want to be clear that we're
consistent with a reference to HIPAA
both at the federal and state level and
line
12.
valid point representative King
thank you chairman thank you for taking
questions today
on issues that are present I and
confusing I like to look to our
ancestors for guidance surely issues
like this must have come up in the 1800s
early 1900s
somebody 15 years old going to a doctor
and the parents maybe didn't know or
they did know
can you tell me I don't know if you have
this information but can you tell me
what it was like back in the day did
parents always have the ability to get
this information or was it understood
that nope 15 year olds that's their
private information I mean I just like
to look to our ancestors what can our
ancestors tell us around back then I
know I was going to say that is kind of
a slight to my age I think but I'll try
not to take it that way um I do not know
the answer to that
um and I think you have some experts on
the committee that are have um were are
or were Physicians that maybe can um
help you a little bit more as far as the
historical nature of um how health care
was handled back in the whenever the
ancestors but um I do not know the
answer to that
representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question uh
I I'm thinking about how parents are you
know it's accepted that in most
situations they have the best interest
of the child in mind and I'm wondering
does the New Hampshire Hospital
Association have any guidance that they
give to the hospital systems uh
regarding this and you know reminding
them that they can't just keep records
closed and if the law is truly
unnecessary you know is there do they
have guidance on that from you guys uh
HIPAA guides them um we don't need to
guide them the federal I mean they know
about HIPAA so it's really the
overarching Privacy requirements federal
and state law
follow up thank you
um well we just heard and I've heard
personally from parents that these these
policies do exist and there have been
emails and I know sometimes you don't
like to believe parents when they're
telling you these things but it is
happening so I think there there does
need to be some guidance and would you
consider bringing that to the New
Hampshire Hospital Association
if this law is truly unnecessary and
just using your your power in your
organization to deal with the problem
representative Cushman what you just
said was insulting to me I do believe
parents um we we are I represent
hospitals and they treat parents and
children and um and all sorts of
patients and for you to stay that was
insulting to me so I I will not answer
your question I certainly will talk with
the hospitals but please do not insult
um me in the future I think I'm all set
thank you I apologize I was not
intending to insult you just going off
of our previous experiences together
thank you
foreign
also signed up to testify is Sam Hawkins
from from Nami New Hampshire
I'm sorry representative Palmer
I'd just like to make a comment about
HIPAA that perhaps we should offline
review that because it is
um it's a very strict law and hospitals
are extremely and and medical practices
are extremely wary of it because the
penalties are huge so a lot of the
reason that people are so wary about
institutions and Physicians are so wary
about giving out this information is
because they can they can end up in
court and so I just would suggest that
people familiarize themselves with that
law a little bit because that's part of
what the problem is here okay thank you
good morning sir good morning minutes
please yes
uh thank you chairman to the committee
for the opportunity to testify today my
name is Sam Hawkins I'm the public
policy assistant at Nami New Hampshire
uh the National Alliance on Mental
Illness Nami New Hampshire is a
non-profit Grassroots organization whose
mission is to improve the lives of all
people impacted by mental illness and
suicide through support education and
advocacy on behalf of Nami I'm here
today to speak in opposition to HB 406
and I'll keep my comments brief because
our stance is very close to the New
Hampshire hospital associations we
recognize the importance of familial
support throughout our system of care
for children's mental health and in our
experience counselors and therapists who
are proficient in their practice will
involve the family including the parents
and Guardians and the treatment of an
adolescent patient
but we do know where there are some
situations where a child may be
endangered by the disclosure of mental
health records and for these children we
believe that access to a private
therapeutic relationship is essential so
we would be asking for the same thing
about the New Hampshire Hospital
Association would be asking for is that
and on line nine changed to an or if
that were to be changed our position
would be neutral on this but as
introduced we are opposed thank you
thank you representative Leon thank you
Mr chairman and thank you very much for
being here
um we're dealing with all sorts of
problems today in our society we
actually just lost somebody in my
community the other day my question is
if there's a provider who is seeing a
child who has potential suicidal
ideation and the parent does not know
about that not because of any specific
threat but because in general I think
that could hurt the parents that could
hurt the child and then that child does
follow through on that is there anything
being done to catch that from falling
through the tracks because I think every
parent I don't do you agree with me that
every parent should have the chance to
support their child while they're still
alive
uh thank you for your question
um
if if a provider believes it is my my
belief that I'm not sure if it's if it's
in law or just standards I believe it's
in law that if a provider believes that
there is a real harmed self or others
for the child they are under a duty to
act and a duty to report
um of course there are still still kids
who slip through the cracks and that is
very tragic but I do believe that
there's still a duty to act relevant to
what you're asking
follow up um thank you and um if there
are any processes to find those children
who slip through the cracks I'd really
be help happy to find out about that and
support those efforts with you yeah
that's what I think thank you
representative McLean thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question
um I just I'm curious we had a lot of
talk about disclosure versus
non-disclosure and and HIPAA and I'm not
a HIPAA expert so I guess I'm just
trying to understand when
um a provider or an institution
implements its policy do they have
discretion when they're implementing
their disclosure policy
to go beyond HIPAA in other words I know
that they can't violate HIPAA but do
they have the discretion to go even
further that and say no HIPAA would
allow this release but we are not going
to I hope you understood what I'm saying
I I think for your question I think I
understand what you're saying I'm not at
all a hip expert as we've acknowledged
this very complicated issue
um
as to whether they can choose to
withhold beyond what HIPAA um what what
HIPAA requires
um
I believe in the chase in the case of a
relationship between a parent and a
child and if laws like this were to pass
they would not be able to do so
follow-up but in in the current state do
they have that discretion or you're not
sure I'm not sure but I can look into
that thank you
other questions
any other questions
yes representative King thank you
chairman McDonald
this bill is dealing with 13 to 18 year
olds
and I think
I think people can disagree have an
honest debate on just exactly when a
person becomes more adult than less
adult
and so you're opposed to this bill but
if this bill were let's just say for 0
to 12 year olds would you support it I
mean is there any age where you finally
say yeah you know what we need to
support that or is 13 your limit or is
there no limit that you know what I mean
is there is there I mean we're dealing
with just a specific set here but if
we're talking 0 to 12 is that when you
support the bill or I don't know I'm
just curious where where your cutoff
line is thank you I appreciate your
question I I'm not sure I'm able to
speak to the organization's viewpoint on
that at this point look into it right
now
okay any other questions
I'm seeing none okay so thank you sir
the last person signed up to testify
this morning on this bill is uh Emma
Sevigny from new futures
thank you chairman and members of the
committee my name is Emma savini I am
the children's Behavioral Health policy
coordinator at new Futures new Futures
is a nonpartisan non-profit advocacy
organization that Advocates educates and
collaborates for the great health and
wellness of all Granite Staters
we are here in opposition to House Bill
406 and our position is very similar to
nami's in the hospital associations
um we in the first instance believe that
this bill is unnecessary and could have
a chilling effect on a child's
relationship with their mental health
provider which could impact treatment
outcomes and cause children to avoid
getting treatment early or avoid being
fully honest with a provider in a way
that would
um you know have a chilling effect on
their ability to receive uh proper and
efficient treatment
um
as you heard wonderfully from
representative kopal about the Berg
decision that decision really emphasized
the importance of having
confidentiality in situ certain
situations for mental health records for
minors
um and so we just would ask in the first
instance that this bill be voted itl and
then in the second instance if you do
believe that this bill needs to move
forward have that carve out where it is
changing that and on line nine to an or
in an amendment and I'm happy to take
any questions questions yes
representative Weber
this is a follow-up to a question that
representative merchand asked earlier do
you have any opinion about
the effect of this bill on the ability
of a court to order
in either direction either order
disclosure to a parent or order
non-disclosure of
a medical record yes
um so I am an attorney but I have been
out of practice for a little bit so I
don't have the answer off the top of my
head that I'm happy to get that for you
if you could that would be very helpful
to us absolutely thank you
other questions
yes representative Nagel believe it or
not I do have a question
thank you for taking my question
um we focused a lot on mental health and
I do understand that um on page 10 of
the guide that we were handed it seems
to be accepted from this bill is that
your understanding or not so
um I'm sorry I left my bill the bill
text it's not in the bill I'm sorry it's
something you're right-handed so um I
don't think mental health is necessarily
accepted to the full extent it would be
under current law this bill would be
narrowing the scope of the ability for a
provider to keep confidential records
for mental health purposes
um and that's why we were requesting
that change from an aunt to an or to
bring it more in line with the mature
minor statue or mature minor standard
that's found in the bird case
other questions
representative palazzov
thank you Mr Chen thank you for taking
my question uh I want to ask what
percentage of
your patients we are talking about
obviously probably it's a significant
one since
um
it's important for you to testify here
is it like one percent of kids who seek
mental health problems that you assess
as antagonistic with parents and you
don't want to release this record so is
it like half of your clients what
percentage just to clarify I am not a
mental health provider I'm a policy
coordinator with a with the non-profit
so I don't actually give mental health
treatment but I can absolutely try and
find that statistic for you across New
Hampshire I'm not sure it's necessarily
exists but I'll look for it for you
thank you very much yes representative
McLean
thank you Mr chair and and thank you for
taking my question so um one of the
things that this bill is sort of
explicit about it from reading is the
fact and we heard testimony to this that
that HIPAA is still there and all the
protection is given by HIPAA are still
there so I think this is clarifying so
can you can you think of an example
because I don't have your experience
where you might come across a situation
where this might actually impede
treatment can you think of a specific
case
um where this bill would impede
treatment yes so
um I think just in a situation where a
minor is seeking treatment and maybe
um you know discussing something that
their parents may not necessarily know
or agree about with and they're scared
to discuss that with their parents but
they're looking to their treatment
mental health treatment provider to find
a healthy way to discuss that with their
parents a lot of times treatment
providers as Mr Hawkins mentioned from
Nami will try to bring in the parents
when it's appropriate so a lot of times
they'll work together but they are not
ready to disclose something to a parent
right away
follow up and and that that kind of
conversation is currently not protected
by HIPAA but it is by state law as your
understanding right now
so my understanding is that in the event
that a minor has approached their mental
health provider and it's understood that
the conversation is confidential under
state law under HIPAA under
um maybe a waiver of confidentiality
then those medical records are protected
from the parent until the minor decides
to disclose them
representative Cushman did you have your
hand up earlier
um and thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question uh I'm thinking
about you were speaking to the chilling
effect that this might have on the
ability to have those prank
conversations with minors
um do you see that there may be also a
chilling effect on parents even bringing
their their children to a therapist to
seek treatment if they can't have you
know reasonable information you know
when they request it besides what's
Exempted under law already
um
I could see it both ways and thank you
for your question
um I think that in most instances as
have been has been mentioned parents are
typically included in mental health
treatment and are encouraged to be an
active participant whether that's you
know set limits with them coming into
treatment or something
um that's between the provider and the
parent and the child
um so I don't necessarily see that this
would have as much of a chilling effect
as it would on the child seeking
adequate mental health treatment
other questions
saying no other questions
okay thank you thank you
no one else has signed up to testify uh
testify on House Bill 406 has anyone
else wish to testify
seeing no one I'm going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 406 and
open the public hearing and House Bill
114 and recognize the prime sponsor
representative Bouchard
foreign
representative good morning
and thank you Mr chairman
and thank you
members of the
Health Human Services and elderly
Affairs committee for taking my
introduction and testimony to house bill
114.
I am representative Don Bouchard and I
represent Hillsboro District 24
Manchester's Ward 4.
House Bill 114 allows a minor 16 years
or older to consent to mental health
treatment without parental
or guiding consent
a new report trusted Source from the
centers of Disease Control and
prevention
shows that the teen suicide rate in the
United States has skyrocketed in recent
years
and when I may emailed you my testimony
you can
click on that and there's a link to that
report and suicide
was recently ranked as the second
leading cause of death for people
between the ages of 15 and 24 and the
data from that is from the population
reference Bureau and that also you can
link on to my
testimony
that I sent you
um the teen suicide rate
had been on a steady decline between
2000 and 2007.
then things picked up
and from 2007 to 2017
the teen suicide rate spiked by nearly
56 percent
the rate climbing from 6.8 deaths per
100 000 people to 10.6 according to the
CDC report
Hospital 114 will help
homeless use
who've lost contact with their parents
youth who feel shame embarrassment or
fear of disappointing their parents
use from immigrant families
whose parents are fearful of giving
consent
used from cultures
that don't condone Mental Health
Services
lesbian gay bisexual and transgender
transgender youths
requiring parental consent can force
these use into emotionally damaging and
or physically threatening situations
of coming out to their parents
prematurely
and without support
instead these use often wait until their
mental health condition becomes dire and
their safety is compromised by Suicide
substance abuse
or violence before seeking services
according to the Trevor Project
2022 National survey on LG ptq youth
Mental Health New Hampshire
39 percent
of lgbtq use in New Hampshire seriously
considered suicide in the past year
72 percent
experienced symptoms of anxiety
55 percent experience symptoms of
depression
52 percent who wanted mental health care
in the past year were not able to get it
and 37 percent did not want to get
parental guiding Guardian consent
House Bill 114 addresses the barriers of
parental consent as well as the needs of
all youths seeking mental health
treatment
this bill will not will not solve all
youth mental health issues however
it will add another tool to our youth
mental health toolbox
when
after my testimony when I because I am
going to have to leave after the
testimony because my committee is in in
session uh in an executive session
however I will give your clerk that
Trevor report a hard copy but I did give
you a Google doc on it also the
Nami research
and the other part is there was a
similar bill
uh
in the last session
house bill
1409 and Christina dies research
submitted
the data from the other states how they
handle this issue
so you should all have that but I will
give a a hard copy to the to the clerk
and thank you Mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee for taking
my testimon and I'll take questions okay
thank you yes representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman
um and thank you representative Bouchard
would you believe that this bill
might actually clarify and actually
limit the age at which people were able
to seek treatment
um
rather than create a new right if we
refer to um
Miss Dyer's research on RSA 135 C12 it
refers to the fact that any person
without giving an age can
can apply for treatment mental health
treatment
so
this would you believe that this might
actually limit the age from to 16 and
above and clarify a situation that's
really
um unclear
and furthermore would you believe that
when I tried to find out information
about this
um
in the in the past few years because
other bills have come up when I called
my Community Mental Health Center and
spoke to the CEO and I said what would
you do if a 17 year old in distress came
to seek mental health services without
the consent of their parents that they
said
we would call our attorney because they
didn't know what to do so that this
would so would you believe that this
would actually clarify a situation
that's very unclear presently
well thank you for the question and no I
did not
but that's
that's great
and representative Leon uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
for bringing this bill to us
um I recognize that there is a lot of
need to be able to go to somebody and
speak I'm curious if you would support
limiting this to non-directive
counseling where you'd be in an
encouraging atmosphere but not offering
advice interpretation or action to
direct the therapeutic process so that
these children can go into a safe
sounding area with a professional but
not necessarily be guided to any obvious
now obviously you're going to be guided
against suicide
because you're because that's one of
those issues but to not not end up in
any sort of guided therapy but just have
an opportunity to speak freely and
address their issues
now uh thank you for the question now
I'm not clear if I understand the
question that you're asking me uh
I I understand it please please do do
you intend for this to include any sort
of therapy where it goes into a specific
intention somebody sent coming in or do
you intend that it just provides an
opportunity for somebody to go talk with
a professional I'm just the the only
purpose of the bill is to give the
opportunity and that's it nothing else
thank you other questions
representative Weber
would you believe representative
Bouchard that I've just had a fairly
urgent request for you to return to
labor but it is which I wanted to bring
to your attention but it's your choice
as to whether you stay here and go there
oh
is that all right well
um we understand you have other
responsibilities but are there any other
questions just for the record uh
I'm seeing none so okay thank you thank
you representative thank you have a good
day you as well thank you
and and you said you had documents for
the clerk
also signed up to testify is Emma savini
from new futures
foreign
thank you for hearing our testimony on
this for the record my name is Emma
savini I am the children's Behavioral
Health policy coordinator at new Futures
new Futures is a nonpartisan non-profit
advocacy organization organization that
Advocates educates and collaborates with
the health and wellness of all Granite
Staters we are here in support of HBU
114 because it is clear that in our
state youth need access to mental health
treatment
um mental health is imperative in
ensuring the health of
um minors and then in the long term as
well
um when a minor is exhibiting symptoms
of a mental health uh challenge early
interventions are most effective and
most
um offer the best benefit for treatment
outcomes especially long term
if conditions are left untreated not
only is it detrimental to a child's
ability to
successfully participate in school
extracurricular Sports it will have
long-term negative effects for most of
their lives if not all of it allowing a
minor the ability to seek mental health
treatment when they need it without
necessarily needing to get a parental
consent
we'll give those children the
opportunity to get treatment early and
effectively
um as you heard at the last hearing it's
typical and most practitioners of mental
health treatment encourage parent
involvement so if a minor comes to them
without parental consent initially they
will likely encourage that child to
eventually Loop in the parent and
encourage a an open and honest lines of
communication between the child child
parent and the provider
um for those reasons new Futures urges
this committee to vote ought to pass on
this bill and I'm happy to take any
questions
thank you questions yes representative
Weber thank you I was interested in
exploring representative Shapiro's
question a little bit more
um
and I am wondering if
I'm wondering now if we pass this are we
perhaps for closing
the option
or a younger
but mature
person seeking
counseling or guidance
um I think I absolutely thank you for
your question
um rep Shapiro is definitely more of an
expert on Mental Health practice day to
day so I would have to do a little more
digging to determine exactly what the
current practice is
um and get you a more clear answer
for that so I'll get back to you
representative McLean
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so um we got this
awesome Memo from Christina Dyer which I
have not had an opportunity to fully
digest but it it states in the summary
section that a New Hampshire law
provides that any person can apply for
mental health services but it doesn't
specifically address the applicability
to minors so I guess my question is is
it needed or is it not needed so are you
aware has anybody come to you at new
Futures and says listen you know we're
looking for care we want to talk to
somebody but we have been expressly
denied that opportunity because of our
age as do you have any experience with
that so I haven't but I'm also not the
best person people would likely reach
out to on that issue just because we
don't provide direct service to folks so
um while I do know a lot of the services
that are available and I'm happy to
provide information to people who call
um typically they go to direct service
providers with those types of questions
all right thank you
other questions
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here my
question is similar to before would new
Futures support doing this for
non-directive counseling where it's just
limited to when they um when when the
minor is trying to get the handle on
what's going on and if anything becomes
more engaged that the parents would get
involved
um I would have to do a little bit more
research before I could get you a firm
answer on that okay thank you
other questions
any other questions
uh representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair thank you for the
question I wanted to follow up on
representative Weber's comment about the
downside if we put 16 in there
currently says any person could you by
any chance would you be willing to
survey the providers out there and find
out in their opinion it's just going to
become a problem for children or minors
if you will under the age of 16. if it's
only one percent is different but if
they're running into real concerns about
making the age limit at 12 having some
any person to 16. it does provide
Clarity but also the same time it does
sort of limit it to anybody below 16.
yeah absolutely I um would share that
concern if we're precluding minors from
getting mental health treatment so I'm
happy to
um as I said do some digging and try and
get some more clarity on that
representative Weber did you have your
hand up I did but I think I've
oh all set other questions
representative King
thank you chairman McDonald thank you
for taking questions
when I was 16 and 17 if I had you know
mental health problems and I needed to
go somewhere I have no idea where I
would have gone maybe the school
counselor or something like that
um assuming this were law where would a
16 or 17 year old go today to get mental
health treatment and
please list as many places that you know
of do the 16 and 17 year olds know of
these places and does this also include
Telehealth thank you
um I am not 16 or 17 and I think that
was maybe a compliment but I'm not
entirely sure
um what is going on in the minds of the
16 and 17 year olds I think similar to
you they'll reach out to the closest uh
person they have so maybe somebody at
the school
um maybe you know a friend has a
recommendation of a counselor they've
been seeing I know there are vast number
of resources out there I could list
dozens I don't know of 16 and 17 year
olds are aware of them of mental health
providers and communities community
behavioral health centers Telehealth
offerings those types of things
um
so I don't know what they're necessarily
in tune with what the what the kids are
doing these days but um I'm sure that
they would be able to reach out to a
trusted adult and get reliable resources
um through either their school a coach
somebody like that
other questions yes representative
Palazzo
thank you Mr Chen thank you for taking
my question what's your understanding of
the scope of
mental health practice as I discovered
here would it include some medications
with possible side effects like
antidepressants
or would it possibly include in the
future
like medical marijuana for different
anxieties
or is it simply a
um non non-pharmaceutical
so um again I left my bill back at my
seat but I believe it requires that um a
parental involvement if medication is on
the table to be discussed the bill the
bill EX
IST and that would include I assume any
medications including medical marijuana
representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
I'm I'm just a question about current
state law and how this will address that
but use the word trusted adult
see a lot of kids that are brought in by
somebody other than their parent for
very specific reasons what is the
current law and how does this affect
that is about the ability of a trusted
adult
um to
give consent or whatever so um I don't
think a trusted adult is able to give
consent on behalf of a minor if the
minor is able to give consent on their
own behalf they're able to receive
treatment if it's a medical procedure in
which a parent needs to give or a
guardian needs to give consent they
would have to give consent I don't think
there's any law that allows just you
know a trusted family friend to give
consent
other questions other questions
any other questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you
also signed up to speak is Sam Hawkins
from Nami of New Hampshire
thank you again for the opportunity to
testify
uh my name is Sam Hawkins I'm the public
policy assistant in Nami New Hampshire
here today on behalf of Nami to speak in
support of hb114
. so over the past decade already high
suicide rates have been rising in the
new in the United States and New
Hampshire according to health Affairs
between 2007 and 2018 suicide increased
57.4 percent in 10 to 24 year olds in
one survey of high school students one
in three youth reported persistent
feelings of sadness or hopelessness and
one in five had seriously considered
suicide
more precisely 2019 New Hampshire data
indicated that 18.8 percent of high
school students seriously considered
suicide and 8.9 percent attempted it in
New Hampshire suicide is the second
leading cause of death for individuals
ages 10 to 24.
we need to look at new ways to address
our youth Mental Health crisis and
reduce barriers to care
this bill is one important measure in
doing so
many factors impact an individual's
willingness to seek care for their
mental health concerns over personal
privacy social stigma and the fear of
rejection have the potential to leave
someone struggling alone and in silence
for teenagers these possible
consequences can seem even more
intimidating and without care their
mental well-being will likely continue
to decline towards crisis
the prime sponsor already spoke to uh
the statistics for lgbtq individuals but
I'll just quickly restate that within
that population 52 percent wanted mental
health care but were not able to receive
it and of those 37 reported that this
was due to not wanting to have to get
their parent or caregivers permission
again we do believe that familial
support and involvement can make a huge
positive impact on treatment and our
experienced providers will focus on
helping a child get to a point where
they feel comfortable reaching out to
their parent or Guardian but for those
miners who who would be unsafe
disclosing their condition or just feel
more comfortable talking out the initial
steps towards treatment private
privately access to care without
parental consent is crucial and could be
potentially life-saving
for these reasons Nami New Hampshire
urges the committee to recommend ought
to pass for hb-114
. thank you questions
representative McLean
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I'm really looking at
this 37 number
um and that's a that's a that's a pretty
big number so I just kind of want to
understand that a little bit
um was that 37 people that didn't even
ask because they thought they would not
get it or is it 37 that they had
actually sought those services and they
said no you're too young and we cannot
give it to you without the parental
consent was it a perception or was it a
reality is I guess my question all right
thank you for your question so yes it's
that that 52 of lgbtq individuals and
then within the report breaks it down uh
reasons why they they did not seek or
did not get treatment I believe the
prime sponsor said he'd be getting you
that report this was one of those items
um and that is 37 of that 52 uh I do
believe this specific Factor would just
include them not even trying to seek
treatment but I'm not sure sure about
the other factors yeah
follow up thank you Mr chair so again to
kind of follow on representative Weber's
and representative Merchants questions I
don't want to kind of cut stuff off so
um are you aware of situations where
service was actively denied because of
someone's age because it's not explicit
in current law
uh I'm not currently aware of any
specific situations but that's uh I I'm
not a provider so yeah
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
um I would like to know if Nami would be
in support of um limiting this to
non-directive counseling where there's
not an outcome with a specific carve out
for suicide self-harm um those types of
dangerous behaviors where obviously
you'd want to cancel against that right
now thank you for your question right
now we believe the current limitation of
the uh um did not prescribing medication
without parental consent uh is where
we're comfortable I don't think we would
want to limit it further
okay thank you
other questions
follow up um sorry I'd be interested in
knowing what types of directive
counseling that you would want to
specifically authorize without parental
consent so even if that's a follow-up
I'd love to get that information from it
that would absolutely be a follow-up
yeah thank you
any other questions
I'm seeing no other questions
okay thank you sir thank you
also signed up to speak this morning is
Jennifer Smith from Pembroke
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee
um
I'm here to speak in support but with a
reservation about this question of what
age and whether it's appropriate to set
it at 16.
um I think
most kids by the time they are in
puberty
which is often before that
and in the pressures of Middle School
are already if they're going to struggle
with things like I have struggled with
are struggling with it so that's why I
asked say that
I'm transgender
I took another few decades past 16 to
get to really understand that
and I want to just comment to
representative Leon's question that I
think directive counseling is an
oxymoron
so I don't think you need to have that
kind of language
um
counseling should be non-directive I
know my first
decent counselor in my early 40s when I
finally recognized I really needed to
have counseling instead of trying to
work it out by myself
was completely non-directive
when I went specifically to a gender
counselor I think she was also
non-directive
but the opportunity to seek that care
was vital
I'm also a retired primary care doctor
and so these legal questions are
important and I hope you take the time
to really work them out and what the age
lower limit might be I'm not sure I know
the answer to that but I know when I saw
a child
adolescent or just pre-adolescent with
their parents I made it clear to parents
that if something was brought to me that
the child wanted kept confidential I
would do that
and if you didn't like that you needed
to seek a different position
so and I don't think I ever had anybody
who said that they objected to that but
that may be
the kind of people that I took care of
so
I I do think it's incredibly important
that we not allow barriers to be erected
to lgbtq youth or anyone else for that
matter whose cultural background
is really a conflict with who they feel
they need to be
and that's that's pretty uh wide group
of people and I I appreciate the mention
about immigrants I'm very involved in
support of immigrant communities
and I know this to be really difficult
I also have done working
Latin America and Africa
and I know that attitudes where people
come from in those places are severely
worse than in most places in this
country
and so trying to allow people not to
get to the point that they are suicidal
is just incredibly important so please
take the time you need on this bill and
I prefer a much lower age than 16. thank
you okay I will take questions yes
uh representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um I'm just wondering do you see any
concern with a parent not knowing that
their child is in a private room with an
adult
of course that's always an issue when
like my faith community we have a very
explicit policy for child safety
and there's always at least two people
out of our worship with the children
um and I think that's that is
extraordinarily important
I hope that we don't have too many cases
anywhere of counselors who take
advantage
um that has happened obviously and
that's a an issue that's not
non-directive counseling that's for sure
and so it's a you know illegal unethical
immoral kind of activity you're speaking
about so follow-up representative
Cushman
thank you
um just uh what would you think if we
required to have two people in the room
since that seems like a good way to keep
the kids safe during that wow I don't
know the a good answer to that obviously
um since I presented this mail
throughout my career
I I always
except for extreme older age with women
who prefer or not bring a nurse in I
always had a nurse come in for anything
that was even vaguely intimate
a female nurse that
thank you representative McKay
would you be willing to tell us a little
bit about your professional background I
I'm a family practitioner
other questions
any other questions
seeing none thank you thank you
also signed up to testify is William
Rogers from Winchester
thank you Mr chairman I apologize to the
committee I'm way out of my league here
and I'm nervous as anything I've heard
all the phds and doctors and stuff but
I'm just a parent and a grandparent and
it would seem to me I've heard the word
uh Team suicide is up it's up it's up we
need to get them into counseling and
stuff it would seem to me that would
make common sense that if a child that
age who we know is very confused it's a
rough aid for any kid to be at it would
seem to me the health professionals
would want more than anything
more than anything to have the parents
involved
so it would see so this seems
counterintuitive to me why would you
want to do it without the parents
consent
the parents would have a right to know
not a need to know the parents are the
ones most likely to help that child
reach the correct decision
and I I would not bring this up but I've
heard three of the people tests and by
the way I'm opposed to this bill I'm
sorry I'm not used to this I guess
you're supposed to say that first
but I've heard three of the people who
were for this bill testify and bring up
the
the the
lgbtq and frankly a lot of parents are
very frightened of of
what
it's one thing to how do I put it's one
thing if a child is honestly feeling
confused and gender confused and stuff
and people they talk about it or
whatever but it definitely seems and I
know a lot of parents feel that this is
being pushed being pushed and so maybe
I'm crazy but it seems to me like this
bill is trying to hide what's going on
from the parents so I think that's all I
have to say thank you okay you taking
questions sir are you all set well if I
don't I don't know anything so but you
can ask okay okay thank you uh
representative King
thank you chairman McDonald thank you
for speaking today
um
if I had to take a guess if I had to
take a guess I'm just making an
assumption you probably see you and
probably your wife as pretty good
parents and you probably had pretty good
parents yourself yes
um but no no no no no okay well then
that's a incorrect incorrect assumption
of my part but
um troubled childhood I was very blessed
to have wonderful parents but you know
some of my some of my friends they had
terrible parents really terrible parents
and
um the only reason that I could see that
a 16 or 17 year old would go to get
mental health counseling without the
knowledge of their parents is if there's
a serious issue between them and their
parents and
um does that concern I mean what about
the kids who who have really awful
parents and and they need somebody I
mean what are your thoughts on that
thank you I could certainly see that and
that's certainly that may have been the
case even I had a very very rough
childhood because of
rough parenting
um
but
of course of course the parents might be
the problem if it's an abusive or
something but
is shouldn't there be
us shouldn't it be some way where an
impartial third party here's what's
going on
and then make a determination yes this
we should go forward with mental health
treatment for this child without parents
consent or no there's really no reason
to let's get the parents involved I can
certainly see that but
but again the fear is
is that there is a push
to to transition our children I don't
know how to say it without saying it
thank you the other representative King
you do
foreign
oh it's okay
can you tell I'm not comfortable and
want to get out of here at least out of
this seat I'm sorry the point of point
of order oh yes representative Cushman
it
um and thank you for obliging
um but can we just make it clear that
they don't have to answer questions
right you don't you're not obligated no
no that's why I asked you if you wanted
any questions no no I'm I'm perfectly
happy to but okay
thank you Mr chairman and also
um thank you Mr Rogers and
um I wanted to reassure you that you're
doing a great thing as a parent coming
here and uh and and saying what you said
um and also uh I also want you to know
that being one of the
non-doctors and non-nurses on this
committee I'm also intimidated
so thank you for coming out today my
questions along the same lines of the
other representative Seth King and
um and I
there are a lot of bad parents out there
that don't know how to deal with this
and my question to you is how how do we
uh inform parents how do we uh I don't
know if it's a community or whatever but
how how could you get involved in your
community to to inform parents on the
right way to uh to approach this
thank you bye
that's that's that's out there I don't
know that I have the expertise
to even get involved but
again
I don't I don't know I'm sorry
it's a good question and that I'm
supposed to say thank you for that
question
and it's a good question but
yeah I just want to say it's an
opportunity out there and I don't know
if Mr Hawkins is still here but you may
want to talk to somebody from Nami and
um and that might help that may be a way
to go is you know again the third party
thing is is let someone who has no
um
it you know I don't know what no chicken
in the fight or something no no no ax to
grind No Agenda
that they might help be help maybe we
have a community board that
if that comes up a professional can go
to the board and lay out the facts and
hear everything in the board make that
determination although that seems
counterintuitive because we've got way
too many boards and way too many rules
and way too many laws already so hey
thank you Mr I'm going to sit here all
right are there any other questions
I see none so thank you thank you
I have no one else signed up to testify
on HP 114 does anyone else wish to
testify on HB 114
seeing none I'm going to close the
public hearing on HP 114 and open the
public hearing on HB 575 FN and
recognize the prime sponsor
representative Phillips
mining representative Phillips good
morning
thank you to the committee for hearing
me today
my name is Emily Phillips I represent
Rockingham district 7 the town of
Fremont
um I support science I support clinical
human trials for Innovation I have
participated in several clinical trials
since being diagnosed with type 1
diabetes in 2001. I know the importance
and time involved in obtaining real
informed consent
this legislation is not anti-vaccine I
am not an anti-vaxxer
I just completed a five-year clinical
trial at MGH that tested a vaccine as a
therapeutic to reverse and improve the
management of type 1 diabetes
they began enrolling patients years
before I joined but due to my plan to
expand my own family I chose to delay my
participation until 2017.
I was given this 18-page document
explaining the risks benefits and
expectations of a participant and what
the responsibility and liability the
researchers had by conducting the trial
all participants in the lead researchers
sign these informed consent agreements
in my personal Research into this I read
the data from the trials conducted on
mice
and the previous 100-year human use of
this particular vaccine before making my
decision to move forward I volunteered
for an experiment knowing my risks and
reward potential
just as I have done times before because
I believe in science I know data must be
collected to improve Innovation and
advancements in Medical Treatments HB
575 would prohibit the state of New
Hampshire from purchasing promoting or
Distributing vaccine or pharmaceutical
products that have not completed human
clinical trials the Bible and boosters
were heavily promoted advertised and
purchased after only being tested on
mice
that is all the testing done before
being approved under the emergency use
authorization and being made available
for distribution the Bible and boosters
were expedited through FDA to meet a
delivery date of Labor Day in 2022 to
Target the ba 0.4 and ba 0.5 Omicron
sub-variants
and as well as the original strain of
covid I believe citizens have
unknowingly been enrolled in a clinical
trial they have not been able to give
informed consent to
according to the press release on August
31st 2022 on fda.gov the fact sheets for
both bivalent covid-19 vaccines for
recipients caregivers and for health
care providers include information about
potential side effects as well as the
risk of myocarditis and pericarditis
early last month the FDA and CDC
uncovered a possible safety issue for
individuals over age 65 that showed they
were more likely to suffer in ischemic
stroke 21 days after receiving the
Pfizer biontech violent shot compared
with days 22 through 44. according to
openvares.com the Under reporting of
adverse reactions is significant
but the submissions for covid-19
injection in New Hampshire are over 4450
as of data through February 3rd this
includes 91 deaths in New Hampshire and
113 permanently disabled individuals
although theirs is not designed to
determine if a vaccine caused a health
problems problem it is useful for
recognizing patterns of Adverse Events
that may indicate a possible safety
problem additionally in October the New
England Journal of Medicine has
published the results of studies
examining levels of neutralizing anti
antibodies against ba 0.4 and ba 0.5
after receipt of the monovalent and
bivalent booster dose they found no
significant difference in neutralization
of any SARS cov2 variant including the
ba 0.4 and B 8.5 between the two groups
neither research Group found the Bible
in boosters to elicit Superior immune
response on November 22nd the CDC
published data on the effectiveness of
the ba 0.4 and B 8.5 mRNA vaccines for
preventing symptomatic infection within
two months after receipt of the booster
dose for people who had received the
monovalent vaccine two to three months
earlier the Extra Protection associated
with the bivalent booster range from 28
to 31 percent
I would not suggest we limit a private
Pharmacy hospital or Provider from
choosing to distribute any products for
clinical trial the this legislation does
not limit their ability to do that
according to my inquiries with DHHS
pharmacies participating in the federal
Retail Pharmacy partnership program
places orders through a Supply Chain
management system independent of the
state
they also received direct shipments from
manufacturers without passing through
the state this is a federal program
where retail pharmacies vaccinate in
long-term care settings however in cases
where quantities did not meet the Direct
ship threshold the vaccine was
distributed by the state after September
6th after taking into consideration the
needs of the vaccinating provider
this would stop the spending of taxpayer
funds on Advertising dispensing and
purchasing of products or vaccines that
have not been tested
through human clinical trials the people
of New Hampshire deserve the opportunity
to give informed consent
thank you questions
representative Coachman thank you Mr
chairman
thank you for bringing this bill forward
um what would be the consequences of
skipping human clinical trials in a drug
development do you have any background
on that
death
I mean so like
phase of clinical one of human trials is
phase one and that determines whether or
not it will it will kill a human subject
So I entered phase two by the way
other questions yes representative Weber
wouldn't we by passing this legislation
be interfering severely with the rights
of those of us who uh during the
pandemic and understanding just as you
understood the risks and made a decision
for yourself
uh wouldn't it be interfering with the
rights of those of us who
um
knew the lack of knowledge
and chose very willingly to accept the
vaccines
aren't you interfering in the other
direction
no because the private you know
pharmacies providers could still
distribute it if they want I still want
the state advertising or paying for it
follow up
but isn't it true that in the case of
the pandemic if it had not been paid for
by the state it would not have been
manufactured or available
so the federal government bought the
vaccines and then distributed them to
state so I don't agree with that but the
state did pay to advertise it and I mean
they they may speak on it to say that it
came from federal grants
um so like there is no fiscal note on
this which I'm surprised because if they
stop doing it they must be getting it
from federal grants so I'm sorry I
forgot the original question I was
the point of my original question was my
concern would be that if this were in
place
uh
no matter whose dollars they were
the drug would not have been
manufactured in the quantities it was or
made available to the many many people
who very much wanted it despite the lack
of knowledge
uh if federal dollars had not been
involved because the drug simply
wouldn't have been manufactured if you
had to wait until after somebody was
ready
until there wouldn't have been the
demand and
the payment in advance for the
manufacturing
I'm not
I'm not sorry I don't know the answer to
your question okay thank you though
representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question
um I heard you to say that you were not
um against the vaccines per se but
rather that
um that you felt they were rushed
through without the proper testing on
um
on human beings but at the same time a
lot of your testimony was talking about
how detrimental the vaccines were
as someone who took every vaccine I
could get and who believes in the
vaccines and who believes they've been
extremely helpful I would have to say I
agree with you that this was rushed
through
and that there was not um
as much research and as much testing as
all of us would have liked
um but it was an emergency a million
Americans died
and um I wonder at what point you might
have thought that it does make sense for
vaccines to be used without the
um
optimal amount of testing I mean what if
covid-19 had killed people at twice the
rate or three times the rate
um
would then it have made sense to
um go forward without the optimal amount
of testing
I believe in informed consent and I do
believe that Granite State or
specifically have taken this thinking it
was safer or further tested than it was
and I think we're finding out now that
it's maybe not as effective as they
touted in the beginning or they thought
it to be and that it might be dangerous
which is why I read those those pieces
of information
um I'm not like I said I did a five-year
trial and I participated in it because I
thought it could improve an outcome that
I personally was from a chronic illness
so I think that people can still
participate in these trials or like you
said in an emergency but what
there are people who are mandated to
take this as well that's a whole nother
we don't want to go down that road but
they had to take it to keep their job
right and so people will say you have
choice you could just not have a job but
you know there's I think that the state
should get out of the business of of
enrolling our citizens into a clinical
trial which is what this was emergency
or not
follow
I'll just ask you again can you conceive
of any emergency that might have been
more intense or the rate of fatalities
larger where
it would have shortcuts would have been
okay
I believe that the covid-19 virus was
was deadly to some groups I do I so I
believe that maybe the emergency youth
of this vaccine
might have been more
appropriately geared towards older
populations in the beginning I'm not
sure if I agree with that now I'm I'm
just it's I'm not a doctor I just think
what happened is not being transparent
and I think informed consent is a very
important step and I don't think we had
that I think it was very rushed and I
don't understand why the state is
involved in this
thank you representative Merchant and
representative Cushman
thank you Miss Mr chairman and also
thank you for taking the question
representative
I'm concerned about creating a two-tier
system
so if I have private insurance
I can take the ability to opt in and get
the vaccine however from covered by a
state-funded program I don't have that
right so therefore you're taking my
rights away from me
I mean they say this vaccine is free
they don't charge the the federal
government paid for this taxpayers paid
for this follow-up sure follow up I
guess the question is that if the state
is paying for it and I'm covered through
a policy insurance policy funded by
public dollars
I don't have the same rights as somebody
else who has private insurance
and that's basically taken my rights
away from me
and I don't believe in the state we want
to take people's rights away you can opt
in or opt out so therefore if the
state's not paying for it I pay for it
on my pocket you're taking my rights
away from me are you not
I don't I don't believe that any
insurance Medicaid or otherwise paid for
doses of vaccine
is that your question
no because the question I'm trying to
get to is that if you boil it down to
the state regardless of how it was
funded by the federal government of the
state government
if I'm under a state policy that's
funded by the state
my rights as an individual are being
denied
versus if I have commercial payer on my
own insurance policy that right's not
taken away I still have it so I see this
is basically interfering with someone's
rights based upon the payment method
that's in place
I could be wrong obviously but I think
that once if the vaccine become
commercialized down the road and then
they start charging insurances maybe
that might apply but as of right now
we're still under this emergency use
so maybe I can listen you're still
you're still denying me my rights that's
what I'm trying to get to to elect the
vaccine yes because if someone doesn't
pay for it through Medicaid or through
the state program and so forth because
you're talking about the purchase of it
or payment of it my right has been
denied because I would have to pay for
it out of my own pocket and sometimes I
can't
I hope we have an expert who can clarify
that because I I don't believe you're
asked to pay for the covid-19 vaccine
when you go to Rite Aid
to get it or provide insurance I don't
believe that if this doesn't cover
strictly covet it covers any vaccine
down the in the future
same thing
I'll look into it I don't I don't I'm
sorry I don't have the answer
representative Cushman and then
representative farmer
thank you Mr chairman
um first a clarifying question and then
if I could have a follow-up okay
um is it it's just the boosters that
didn't have human clinical trials
correct correct okay and um so
my understanding is
that the federal government paid for
this through the emergency use
authorization act and
then the states received the vaccine the
state of New Hampshire did not pay for
it that itself
that's my understanding correct thank
you
representative Parma then representative
McLean
so I have a sort of two part one is to
follow up on uh representative Shapiro
which is so Ebola has about a 50
fatality rate
um would that you know exceed your
threshold for like okay whatever we can
do we're gonna do
um the other thing is if if this is more
an issue of consent should the law
should this bill be about the state
offering informed consent before any
vaccine that fits the parameters you're
talking about rather than just Banning
the state from doing it
let's start with your second question so
part of informed consent I think we're
familiar that these vaccines came with
blank inserts so there was no
information for the provider let alone
the patient to really see the insert on
what was even in it so I don't think
there was an opportunity for that your
first part about ebola I believe they've
done human clinical trials on the Ebola
vaccine maybe is there a new strain like
I'm just asking for that to be tested on
humans before the state gets involved
with Distributing it
so my example of Ebola was not so much
whether or not there's a vaccine there
but the fatality rate was so high that
you in in let's just say it's a new a
new a new pandemic with that kind of
rate
um I wouldn't want to see a barrier to
treatment because that would be
obviously incredibly devastating
um I believe that to improve treatment
you have to try medicine and have trials
so
I think that there's a divide here in
general that vaccines are
um without concern to some and that
there's no big deal but there are real
vaccine injuries so I think that taking
a vaccine just in case it might have a
beneficial
um component to a deadly disease or not
that's not something that some people
are willing to do or want to do or the
state should be involved in
okay representative McLean thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
um you know so absent uh a compelling uh
State need which is a very high
constitutional buyer
um I believe every person every citizen
whatever should have the right to do
their own risk benefit analysis with
respect to a drug so for example
um if the zombie apocalypse was to come
and they said well we don't have this
vaccine tested on humans I would do my
risk benefit analysis and probably say
I'm going to take that vaccine because I
don't want to be a zombie but I think
the the the bigger concern I had for me
specifically coming out of this pandemic
was the fact that it was very hard to do
that risk benefit analysis because it
was very you know what's real what's not
real and I know that many of my
colleagues put up peer-reviewed studies
out of Europe that were prompt taken
down and so that for me was the bigger
problem was just that it was hard what
is real what is not real what is
misinformation what is not and I see the
the promote the States involvement in
promoting the vaccine as kind of kind of
damping down on some of that debate so
would you be open to amending the
legislation to just removing the
promoting part
um I think in representative Merchant's
point is well taken if we want to
get this out as quickly as possible
maybe there needs to be some State
involvement but I think everybody should
have the right to have an informed risk
benefit analysis and so I I I would be
open to looking at it but just taking
out that promotion part so what are your
thoughts on that
so you want to ban the state from
Distributing it or purchasing it or you
you just want to keep the promoting part
no I I think
especially in an emergency like the
zombie apocalypse if you want to get
something out quickly the state may be
the most effective way to do that and so
I don't necessarily want to take that
you know out of the equation my bare
concern as I said people should be able
to do their own risk benefit analysis
and so when the state actively gets into
promoting one side of it that's where I
think in this pandemic I I saw them go a
little bit over the line and so I would
be comfortable taking out the promoting
part but I think the other elements of
the state they have a role so I just
wanted to get your thoughts on that
what I'm hearing is that you want to
keep the promoting
keep the Banning of promoting promoting
it yes yes
I think that's the most important part
because I agree with you if you're if
you're getting all your information from
the government and in the age of
censorship we're not getting like you
said access to peer-reviewed studies and
whatnot I mean it's it's within the
committee's hands to amend it as they
see fit um so I think there's
improvements in many different areas so
thank you representative Leon thank you
Mr chairman and thank you representative
my question comes to the idea of
informed consent and our lack of human
data my question is if you would be
um what you think about the idea of if
the state is purchasing and distributing
a product that has not been fully tested
and especially one where the data can no
longer be collected because a crossover
effect if the state could instead have a
registry program that allows people to
either opt-in or opt out and be
essentially blinded to the world so that
we can actually get some data so that
those who want to participate in in a
actual clinical research for the benefit
of themselves get that and then we avoid
the moral issues of having somebody in
the control group if they would rather
have the treatment what do you think
about that
normally I'm against Registries but
um yeah that's an opportunity for
somebody to willingly opt in uh because
you're right that clinical trial I keep
saying that it's not it's not actually
happening anymore because nobody's
collecting the data and it's completely
muddied the water so yeah I mean I'm I'd
be interested in hearing more about it
thank you representative Seth King thank
you chairman McDonald and thank you for
being here today
isn't it true that there is a massive
financial interest on behard on behalf
of the pharmaceutical companies to get
the government to subsidize their the
purchasing of their product for every
citizen in this country and isn't it
true that the pharmaceutical companies
made ungodly amounts of money from this
pandemic and doesn't that create a moral
hazard thank you
yes
representative
thank you Mr Chen thank you for taking
my question uh help me understand how
this legislation uh Falls uh into
current uh legal framework and um I'm
kind of surprised by some questions
because my understanding we are already
deny uh freedom of people when it
comes to be financed for some harmful
uh drugs or be financed for some drugs
that were not
scientifically proven to be helpful so
and we already have regulations that
medication need to be
tested including
those steps that you outline
in this legislation
so that fact that
boosters did not have the human trial
how does it fall with current
legislation was was some lost break we
can buy that or did we actually need
this new legislation to fix this
situation thank you
I'm probably not the best person to
answer the legality of what happened but
I think because it's under emergency use
authorization what happened obviously
it's unprecedented at least in my
lifetime so um for this to happen but uh
we do have hopefully someone who can
hear who could answer this question more
accurately
um
I don't
I guess I don't have any more things to
say about your question I'm sorry thank
you all the questions
seeing no other questions thank you
also signed up to speak today is a Orion
tannian and Dr Benjamin Tran Benjamin
Chan from the Department of Health and
Human Services
morning gentlemen uh you indicate you
need five plus minutes is that combined
or or
uh we'll try to keep it tonight five
plus minutes for the two of you is fine
yeah right
good morning chairman uh McDonald and
members of the committee my name is Ryan
Tanny and I am a registered pharmacist
in the state of New Hampshire and I'm
also the chief of the Bureau of
Infectious Disease Control at the
Department of Health and Human Services
Division I'm having a little trouble
hearing if you could move the microphone
up absolutely sure
try
so uh I'm also joined today by Dr
Benjamin Chan and infectious disease
physician in the New Hampshire State
epidemiologist and we're here today to
speak in opposition to house bill 575.
to begin the wording of this proposed
legislation could I just ask if you put
it right in front
of them sideways they're very
directional they don't they don't pick
up anything from any other side perfect
so we believe the wording of the
proposed legislation is both vague in
its intent and it's unclear we also
believe that there's insufficient
insufficient detail to know the intent
behind requiring human or voluntary
clinical trials there are different
types of clinical trials some that study
safety some that study Effectiveness and
then others that actually do both and
then there's also different methods to
measure effectiveness of vaccines and
pharmaceutical products
so we also believe that uh there this
was brought forth due to concerns
related to the covid-19 bivalent vaccine
formulations
um however this did follow a similar
process to our annual influenza
vaccinations so a comprehensive
collection of this data in the covid-19
vaccine safety and Effectiveness studies
they were reviewed by the FDA and CDC
prior to their release in September of
and this did include human clinical
trials of the previous monovalent
vaccine formulations human clinical
trials of different bivalent vaccine
formulations including beta variant
bivalent vaccines and the ba.1 bivalent
vaccines
this comprehensive collection of data
was also summarized in a New Hampshire
science brief that was also published in
September of 2022.
and then additionally we are unable to
identify the intent or reason for the
use of the word voluntary as federal law
21 CFR section 50.20 prohibits the use
of involuntary human subjects in
clinical trials as that is considered
unethical
so because covid-19 vaccines followed a
process similar to our annual influenza
vaccines
if House Bill 575 is enacted it is
likely that the department and our
partners would be unable to purchase
promote or distribute the annual
influenza vaccine and this could
negatively impact patients and staff
that are in our County nursing homes and
Correctional Facilities those at the New
Hampshire hospital Glencliff home and
our veterans at the New Hampshire State
Veterans Home in Tilton
as well as the Manchester and Nashua
Public Health departments and this is
contrary to the mission of not only
these individual organizations but the
department as well
also depending on how House Bill 575 is
interpreted in cases where child and
adult vaccines are periodically updated
without a new clinical trial this may
impact our ability to purchase and
distribute other vaccines that prevent
life-threatening bacterial infections
and an example of this would be the
pneumococcal vaccine
so we also believe that there would be
unintended consequences for our state
vaccine for children program which
allows us to purchase vaccines on a
federal contract at a discounted rate
so without this program New Hampshire
providers would be forced to purchase
the vaccine commercially resulting in
higher costs to the health system
and then although covid-19 was the
leading cause of death by infections and
respiratory illnesses in children the
department continues to make the
statement that we do not intend to make
Cova 19 or influenza vaccinations a
requirement for school or Child Care
attendance
and then lastly an additional
consequence of House Bill 575 is the
potential negative effect it could have
on the FDA provision known as expanded
access which this is also known as
Compassionate Care
so Compassionate Care is a mechanism
where patients with serious or
immediately life-threatening diseases
and conditions have access to medical
products to include biologics vaccines
and other pharmaceutical products which
are outside the scope of the clinical
trial for which it was designed after
they meet certain and strict criteria so
these products are undergoing a clinical
trial but in Desperate situations and
under the compassionate use provision
there's usually no other alternative
therapy that's available
and then this would this is most often
seen in patients with conditions such as
ALS muscular dystrophy or certain types
of cancer
so in summary we are opposed to House
Bill 575 as we believe the language to
be vague and the intent is unclear
there's also a robust Federal regulatory
process to assess vaccine and
pharmaceutical product and safety as
well as Effectiveness and we believe
that this will result in several
unintended consequences and it would
decrease the access to life-saving
vaccines Therapeutics and lead to an
increased cost for health care
and we will also be submitting written
testimony after we stay and answer any
questions that the committee may have
thank you thank you Dr Chan
can you hear me okay I can great Mr
chair Madam Vice chair members of the
committee thank you so much for um
taking our testimony today on how spill
575 I don't want to take a lot of extra
time as Dr tanian just mentioned we will
be submitting testimony on this but we
have a number of concerns around this
legislation what I heard from the
sponsor was primarily concern about the
covid-19 bivalent formulation of the
vaccine and I think I'm happy and we're
happy to discuss this the concerns
further and take questions during the
during the Q a
um but do want to just summarize and
highlight that the wording in this bill
is very Broad
um and so that will have likely
um a number of unintended consequences
on our ability to promote purchase
distribute uh other Therapeutics not
just vaccines but certainly vaccines are
included in this and I think Dr tanyan
highlighted the potential impact on
influenza vaccine I will say that the
annual updated influenza vaccine every
year that is well studied and has proven
safety
that goes through a similar process by
which the FDA transitioned to the
bivalent vaccines rolling out every year
and so but it's it's unclear what is
intended in the legislation by clinical
trials but if the intent is to stop what
happened with rollout of the bivalent
covid-19 vaccine that likely will also
have implications on our ability to
promote distribute purchase other
vaccines like the influenza vaccine
which doesn't undergo full human
clinical trials every year before it is
updated and distributed so I do want to
try and sort of separate you know the
the issues in the wording of the current
legislation versus the concern from the
Copa 19 bivalent vaccine
um but let me stop there because I know
that we're over time but we're happy to
take questions and expand on it on any
of those points thank you all right
thank you representative Shapiro
and thank you for taking this question
um you know one of the concerns only one
of the concerns addressed in the bill
and addressed by the sponsor was about
informed consent and um you know when I
got my first vaccines I
drove it was a drive-by with a National
Guards person giving me a shot
so my question to you is
leaving aside some of the other problems
in this legislation can do you have
ideas about how New Hampshire
in the future could have a more robust
informed consent process maybe maybe if
I can I'll start by answering and see if
Dr tanyan has any other comments
informed consent happens
between a healthcare provider and the
patient that's receiving the vaccine
from that health care provider
so in most of the situations that are
being discussed it's not actually
appropriate for the Department to obtain
informed consent because we're not
administering the vaccine to the patient
we're not serving as the medical
provider if you will to the patient
receiving the vaccine now there were
situations during the covid-19 pandemic
where that did happen as you mentioned
the National Guard run Coba 19 Community
vaccination clinics were done under
medical direction from the Department of
Health and Human Services
there were networks that are Regional
public health networks were out doing
targeted kova 19 vaccination clinics to
for example nursing homes and long-term
care facilities and in those situations
where we had to stand up those types of
mass vaccination clinics those Community
vaccination clinics the the department
does in emergencies step into the role
of serving as that health care provider
but that's that's really sort of the
rare exception and when we do that
we go to Great Lengths to make sure that
there is informed consent and there's a
whole team teams of people and a whole
process by which we do that there was I
think a 50 to 60 page protocol which
clinics were required to operate under
um documents that people were required
to sign you know parents that were um
you know attending clinics with their
children to sign informed consents but
when we talk about how the routine
delivery of medications and vaccines
occurs
um the majority of the time outside of
an emergency it's not the department or
state government getting informed
consent it's informed consent and that
situation happens between
a provider and the patient in that
clinical interaction
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman I have two questions one of
which is very quick I'm hopeful that I
could we could get a list of those
vaccines and Therapeutics that would be
at risk from this legislation obviously
it won't be complete but you already
have a good number of them and now my
actual real question is around informed
consent and there's someone
misunderstanding about whether it's a
provider-based informed consent in New
Hampshire or a patient based and I'm
curious as to whether you and the
department would support for the future
legislation to make it clear that
informed consent is based upon that
individual that patient or their parent
understanding the risks and benefits and
making it clear that any any outside
force including a risk of losing a job
invalidates that consent because that
actually is compelling use
so maybe I'll respond to your second
question first
um
the and I'm sorry that was a complex
question so I I may not be fully um
understanding it
um but I do want to point out that the
the reference earlier to human clinical
trials and informed consent for studying
vaccines is a very different situation
and a very different process uh from a
patient coming into the health care
setting and choosing to get
a vaccine a medication a colonoscopy
cancer screening Etc and there are
currently medical processes and
standards already established by which
that occurs you know by which informed
consent occurs between a provider and a
patient so I I'm not sure that I'm that
we're maybe the best
Department to address or answer that
question
um but responding to your first question
um I we don't have a full list of
potential impacts of this legislation in
terms of Therapeutics and vaccines and
partly that's because the intent of it
isn't clear and it's not clear what's
meant by you know requiring human
clinical trials as Dr tanyon said you
know there's different types of clinical
trials are we talking about you know
randomized double-blinded
placebo-controlled clinical trials we're
talking about observational clinical
trials we're talking about trials that
are focused and required to report out
on vaccine efficacy or clinical trials
looking at immune response or clinical
trials looking at safety there's a whole
as I'm sure you're you're aware um
Madame Vice chair there's a whole range
of uh clinical trials and so there's
it's very hard to know how this
legislation will impact that range of
Therapeutics what I can say and what I
what I alluded to was the fact that
there are vaccines that undergo periodic
updates and those are the vaccines in
particular that I would have most
concern about so we saw that of course
with the kova 19 bivalent vaccine where
the strain was updated we referenced the
influenza vaccine where the influenza
vaccine gets updated every year the
formulation doesn't change but there's a
tweak to the strain of virus that's
covered so it's not really a new vaccine
it's an update or a tweak to an existing
vaccine but this also occurs in some of
for example the pneumococcal vaccines
Pneumovax prevnar
for some brand names where over time
there are additional
um
formulations inclusions of different
strains of the bacteria that are
included in the vaccine that get updated
and there aren't necessarily you know
full you know vaccine efficacy trials
what oftentimes happens with some of
these updates is that they compare
antibody response right they they infer
vaccine efficacy by looking at antibody
response from to the new vaccine
compared to the old vaccine and so so
the impact of this largely depends on
what's meant by human clinical trials an
incomplete list would be good too
I representative Merchant
thank you Mr chairman
and thank you for taking the question
how would this impact off-label use of a
vaccine a lot of times operable use does
not go through clinical trials so the
way it's written here would that impact
the ability for a provider to use the
vaccine for operatable use
thank you for the question
representative Merchant that was a
concern however again where the intent
and scope of this legislation is as
written
we we do fear that it could be open for
interpretation it we sort of touched
upon that when we discussed the FDA
compassionate use provision there you
know as we know there's nothing to
prohibit a provider from writing
something from uh from an off-label use
and to just you know briefly touch upon
the previous topic of informed consent
there you know again speaking
specifically to perhaps the the
profession of Pharmacy where under RSA
318 and other administrative rules
um you know there there is a process for
instance when someone is receiving a
medication or a vaccine in the pharmacy
setting by law the they are supposed to
be offered the opportunity to receive
counseling from from a pharmacist and
the patient does have the ability to to
accept or decline that and that is just
another opportunity or touch point where
that health care provider and patient
have that opportunity to discuss and
make that determination regarding
consent
thank you representative Weber
thank you
aren't we making things a little too
simplistic when we only look at the
rights of the person who is receiving
the vaccine and there's all the
questions about voluntary involuntary
and how much information they've got
which is very important but are we not
also
neglecting particularly when we're
talking about
um
the cases in which there is a job
requirement for example that we are
balancing the right of one person not to
receive a treatment that they do not
believe is going to be helpful or
effective for them with the rights of
another person
who might very well suffer Health
consequences
from coming in contact with an
unvaccinated person and isn't it true
that we have to both of those rights are
deeply personal and fundamental and that
we need to find the appropriate balance
between the two of them
yeah so so I agree with you and I think
that that what you're expressing is
exactly what public health tries to do
we look out for the health and the
well-being not just of individuals
although that's the case as well but
also communities however you define
Community whether it's a school
Community or a business Community or the
population of a state or a region
um you know I think our our comments and
our Focus here um in the testimony has
been
um more you know because of the the
wording of House Bill seven excuse me
575.
um you know the focus of that really is
is on
um government's ability to distribute
promote purchase vaccine but but I do
think it's an important point that it's
not just government you know one of the
other areas where the the wording is a
little bit vague is that you know this
isn't just state government this this
bill and the implications of this bill
would also extend to County cities towns
water districts school districts uh
school administrative units and other as
I public entities and so this
potentially not only
potentially has broad reaching
implications for other Community
Partners which are also trying to look
out exactly for for what you're saying
that the health of the health of the
community and not necessarily just the
individual
nice representative King
thank you chairman McDonald and thank
the two of you for being here today I
really appreciate your testimony I think
you guys brought some excellent balance
to the conversation
um
I I hope you can help help me and uh
understand what's going on so
um we have a bunch of other not just
this vaccine but a bunch of other
vaccines and Therapeutics that currently
all the time are being given to people
to patients
um some of which are you know they've
got nothing left to lose and
um and that goes on all the time
my question for you is and I've got a
follow-up my question for you is
who is currently making the decisions
it's it's it's
a bureaucracy right that makes the
decisions on which Therapeutics or
vaccines that they choose to promote
purchase distribute
um
and there's others there's got to be
other Therapeutics and such that some
bureaucrat or some bureaucracy is saying
nah we're not going to buy that we're
not going to We're Not Gonna promote
that so my my first question is who's
making the decisions on which ones to
promote and purchase and such
yeah so so maybe I'll start again and
see if Dr Tanya wants to comment but I I
think your your point is well taken that
you know it's not the New Hampshire
Department of Health and Human Services
or New Hampshire state government which
is approving and authorizing
um these you know any therapeutic that I
can think of any vaccine and any
medication
um and I think the larger Point here is
that there is a federal process that
we've seen play out with the kova 19
vaccines but there's a federal process
by which there you know that there's
requirements on the part of the FDA uh
the U.S federal drug uh Food and Drug
Administration to ensure that there are
requirements in place for pharmaceutical
companies that develop vaccines to study
them appropriately so that they're shown
to be safe and effective but even you
know approval or authorization on the
part of the FDA
um isn't the only
check and balance so to speak those
vaccines if we're talking about vaccines
then goes to
um you know the CDC and the advisory
committee and immunization practices to
make clinical recommendations so I think
the point is that there's a whole
Federal process by which these vaccines
and these Therapeutics get reviewed and
or recommended
um and then there are National medical
organizations which also put out
clinical guidelines
um and so at a state level that's not
that's not our role we don't approve we
don't authorize vaccines what we do do
however is we ensure that um
particularly in the case of something
like a pandemic in the covid-19 vaccines
we do review the science we do make sure
that they are safe and that they are
shown to be effective and that's part of
the reason there were a lot of questions
coming in about the covid-19 vaccines
and that's part of the reason that we
put together that Dr tanian mentioned
this New Hampshire science brief so that
our
communities could be reassured that we
were in fact reviewing and looking at
the science around the bivalent Copa 19
vaccines okay follow-up follow-up I
appreciate your response although I'm
not sure it really addressed my issue
and that is
when there's a therapeutic of any kind
forget vaccine just therapeutic it's not
it's not Vice chair Leon or chairman
McDonald who says this is this is
something I want to do and we're going
to promote it and we're going to buy it
and we're going to let the patients get
it somebody is making the decision to
finally say yeah we're going to promote
it we're going to buy it that the only
person or people or group of people I
can think of are bureaucracies and
bureaucrats they're the only ones that
at the end of the day or if my
understanding is correct that are going
to say yeah this is something we're
going to do here
and so
I guess the concern I have is
so for example you have what's known as
regulatory capture where
the the the regulatory body that is
meant to you know protect the public
from say the pharmaceutical industry
they end up being populated with people
that used to work for the pharmaceutical
industry and it's sort of a revolving
door and it's like the chicken and the
head you know the the fox guarding the
hen house and I'm just curious how we as
as
representatives of the people can
provide oversight over over this whole
system when because right now it just
feels like the bureaucrats have a blank
check to to make total unilateral
decisions and I don't feel like there's
any input from we the people so can you
just explain that a little bit thank you
so so two comments and I'll try to make
these more direct first you know I don't
think we generally recommend legislating
Medical Care and so when you're talking
about
um you know vaccines Therapeutics
whatever the pharmaceutical therapeutic
is you're talking about essentially
delivery of that in a healthcare setting
um there's always dangers with that
um the second comment I would have is
that there is a federal system or
bureaucracy maybe as you put it
um that initially assesses and evaluates
Therapeutics to see if they're safe and
effective to make them available but
then there's a Whole Net medical
professional network of
um of medical providers Professional
Medical organizations which assess and
recommend
you know how that therapeutic should be
used at the at the patient level so it's
really sort of a multi-tier system you
know the bureaucracy if you will that I
think the public oftentimes sees is you
know for example the FDA uh reviewing
and approving a therapeutic or a
medication but then what happens is that
there's an assessment about how that
medication or that therapeutic is
appropriately appropriately used at a
clinical level
um and that's where non-governmental
groups come in
um
you know so for example when you're
talking about you know covid-19 and
treating kova 19 there are professional
medical societies like the Infectious
Disease Society of America for example
or idsa which weighs in and has
recommendations on how to appropriately
treat patients that might have covet 19.
if I may add to that uh representative
King one of the outcomes of the previous
legislative session was the passage of
House Bill 1045 which established a
ethics advisory committee and that
committee also includes members of the
House and Senate and they are there to
as well as other stakeholders as well to
advise the commissioner in the
department on matters such as this
other questions yes representative Nagel
thank you Mr chairman thanks for taking
my question I this is a fairly maybe not
simple
um we had heard an earlier testimony
from somebody else that there is no
ongoing effort to assess risk and
benefit of these vaccines is that true
um and what is actually being done and
third how would a provider report uh
adverse effects yeah so so that is that
is not true there is ongoing multiple
trials and I would lump them into two
categories one are the pharmaceutical
clinical trials so this is where we're
talking about the you know phase one
phase two phase three clinical trials
and in fact there are ongoing um
pharmaceutical clinical trials for the
original monovalent vaccines I I believe
they're still ongoing the plan had been
to continue those clinical trials for at
least a couple of years
um but there are all there are also
clinical trials that were conducted for
beta variant bivalent vaccines ba1 one
Omicron bivalent vaccines
ba45 bivalent vaccines they're study
into other sort of types of in
combination vaccines so so there's
always those pharmaceutical clinical
trials going on but on top of that
um there are what we call real world
vaccine Effectiveness trials and so you
have studies coming out of you know
Medical Systems like Kaiser Permanente
in California and there was actually a
study recently from North Carolina
published in in the New England Journal
of Medicine showing that the bivalent
vaccines have significant added benefit
over the monovalent vaccine formulations
when used as boosters for protection
against infection hospitalization severe
disease so so these are studies that are
continually rolling out
um every week I get new studies in my
inbox and so there's no shortage of
study of these vaccines and and the the
trials are pointing to a number of
things
one is that the bivalent Copa 19
vaccines do produce a higher antibody
response particularly against the more
recent
Omicron variants compared to the older
or original formulation of the vaccines
there's actually
um the the bivalent vaccines are more
protective against severe disease and
actually there's one trial that just
came out I don't want to go two in the
weeds here there's one trial that just
came out that um was a head-to-head
comparison put out by one of the
pharmaceutical companies from the UK
comparing monovalent boosters versus
bivalent boosters and they actually in
show that they actually showed uh not
only decreased risk for severe disease
but decreased risk for
um people getting covid-19 itself
getting infected and developing sickness
even if it's not severe disease
yeah
also
I representative Missouri no go ahead
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so what vaccine on the
childhood schedule has ever not had
clinical trials
um well I think that comes down to how
you Define clinical trials
so so you know are you any clinical
trial I mean the the kova 19 bivalent
vaccines wouldn't fit that criteria
the covid-19 bivalent vaccines had
clinical trials
so I think it comes down to the details
of like what do you mean by clinical
trials
okay and I I think that's I think that's
part of our concern and part of our
point is that um you know yet there were
absolutely problems with the rollout of
the bivalent covid-19 vaccines we'll be
the first to acknowledge that but a lot
of those issues were around the
communication and the coordination of
that not because there wasn't data
showing that the covid-19 vaccines
weren't safe or effective
and those are two separate issues I
think
okay follow-up follow-up so out of
um the 50 people that I know uh who have
received the coveted vaccine probably
even more
50 of those people still received still
got covered and many of them did end up
in the hospital so at what point and I
think it's you know as an add-on to your
question I'm not sure if I heard the
answer as at what what point do we put a
pause on promoting and distributing
vaccines like this that
many of us looking around are saying not
super effective and honestly as of
lately been causing some damage and
every single day we are seeing on the
news if you're paying attention of
people have perfectly healthy people
dropping suddenly and people can't
figure it out
but the timing of it seems interesting
to me so but at what point do we put a
pause on a vaccine that didn't undergo
intensive testing to begin with on
humans and
you know try and go like
we a lot of us have natural immunity you
know that should count for something too
so at what point do we just stop pushing
the vaccine vaccine when some of us see
it as at this point not super effective
yeah so excuse me
um feel free to jump in here if you want
anytime
um so so thank you for those questions
um you know the vaccines so I think
you've raised a number of different
issues um or at different points the
first response that I would have is that
the vaccines are effective
um and this gets I think to the initial
question of like well what are what are
we measuring what what is the purpose of
vaccination and in the early days of the
vaccines rolling out there was hope
and early data showing that the vaccines
were 94 95 effective at preventing even
infection
um and so there was hope and even
expectation that the covid-19 vaccines
would be um
uh would would prevent transmission
prevent infection prevent circulation of
covet 19. now that didn't pan out for a
couple of reasons uh new variants
emerged which were more likely to evade
or Escape immunity and we've seen the
vaccine protection Wane or decrease over
time but that doesn't mean that the
vaccines aren't effective and don't work
there's there's a plethora of data out
there showing that the vaccines are
effective highly effective still at
preventing severe disease preventing
hospitalizations preventing deaths
um and you know some of that data we
highlight in our in our science brief
um so I think that uh we we don't agree
with the statement that they're not
effective they are still effective but
the focus of the vaccination programs is
Shifting to preventing severe disease
severe outcomes like hospitalizations
and deaths and in fact we've seen the
hospitalizations related to covid-19
we've seen deaths related 19 drop and
even this past you know since the summer
time deaths hospitalizations while they
still remain too high are much lower
than they were at any other point during
the pandemic
regarding safety of the vaccines
um you know I am uh so there are there
is
quite a bit of wrong information out
there about kova 19 vaccines causing a
huge number of deaths and that's not
true every death that occurs after
covid-19 vaccination gets reported to
theirs and part of the reason it's
reported is as a surveillance system so
it can be investigated further and most
of the time what's found is that people
died from covid-19 itself the infection
not the vaccine or in older adults they
died from chronic illness like heart
disease
there are
to my knowledge very few
if any
deaths for example related to covid-19
vaccination and this is this is data
coming from you know National
investigations into each and every one
of these deaths that's reported
can I have a follow-up so sorry so are
you not seeing an increase in myocard
artists and teens
yeah so so the the exception there is
myocarditis there um there has been an
association so first off um uh New
Hampshire doesn't have New Hampshire
specific numbers on this but you're
right there is an association between
kova 19 vaccination and myocarditis or
inflammation of the heart muscle there
are you know numbers on this you know
measuring it in number of cases per
million doses administered but again you
have to take into account the
complications from covid-19 itself and
so multiple studies showing that the
risks of myocarditis after infection
even in that highest risk group young
adult adolescent males is anywhere from
two to eight times higher from viral
infection versus the vaccine and most of
the time when people get myocarditis
after vaccination it's limited and
people recover on their own so there are
these concerns I want to acknowledge
that
um but the the risk benefit analysis
that's done has shown that the benefit
of vaccination
outweighs the minimal safety risks and
the rest risk from covid-19 is greater
the risk from infection itself is
greater than from vaccination
was myocarditis you also representative
representative Merchant
to uh Dr tanium by the way it's good to
see you again
nice to have you back in the state
when we talk about the efficacy of a
vaccine and so forth could you speak to
the fact that influenza vaccine itself
it doesn't always prevent anybody from
getting flu if you will and the
complications of it so therefore there's
a vaccine that we take almost every
single year many of us it does not mean
that because we had the vaccine we'll
never come down with influenza could you
clarify that for me
foreign
thank you for the question so I'll I'll
start with the first part of that and
then I can hand it over to Dr Chan for
for a follow-up and this kind of relates
to uh the concerns I have representative
Missouri had
um where one of our concerns with this
piece of legislation is
um
for the Department to not be involved in
some of the promotion for certain
vaccines and if we really start looking
at effect efficacy year over year we
know that some years the influenza
vaccine is considered 40 to 45 percent
effective while other years it can be
upwards a double of that for
Effectiveness so so to draw a line on
what we're going to Define as as
effective is one of the concerns that we
would have with the legislation as as
written
okay uh anyone who has not asked a
question yet I don't think you have on
this bill have you representative McLean
thank you Mr thank you for taking my
question so I agree that the bill is
problematic but I may think I think
there may be a bit of a nugget on on the
promotional side of it and so I just
wondered if you guys could tease out a
little bit more I know that you've
talked about it uh with respect to where
you see the role of the state in in
promoting whether it's the coveted
vaccine or the influenza vaccine my
personal experience has been that risk
benefit analysis is done but it really
doesn't get down to the patient so I
hear on the radio all the time the covet
vaccine is safe and effective go out get
your influenza vaccine but I'm the guy
who always shows up an hour early reads
the paperwork I request the written copy
of the paperwork on one and so I ask
questions and unless it's my pharmacist
you know it's coming Direct in the
pharmacist invariably the the person can
ask answer not if well it's right here
I'm just asking a question what does
this mean well I don't know what does
this mean well I don't know and if
that's not from the pharmacist who
typically can answer anybody else cannot
so in terms of me being able to execute
my risk benefit analysis as a patient at
your level you may understand
but all that the patient's getting
really is the promotion and when it
comes to getting the data to complete
that risk benefit analysis it's just
you're not able to do it unless like I
said the pharmacist was the person
actually delivering the vaccine so what
I and that's where I think there may be
something in portions of this just want
to invite your thoughts on that where
you see promotion and what might be done
yep thank you for that question so it as
we've seen with other key words in this
piece of legislation it's very unclear
how certain things are being defined and
we would say that promotion is another
one of those key words
um is promotion going to be defined as a
physician at the New Hampshire Veterans
Home offering a veteran would you like
your annual influenza vaccine we don't
have answers to these questions because
unfortunately the the language in this
bill is just so vague and the the intent
really isn't clear there
is you know and as you mentioned before
uh you know great on you for doing all
that additional research and asking
those questions and being engaged and
that is something that you know any
provider any pharmacist loves to see
from their patients but again there are
other mechanisms in place where
in that facility you know for
particularly the pharmacy you know that
person is supposed to be offered the uh
right to receive counseling from a
pharmacist and that person can choose or
you know Choose Or deny that um that
offer
and if I can just quickly add from like
a practical standpoint you know we we
talk about influenza every year and we
get asked uh publicly by media what can
people do to protect themselves from
influenza and so this legislation
potentially would prevent us from saying
publicly well influenza activity is
going up get a flu vaccine right that's
promotion of a flu vaccine so so there's
real I think practical real world
implications for how Public Health talks
about and messages some of these
Therapeutics and you know that doesn't
seem
right to us but it also doesn't seem
like maybe that's the intent the
underlying intent for the legislation so
we just want to acknowledge that there
are some
potentially significant impacts on our
ability but also our partner's ability
to operate with the some of the vague
wording in this legislation
representative Palazzo
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question uh two parts first it
doesn't only talk about vaccines it
talks about pharmaceutical products but
what about some other medications would
you be open to expand it for example in
terms of masks policies now most people
in this room are musculus despite some
cells covered to violence go going
around and but it was slow to implement
and stop masks mandates even when there
were some facts that they were
ineffective at the same time it's the
beginning of pandemic in the early 2020
the citation was the opposite all the
data was that the masks were helpful but
uh
Professionals in your organizations
believed that masks were helpful but
were advising public
in middle west because there was a push
to I don't know Federal push Point
border Mr chairman yes representative
Weber
um in the interest of time I would like
to ask if if mandates aren't well
outside of what is covered with this
bill
okay I can I will concentrate on if I
may uh on on this bill and uh
so in in terms of uh pharmaceutical
products and vaccines wouldn't be easier
for you to follow fact-based medicine
because you testified that sometimes uh
um public health and sometimes just hope
is guiding your or let's say like I hope
that vaccines will prevent infections
and sometimes that hope uh and let's say
it did not materialized so it wouldn't
be easier for you if you will be guided
by
fact-based well-tested sort ofly tested
guidance thank you
well I'll just say uh quickly that you
know I don't I think I we use science
and evidence and studies to
um
uh talk about and promote vaccination
that's why we're out there talking about
numbers and vaccine Effectiveness
numbers and different studies that are
done and so so much of that literature
that we've been reviewing on
particularly vaccines throughout the
pandemic but but also other Therapeutics
um you know but but the vaccine science
is outlined in our New Hampshire science
data brief
so anyone who has not asked a question
yet of these gentlemen
I think we've pretty well covered it so
thank you very much thank you
also signed up to test uh to speak today
is Dr Merrill Nass
you asked for three to five minutes if
you could keep closer to the three
that'd be great
foreign
thank you for inviting me
um I've given you my written testimony
I'm uh
confused right now because the previous
speakers have obfuscated and made some
errors in what they've said and I wanted
to correct those errors but I also want
to give you my testimony so help me tell
me what I should do
testimony first please okay
uh my name is Dr Merrill nass
um I'm in favor of this bill I'm a main
physician I am currently suspended on my
license for providing early treatment
for covid and uh telling the truth about
the vaccines I'm in the middle of a
hearing
a vaccine okay there are two kinds of
products under the FDA under the law in
the United States there are licensed
products and unlicensed products there
are only two kinds licensed is called
approved in FDA terminology unlicensed
if it's under eua is called authorized
in this written testimony that you have
I've given you statements from glaxo
from the American College of Physicians
and from the CDC about what it takes to
license a vaccine
the reason why it's such an arduous long
process is because there's been lots of
problems found in vaccine development in
the United States over at least the last
50 years and I will mention just a few
um
vaccines in cats still cause sarcomas
which are Cancers
multiple vaccines are grown in tissue
cultures and these tissue cultures the
cells may contain oncogenes in other
words genes that have been inserted into
the DNA of of the cell line but may come
out and potentially could cause a cancer
for example the flu cell vacs is one of
about 10 flu vaccines that are licensed
in the United States it is grown in the
maiden Darby canine kidney tissue
culture if you take those cells and give
them to nude mice they cause cancer
but we are getting those as flu shots
they generally don't cause cancer in us
but this is the reason you have to go
through a process
there are other vaccines that cause
thyroid diseases in dogs there are many
many potential problems in a colored
graphic I've shown you five disasters
when vaccines were rolled out quickly in
the United States and in fact this
coveted vaccine was not the fastest that
got rolled out it apparently took 326
days we've had them roll out before in
six months
there's a big problem potentially coming
up and that is a non-profit called sepi
Coalition for epidemic preparedness it
is funded by the United States
government Norway UK many countries over
30 countries fund it and they are
pledging to roll out vaccines in the
future in 100 days for the next pandemic
that is extremely dangerous there will
be no possibility to test them in humans
for safety
um
but that is what's coming up and I've
shown you a little bit about that that
is they are funded also by Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation and
um the welcome trust it's a very
important it the the president is an
American who spent his career working
for the U.S government
okay
um
I would ask that you amend the language
of this bill
um the speakers before me made a mistake
the only vaccines that are available in
the United States that are licensed
without human clinical trials are the
flu vaccines no others are and no others
will be there are no pneumococcal
vaccines that are licensed without
clinical trials
um this is this has been done for
decades it's considered safe these
vaccines are pretty well known although
they keep developing new platforms for
flu vaccines
so we have a flu vaccine that's been
around for about 10 years now that's
grown up in cells in tissue culture of
the full army worm for example and
there's a small amount of DNA and
protein from that worm or or moth just
as there is a tiny amount of DNA and
protein from the
kidney the the dog kidney cells in the
flucelvax vaccine the army worm vaccine
is called flu block
and when you go to a pharmacy you really
don't know what you're getting unless
unless you ask
all right
so almost every time a vaccine has been
rolled out quickly because it was an
emergency there was an unanticipated
disaster and usually it led to the
ending of the vaccine program
in 1955 the Qatar incident occurred in
which forty thousand children got polio
from an improperly activated inactivated
vaccine and in 1976 400 Americans got
Guillain-Barre syndrome a paralytic
illness at least 25 died in the swine
flu vaccine program ended could you
begin wrapping up ma'am please I have a
couple more paragraphs since 2020
thousands of Americans have developed
myocarditis and I will give you in a
future testimony today data on the
myocarditis problem
if you don't want New Hampshire citizens
to be among the guinea pigs for these
rapidly rolled out future vaccines as
well as potentially we don't know what
the problems are yet with a bivalence
because they only were rolled out in
September
vote for this bill New Hampshire can
protect its citizens from precipitous
and Reckless medical experiments by
simply requiring that all vaccines
accept the seasonal flu vaccines go
through human clinical trials before
being rolled out for Mass use
this is what it takes to be licensed and
be called safe and effective citizens of
the Granite State deserve no less please
protect us thank you thank you
questions
yes representative McLean
uh thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I mean at 10 years is
a is a very long time
to approve a vaccine and given that
there may be situations where there's
life-saving opportunity
uh don't you think if you say I'm gonna
take away that right all together
um that you would be depriving people of
an opportunity to make their own
assessment
um what do you think of that so there's
two answers to your question
um the first is yes if you give people
adequate informed consent they should be
able to do whatever they want no one
received in for adequate informed
consent for the coveted vaccines and
they generally don't I mean if you got a
the flu vaccine made in the fall army
worm or the dog kidney cell were you
told that there was an oncogenic uh you
know virus in it so that's the problem
particularly with covid when these
things were deliberately given out by
national Guardsmen who have no medical
training there could be no informed
consent there were a variety of informed
consent forms that I have reviewed and
some of them simply asked for your name
your address your demographics and then
said you're signing an informed consent
form so the other part of informed
consent and what is required by law but
didn't always happen under the emergency
use authorization bill which is called
the prep act and was only passed in 2005
before 2005 there were no emergency use
authorizations there are only licensed
drugs and compassionate use
um that that bill requires that all
significant known risks and benefits be
provided to the patient and that is in
lieu of the previous written informed
consent
and even that minimized informed consent
has not been provided to people so
um so that's where the problem is now
yeah it doesn't necessarily have to take
10 years to make a vaccine some are made
faster and some slower
we had another problem with covid which
was that the CDC and the FDA or and some
other people already knew that we had
drugs that would kill the covet virus in
tissue culture and they suppressed their
use in order to wait for a vaccine
it's very and they knew because they had
tested the 60 over 60 drugs were
identified by the NIH in a paper
published in 2014 that killed the
um SARS one and or MERS both beta
coronaviruses in tissue culture they
knew about this their people published
it they suppressed it it's very likely
that there are other drugs that will
work against other new
um
pandemic viruses or bacteria but we need
federal agencies that are going to allow
us to to have them I lost my license
because I was providing fully licensed
drugs which I'm perfectly legally able
to do to patients who wanted them you
know and and that was considered a
heinous crime and my license was
immediately suspended
um there's one other thing I wanted to
say and now I've I've forgotten what it
is okay
a quick follow-up please thank you Mr
chair
um so while I agree
um with your comments about informed
consent and that it wasn't the best
um but this bill goes Way Beyond
addressing that
um so do you
because basically it takes the state out
of everything Distributing purchasing
um so what are your thoughts on that
though
so I want to emphasize that almost all
the vaccines that we have are licensed
everything is licensed otherwise you
can't get it unless it's under eua so
right now only the covid vaccines are
under eua previously an anthrax vaccine
a smallpox vaccine have been under eua
um
so
what should
the covid vaccines don't really work I'm
going to tell you in a later testimony
what Tony fauci said to uh three or
three weeks ago in a paper he just
published the efficacy is poor the
duration there's a very brief positive
duration of action then it goes to zero
and then the effects become negative
um overall there's been no real risk
benefit analysis of the coveted vaccines
because when you look draw it out for a
long period of time you find that people
become more susceptible to covid and in
the UK data and some other countries
data but not the U.S data which is not
very reliable
there are higher mortality rates in the
vaccinated so
um
it's a it's a complicated picture but in
the testimonies I will be providing you
today I'm giving you data from FDA CDC
why don't we deal with those testimonies
the appropriate time okay
the other relevant to subsequent bills
let's focus at that time
representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
um my question is related to
um the kind of
evolution of medical ethics
um it seems that since the beginning of
the covet pandemic we have seen the
practice of Public Health which used to
operate under the um
uh the principal
where we like I can't remember the name
no it's um anyway
Public Health
precautionary principle thank you ma'am
yes so it used to be operated under that
principle and it seems like we're
stepping away from that
um and now it's you know throw a dart
and hope that it sticks and I'm just
wondering where you see medical ethics
going I've seen chipping away at the
informed consent process for clinical
trials in general with some changes to
the
um the common rule in 2016 now you don't
need to be informed that you're in a
clinical trial unless uh the IRB if an
IRB votes that you don't need to be in
informed that you're enrolled in one and
where do you see this going
well I think you know what's clear to
everybody is that public health has
become entirely politicized and
um you know it is being run for in some
cases commercial interests in some cases
political interests
um the precautionary principle has in
large part been thrown out the window
regulation at the FDA it has been
eaten away in in certain ways for
example project warp speed did not go
through normal FDA processes because
um because it was an eua and because
the manufacturing was run through a
military army program
um I wanted to point out that in terms
of Ebola there's actually a licensed
Ebola vaccine in the U.S now FDA
licensed it about three years ago it was
used in the second largest Ebola
epidemic which occurred in the Congo in
2018 and 19 and it did not reduce
mortality and they had the highest
mortality yet of 60 percent in that
epidemic
uh you know that's the problem when you
look you're licensing vaccines now on
the basis of antibody levels and they
are not a good surrogate for immunity
and yet we're doing that because that's
what you can do quickly
okay other questions
yes representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question I
I'm just curious I I don't know if you
said this uh what is your medical
specialty Internal Medicine okay thank
you
other questions
I'm seeing no other questions
okay thank you
uh we have quite a list of bills to come
and we are not uh when we we have a
couple more speakers on this bill by the
way also uh what I'm thinking
um
in terms of the committee members
perhaps we continue and those who wish
to go to lunch may do so
and you know obviously those who want to
stick it out May do so also so I'm
assuming that what you're you're
proposing is what we used to call
rolling lunch and some of the good good
way to folks stay here in some well
we'll keep the hearings going and people
can go to lunch as as they wish fine
with me any objections to that
okay thank you okay we'll continue then
also signed up to testify is Kate Horgan
from the New Hampshire Association of
counties
thank you Mr chair my name is Kate
Horgan I represent the New Hampshire
Association of counties I don't think
I've had the pleasure of being in front
of this committee this year yet so just
to give you a quick overview of what the
association is we represent all of the
elected and appointed officials in your
County government and specifically in
this case I am here for your County
nursing homes the association is in
opposition to this bill and we share
many of the same concerns that Dr Chan
in the department brought up County
nursing homes are sometimes the only
ways or options for individuals to get
Services
County homes offer flu vaccines every
year and this bill the way it is worded
could prevent that in the future in
addition this could prevent a resident
of a nursing home who is participating
in a clinical trial from participating
in that clinical trial the way that we
read that this bill they may need
support or whether that be
Transportation or uh
delivery of services from the County
nursing home does that count as
promotion as I read this Bill yes it
does finally the association would like
to notice that we would oppose any
legislation that would create a
situation where state and federal
statutes are in uh set against one
another forcing the counties to choose
which set of statutes they are going to
follow which could result in dire
consequences for the long-term care
system in New Hampshire I will conclude
my testimony because they are far more
expert people behind me coming but I'm
happy to try and answer any questions
that the committee has representative
Leon thank you Mr chairman and thank you
very much welcome to the committee this
year
um that caught my ear that there may be
some conflicting Federal statutes if you
don't know them off the top of your head
I'd appreciate if you could send them to
us I would be happy to look into that
representative Leon thank you
representative palazzov
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question if we still try to
save this uh Bill what would you propose
you mentioned uh clinical trials so
maybe we can write the amendment to put
exception for clinical trial but other
any other specific things that we can
add to this build to make it more
tolerable thank you representative for
the question I believe you will find
last year in several of the bills this
body did put exemption language in for
uh long-term care facilities and we
would recommend that you include that
language in this bill
other questions
seeing no other questions
thank you thank you
also signed up to speak is Dr Jeff feder
from the New Hampshire hospital
microphone
push the button so yeah there you go you
hear me okay now yes okay thank you
thank you for the opportunity to speak
to the committee
um Jeffrey Federer I'm the chief medical
officer at New Hampshire hospital
um and um I want to speak about the
impact of this bill on our patients and
our institution patients with severe and
persistent mental illness have a 25-year
lower life expectancy primarily due to
medical illness not suicide or homicide
or other injuries
and access to Medical Care is the
primary reason that
medical morbidity exists
we know that patients with severe and
persistent mental illness have
difficulty accessing flu vaccination and
as you have heard in previous testimony
this bill as written would present an
obstacle to our providing flu
vaccination and potentially other
relevant vaccinations to our patients
I also am concerned from the standpoint
that
if a patient were not at New Hampshire
hospital in the same situation they
would be able to obtain a flu
vaccination otherwise this may expose
the state to
um a violation of the Americans with
Disabilities Act
um conjugate congregate living of the
sort that happens at New Hampshire
hospital Glencliff home and group homes
where many of our patients reside our
high-risk situations for Respiratory
illness and vaccinations a very
important tool
um our ability to to provide these
vaccinations to eat mechanisms is
important
um I am concerned also about the um the
promotion language in this bill from the
standpoint that it could be interpreted
to make it difficult or prohibited for
um State Physicians and nurse
practitioners
and nurses to have Frank conversations
with our patients about the risks and
benefits of vaccination
finally I want to address the issue of
informed consent in this population
um in form of consent is something we
take really seriously uh in an
environment where there is an element of
coercion there's an involuntary
hospitalization and and other legal
constrictions on folks we
have very uh strict procedures to ensure
that Guardians and
capacity medical decision-making
capacity uh considerations are addressed
properly so that that is that is a part
of the fabric of how Medical Care is
delivered not just about vaccination
about everything in our Institution
so I'll keep my comments brief and be
happy to take any questions thank you
any questions yes representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and um just so I'm
understanding completely
um I had a relative who lived for a long
time until he passed away at Glen Cliff
home
um where he got fantastic care
um
you know he had a guardian and um so
informed consent would have gone in that
direction but are you saying that
um for for that population for my
relative that um
the covet vaccine and flu vaccine just
wouldn't be available to them
if this law was to be passed that that
is the way it appears that the intention
of the bill is and I suspect that the
from the previous testimony that flu
vaccination was not intended to be
included but but the plain language
would tend to include it
thank you okay thank you other questions
saying no other questions thank you sir
foreign
also signed up to speak is Kate pray
from new futures
hopefully I pronounce that name
correctly
close enough it's Frye what that's it's
spelled Fray so I understand I think we
should keep your testimony I have
written testimony so I'll be about two
minutes I'll leave you my testimony
again Kate Frye from I'm the vice
president of advocacy at new Futures new
features that poses this bill we work
very closely with uh partners and policy
makers
um on to improve overall public health
and improve health Equity across the
granite state we agree with concerns
from the department and others who spoke
about the lack of clarity to this will
and one of the major concerns we would
have is um the affecting
um really important valuable and
effective programs such as a vaccine for
children program in New Hampshire
um what would would be concerned about
the impact if the state could not
provide those at a reduced cost to our
communities and therefore that cost
would be passed on to families and just
to keep them mind that vaccines
particularly for children are one of the
number one Public Health accomplishments
over time and has prevented diseases
such as polio mumps measles the list
goes on and for a bill that doesn't have
um the proper intent there could be some
unintended consequences I'm happy to
leave my testimony with the committee
that'd be great thank you
any questions
I'm saying no questions thank you
also signed up to speak is Deborah
Johnson from Grantham
thank you
um
mine is a question
um to some of these people that make the
decisions for us
um
why did the FDA try to seal the coveted
vaccine research documents including
trial results documents for 75 years and
why did it take a court order to release
these documents which are now being
studied by a team of over 3 500
researchers under Naomi wolf with very
concerning findings and why should the
public have any trust for information if
it is not allowed if we're not allowed
to see it
and
sorry
and that's really um does anybody have
questions for me oh okay that was quick
uh any questions at all
I'm seeing done thank you ma'am
also signed up to speak is Andrew Hosmer
from New Hampshire Public Health
Association
thank you very much members of the
committee and uh Mr chairman
uh my name is Andrew Hosmer I'm here
today representing New Hampshire Public
Health Association which is an
organization that Champions Public
Health policy and practice so I in
the discretion of time here I have
handed out a written statement from the
executive director Hanan bedri of New
Hampshire Public Health Association
um and I will let that stand as my
testimony I am here and the association
is here in opposition to this bill and
certainly we are supporting the
department because we have the exact
same concerns with the bill I'm happy to
take questions or sit back down any
questions
I'm seeing none thank you thank you Mr
chair
also signed up to speak is Terese
Grinnell
hi my name is Therese Grinnell I
appreciate the time to speak I am a
hospice nurse I live in Loudoun New
Hampshire
um I have a few quick comments just
based on the testimonies that I've heard
one as clinicians we take an oath to
office we take an oath not to do any
harm
so what I saw in the last two years is a
lot of clinicians including this doctor
that gave up her entire livelihood and
everything she worked for
to be able to try and prescribe
medications or give the opportunity to
her patients to try something that was a
known medication why that was stifled is
a question all of us have to ask because
the science is there that those
medications worked
these vaccines we are seeing tremendous
tremendous Fallout
there was a documentary that my nursing
instructor had us watch before we
graduated and I would encourage all of
you to take the time to look at it this
was 15 years ago and I am so glad she
had me watch it it was called the caring
corrupt corrupted nurses of the Third
Reich and it talks about how the
government
actually came in and the elderly and the
mentally unstable that were in these
facilities were the first that they
tried to go ahead and do away with
I don't care if I sound like a
conspiracy theorist but I'm here to tell
you that is exactly what I am witnessing
in my practice
and I'm not ashamed to say it
we have children and families who trust
the government that these vaccine mobile
clinics mean that this is safe for their
child
only to see four children die in New
Hampshire from these vaccines
we are going to have to take account as
the history Marches On whether we rush
to Market this intervention
whether or not there was something else
therapeutic that we denied the right for
people to try
I have so many clinicians one that left
Concord Hospital she got an email if you
prescribe this medication you will be
put on notice you will lose your license
since when are we taking it away from
the doctors and the nurses and the
clinicians who took an oath to do no
harm and now we're forcing them to
actually do harm
to withhold a medication that might work
as soon as someone's symptomatic or to
force the vaccine or encourage a vaccine
or Market falsely a vaccine that's going
to keep you from getting this virus when
we know that that's not the case
as far as the County homes and the
nursing homes and the mental health
hospital
each of those patients is under they're
assigned a provider
it is between that provider and that
patient to have informed consent whether
it be with a guardian or a family member
who's cognitively intact to understand
the options of treatment and the risk
and reward for each of those
that is not something that a government
should be
falsely leading young parents
family members and everyone else to
believe is safe
there's a responsibility to each of you
here to your constituents and I would
just beg that we would pause and make
sure that we're not doing harm
that you take a moment to watch that
documentary
it's not anything new it's not just some
random Youtube it was my nursing
instructor at nhti that wanted to make
sure that I watched that and if I had
not watched that I would not have had
the red flags go off the way that they
did for me and I'm glad that I stood up
and said whoa
there might be risk here
and I'm sad when I go into The Birches
and one of the nurses says hey T are you
still standing up
about the vaccines I saw you on the
corner well it kind of evolved from
there she goes well I wish I would have
stood with you and she points to arm
crutches
she can no longer ambulate without
crutches and she once used to hike all
of our mountains
it's a reality these vaccines and these
boosters are doing harm
and we need to be aware of that thank
you for your time thank you any
questions
representative Palazzo are you taking
questions ma'am or
are you taking questions or you don't
have to if you don't want any questions
representative thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question uh am I
right in understanding that those four
cases of minus uh dying in New Hampshire
after receiving a covet vaccines that
those four cases the officially
documented in the wireless database
so the virus reporting does have the
cause of death
as related to the vaccine if that's the
question so yes it is well documented
through representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
being here
um so to your point about in the County
nursing homes and you know where we see
that we may have this conflict if we put
something in the bill to say that this
does not apply to you know a pace
provider patient
decision making that if a physician
truly believes that they should be
promoting this that they can have the
conversation with their patients and
that way it can put that concern to rest
yeah I believe informed consent is part
of the way that we make sure that our
patients know the risk reward it's
always been you know how we are supposed
to practice and we've taken that away
and I think that's very dangerous in
addition you have people who desperately
need to be in these facilities and they
cannot be accepted into one of those
beds unless they get this vaccine to me
that is
which is horrible if I have a family
member that needs mental health crisis
and needs to be at the New Hampshire
state hospital or needs to be at
Merrimack County nursing home for care
they're forced to take something into
their body that we don't know isn't
going to harm them
to me that's discrimination that's
that's putting this person into a place
where they have to do something that we
don't have informed consent for them to
even it just it's dangerous
follow up thank you um what you what you
just said is pretty striking so
um and I'm not aware of this happening
so enlighten me if it is
um are you saying that some patients are
being denied beds at these facilities if
they don't receive the vaccinations my
understanding is many of our almost all
of our nursing home facilities in New
Hampshire require that the patient be
completely vaccinated and boosted and
they're not able to get an exemption in
order to have a bed in that facility
which is dangerous to me thank you other
questions
I'm seeing no other questions okay thank
you you're welcome
I have a partially completed card
indicating somebody supported the bill
but nobody put their name on it
um I mean we have a blue sheet over
there you can sign in just Express
support if you don't want to testify
um so again I don't have any name on
this card no one else has signed up to
testify does any yes sir
is that yours what is that your card
okay what's your name sir
yeah there's no name on it there's no
name or could you finish it up for us my
name is Joseph
m i R well we'll bring it down to you
sir
I've heard a lot about it a microphone
but fell out your card sir just take a
moment
okay you have three minutes okay I've
heard a lot about it informed consent
here which is addressed by this bill
because uh because of the term promotion
that's in it and uh I would I would I
would uh assert that the
promotion is disinformation it's
disinformed consent I have I have a
I have a document here and it's from
two uh Ohio uh or Oregon State Senators
and they um
it's a formal grand jury petition sent
to the Department of Justice Biden's
Department of Justice it was sent in
October of 2021.
and what it what it describes I'm a
statistician by the way I'm a uh I'm a
graduate of MIT mathematics I uh I have
an MBA from Columbia University in
finance okay that's uh much of my
credentials I have no medical
credentials
um but this um
they talk about statistical
irregularities that have been used to
establish public health policies that
infringe upon the con constitutionally
protected civil liberties of the
citizens and represent irregularities
that have laid to Major collateral
damage including but not limited to one
historic small business laws and
Community economic collapse two
unacceptable rises in mental illness
drug abuse and suicide rates now this is
they're saying that this is what let
What's led to that now we're looking for
one of the other bills we're looking for
the cures for these things but these are
the this is a source you have to get rid
of
and unnecessary loss of life due to the
withholding of evidence-based treatments
from citizens in need and I think Dr
Nash talked a little bit about that
the um
this formal petition acts as both an
official Complaint and preliminary
exhibit to assist grand jury members in
orienting themselves to the scope of
alleged crimes committed and there's a
CDC and FDA which are being accused of
this misinformation which has led us
which has led us to um
the the medical malpractice that the
um our providers and our governments
have been leaning on okay so this that's
the problem
second thing is
um you might I mean just just common
sense you know have I I hope all of you
have looked at the bear system and
limited to New Hampshire and and stuff
why and the bear system in general
it 2000 the first two thousand people at
least two more than two thousand people
have died on the day of the shot more
more than two thousand people have died
on the second day and the thousand
people have died on the third day not in
New Hampshire that's that's the United
States and other it's probably half of
that is probably United States if you
could begin wrapping up Sir what if you
could please start wrapping up your
testimony okay
um
here's the results for this for the
shots as of the the first year the
numbers the percentage of people who
died with covid that were under age 70
in New Hampshire in New Hampshire 12
okay first year the first year of covid
only the um
only the the at-risk population could
get the shots the second year of covet
it was given to the wider Community the
health the healthy Community the working
age people
it's like second year 37 percent
of of the uh those who died with covid
were under age 70. okay so it went from
12 percent
under a 70 to 37 percent one under 870
and one last thing on April 29th uh 2021
uh Beth Daly of HHS told us that only
one person under age 65
who had no core morbidities only one or
two one or maybe two she said it was at
the gov the governor's press conference
said it's online you can get the text
um one or maybe two
died
with covet at that time and at that time
1300 had died
so this this was not this is 2021 the
the vaccine program had already been in
engaged for for healthy working age
people for a month and a half and on but
only and and then the uh Mr chairman we
have restricted okay the testimony of
other people right I know he was
wrapping up
Sir can we get a copy of that written
testimony
foreign
okay thank you
okay
also signed up to testify is Stephen
Robinson from Northwood
foreign
[Music]
sense okay first and foremost
personally I support this bill that's
not without that uh off the bat
I want to address Mrs Mazer because her
quite her statement saying when's this
going to end
I thought about that and I've been
thinking about that since the started
but it's going to end when they get out
of our back pockets your back pockets my
back pockets you always found the circle
dig it into us
and I like to address Mr Chan why don't
you go to that lady who lost his
three-year-old daughter in Raymond and
tell her your vaccine is safe and
effective I like to go see who do that
all right I call it I call Bull
yeah I'm a very straightforward person
have you ever noticed sir can you keep
it to the topic and not to anything yes
I'm trying to save something I do
support this bill it's about time that
we you as a community make the right
decision and protect the people of New
Hampshire not these lobbyists and
pharmaceuticals that was pushing Us
Poison down our bodies I like I said I
speak here as a grandfather a parent and
a concerned citizen okay I speak from
the heart okay I don't have all my
literature but I do uh belong to a lot
of groups and I see a lot of people
going down it's not ironic about seeing
Peak Athletic uh athletes dying in the
prime and it's all over the world or you
know you're absolutely ahead of us it's
happening here
anybody watch football is that just like
ironic
and that guy Hamlet cannot talk about it
why because it's safe and effective it's
not safe in effect I lost an uncle to it
I lost two neighbors to this poison so
really do the right thing for New
Hampshire citizens that's all I have to
say I'm open for comments or questions
whatever you want to be but I'm speaking
from the heart I don't have a
spreadsheet I'm speaking Point knowledge
in my heart okay sorry does anyone else
I will have to say do I am a delegate I
am running for planning board I'm
running for Budget committing my own
town I am involved in politics okay
maybe not yellow but I will be at your
level when I retire I guarantee that to
write the ship in New Hampshire okay
thank you sir any questions no no please
no no no no no applause
uh questions I'm seeing none thank you
welcome have a great day I have to go
back to work
no one else has signed up to testify I'm
assuming no one else wants to testify at
this point so I'm going to close the
public hearing on on HB 575 and I am
opening the public hearing on HP 557 and
accordingly recognizing the prime
sponsor of the Bill of representative
co-fault who is a member of our
committee
all right
oh okay well
okay okay
representative cofult are you available
for 557 uh
sorry about that
my apologies Mr chairman in the
committee uh thank you for hearing my
testimony for the record my name is Jim
cofult I represent the towns of Wilton
temple in New Ipswich which is
Hillsborough County
District 32.
so many of you in the room may be
familiar with the language of this bill
we saw something very similar to it
last year in the form of House Bill 1379
and this is
um
essentially about whether or not
the mandating of immunizations for
children in our state should be a matter
for the legislature to decide or whether
the legislature ought to delegate that
power
to to unelected people in the agencies
um
essentially
I guess I'll I'll start by kind of
breaking down where we are and how we
got here so RSA 141c
um 20a stipulates that certain
immunizations are required for children
living in the state of New Hampshire
um practically speaking this is enforced
at the uh at the child care and school
level nevertheless it is a requirement
whether a child is in child care or or
school or not
there are also certain exemptions such
as a medical exemption or a religious
exemption that families can Avail
themselves of
but
the the immunizations there are a number
of immunizations mentioned specifically
in statute which means that the
legislature at some point heard
testimony in hearings like this came to
a decision and decided that those should
be required immunizations
those include diphtheria mumps pertussis
polio rebello rubiola and tetanus
um the same RSA also specifies that the
Commissioner of Health and Human
Services has the power to adopt rules
with respect to other diseases requiring
immunization
this has led to three additional
immunization requirements being
established within administrative rule
these include varicella or chickenpox
hemophilus influenza type B and
hepatitis B
this bill is not intended to argue for
or against any of those immunizations
the you know personally I believe that
that should be a decision that rests
with each family
um the concern that I have that I've
raised before and will continue to raise
is that
the decision to mandate a medical
procedure of any kind
is a very grave decision
I believe that the people of New
Hampshire deserve to have that decision
made by their elected representatives
there is uh
you know there there is a rulemaking
process and there are there's a
potential for hearings in the rulemaking
process but let's be very clear about
the what the rulemaking process is and
is not
specifically the rulemaking process does
allow for hearings on a limited basis
but it uh you know It ultimately places
the decision in the hands of arguably a
single person there is a
a committee The Joint legislative
committee on administrative rules
consisting of legislators from both the
House and Senate who have an opportunity
to raise objections those objections
must be made on statutory terms in other
words
a majority of the committee must vote
that a rule is not authorized in statute
in order to block it from taking effect
so it's uh it's sort of the the deck is
stack that administrative rules do
become
have do do become law have the effect of
law unless members of that committee a
majority of members of that committee
find a reason
um that it it would violate statutes to
to allow it to go into effect so
um what we have heard multiple times
from the Department of Health and Human
Services is that the department does not
intend to implement required for
requirements for a covid-19 vaccination
at this time it is always qualified with
the phrase at this time and although
this is not this this bill is certainly
not specific to covid-19 I think it's a
concern for a great many people as we've
heard and um
I think that there are as we as we see
the CDC and asip uh move forward with
placing the
um the covid-19 vaccine on the list of
recommended vaccinations I think that
the concern of that possibility is
increasing and
it's interesting that a CDC director Dr
Rochelle wolinsky
um
testified a couple of weeks ago
before Congress and was asked why
why did they make the decision to put an
emergency use authorization vaccine
on the the immunization schedule for a
disease that poses very little risk to
children and for which uh the vaccine
poses many potential side effects
without actually preventing transmission
and her answer is very telling
quote
the reason that the asip recommended the
CDs the CDC put the covid-19 vaccine on
the Pediatric schedule was only because
it was the only way it could be covered
in our vaccines for children program
it was the only way that our
underinsured children would be able to
have access to the vaccines that was the
reason they put it there in other words
the CDC is now recommending vaccines not
because they're recommended not because
they're effective not because they're
helpful but because
they can provide them for free
I find that to be a sort of disturbing
development in in this process and I
think it raises concerns with respect to
what could potentially happen in New
Hampshire one of the questions that came
up the last time I presented this bill
was
um you know don't you think our current
commissioner has done a good job and the
answer was yes and I can my answer
continues to be yes with respect to the
acting commissioner as well I am very
pleased that they have actually
exercised a good deal of restraint
in not adding a lot of those asip
recommended vaccines
to the requirements in New Hampshire in
other words they've only chosen to
require a fairly small subset
having said that
I believe this legislation is necessary
because I think that these kinds of
decisions as I said before
are extraordinarily serious and that the
people of New Hampshire deserve to have
them made by elected representatives
so
um
you know we don't know what a future
Commissioner of Health and Human
Services might decide to do
so
the bill does
um
the bill does contain a provision that
last year's Bill did not
namely there's a concern that the
the immunizations that are named in rule
but not in statute
based on last year's bill would have
just disappeared as soon as that bill
went into effect and that would leave us
suddenly without a mandate for varicella
Hepatitis B or hemophilus influenza type
B
um this bill addresses that concern by
asserting that those rules would remain
in effect until their expiration date of
June 30th 2026 that would give the
legislature ample time
to bring forward legislation and and
submit those to a full public hearing
such as the one we're we're sitting
through today
so that ends my testimony and with that
Mr chairman I will take any questions
thank you representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thanks for
taking this question
um
I hear you and I agree with you about
what um an important decision it is to
either add a vaccine which it will then
be required or or not
um
and like many of the bills that maybe
all the bills that we hear there are
going to be
um
they're going to be positive things that
come out of it if we pass it
um
and there might be positive things that
come out of it if we don't pass we're
always you know we're always making a
measured decision about which is the
most positive direction to go in so my
question to you is if we were to pass
this legislation
and future decisions about vaccines were
fully in the hands of the legislature do
you have any ideas about how we could
avoid the incredible partisan
um
um turmoil
within which environment will have to
make these decisions
thank you for the question
um
people have strong feelings about this
there is no doubt
um
I generally default to the the wisdom of
parents in making these kinds of
decisions for their children I would I
guess one of the things I would point
out is that if you look at voluntary
vaccination rates and we've actually
we've we've asked this question of
Health and Human Services although I
think we didn't ask it very specifically
so if they were you know they had some
general numbers and the voluntary
vaccination rates in the state of New
Hampshire
if memory serves me correctly and
perhaps they can clarify this is
somewhere between 70 and 90 early low
90s percent on various types of vaccines
in the state of New Hampshire so the the
reality is that voluntary vaccination
rates are very high
and you know I I guess I'm I'm kind of a
Live and Let Live kind of a guy and this
to me is the sort of legislation that
that asserts that we all ought to be
able to make these decisions and and get
along reasonably uh on that basis
follow up
I think I'm also a live-in Let Live guy
and I think um
you know while we might be on different
sides of issues I also think parents
should be fully involved in making
decisions for their children my question
really is more if we're looking forward
to the legislature making decisions
about these kinds of issues not families
um
how can we avoid the kind of intense
partisan conflict and that that we're
seeing in the room today to be perfectly
honest with you and how is that a good
environment to make these decisions
thank you for the question I guess I I
would just respond that I think a good
healthy debate is is good
um it
I think it bothers me as much as anybody
when I see that an unhealthy debate
um and so I think it's just incumbent
upon all of us to try to maintain that
kind of a tone yes it will get
um you know it can get heated at times
because people have strong feelings
about it but I I think we can we can do
well and it deserves a public hearing
another discussion yes representative
McLean
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um
um maybe you could kind of inform the
committee a little bit about some of the
history as to what because it used to be
just statute and then it evolved to to
Grant this rule-making Authority were
there any concerns or issues that drove
the decision to kind of move in that
direction that you're aware of
thank you for the question so I
um I I would probably defer to the folks
from from DHHS here who who can State
their concerns I know that one concern
that has come up in these discussions
fairly frequently is what if there's an
emergency if there's a public health
emergency and we have to act fast
um I would say I have a couple of
responses to that first of all that the
um the voluntary rate of vaccination is
very high even for the covid-19 vaccine
which many people were you know were
questioning had a very very high rate of
voluntary vaccination in the state of
New Hampshire
um the the other thing I would point out
is that under the emergency statute the
governor has pretty broad Powers
um and
can can can issue mandates if there is a
grave Public Health concern there so
um I think that there are there are ways
to handle those those concerns uh
without necessarily granting the sort of
blanket uh Power for mandating new
immunizations
other questions
and rep representative Missouri yep
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um so I hear that so
that this bill removes the rule-making
authority from DHHS and then I heard
someone else say that it hands it over
to the legislature but I don't see that
authority of legislature on here did I
miss something
just just by virtue that the power the
legislature is is endowed by the
Constitution with the power to make laws
so
um
it it's the what is already in statute
so if you look at the bill
um line four
um that's what
the legislature has already deemed
should be a required immunization under
under state law
thank you
a little bit
so yeah so I guess my concern with that
a little bit is
what representative Shapiro alluded to
is
um
so majority versus minority in the
legislature and how a decision
this could be a like a big
if something like covid comes up again
and
in a future uh where the majority
mandates something that is against the
will of the people
uh
that concerns me a little bit but so so
last year there was a bill before this
committee which would have mandated the
covid-19 vaccine for
the bill called them children but it was
children up to age 26
including anyone enrolled in an
Institute of higher education which
might include children up to age 99 for
for all we know I would have to go back
and read that bill to get it exactly but
those kinds of bills do come before us
um that one I think was was retained or
it yelled fairly quickly we I think are
going to be hearing a bill later that
would repeal the medical freedom in
immunizations act so
um also part of 141 a or C actually at
141c I believe so it it's it is within
our power as a legislature to to decide
these things unless somebody wants to
um sort of assert in the Constitution
that we don't yeah
other questions
representative Cushman
thank you for taking my question
um so I'm
to follow up on uh representative
mazur's uh question
there is more public input
when the legislature is required to take
up a bill as opposed to when the
department proposes an administrative
rule is that correct yes it is
absolutely and and that's part of my
concern and part of the reason I I
raised this bill is you know
fundamentally that these things should
be decided by The People's elected
representatives but
um that the the hearing process the
public input process is is considerably
greater in the legislative process than
it is in the rulemaking process
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative I
have a question related to the
rulemaking process and what Authority
jailcar has
um it's it's my understanding that gel
Carr can only reject a bill if it's
contrary to current statutes so with the
current statute of medical freedom and
immunizations they would not be able to
to add the covid-19 vaccination through
rulemaking however if that was removed
it would be fair game is that correct
can you repeat the last part of your
question again I'm sorry that rules can
only be rejected if they're contrary to
the statutes and there's currently a
statute that prohibits mandating the
covid-19 vaccine for any public benefit
which would include school
um
there there is a
so so the current so 141's
141c actually stipulates that this is a
requirement for every child in New
Hampshire
it would be interesting to explore what
you just said which is you know if if it
becomes a condition for attending a
public school could it then be excluded
um that would that would put people in
the unusual position that homeschoolers
could then be mandated the coveted
vaccine whereas everybody else would not
so it's
it's I think it's it's Uncharted
Territory
thank you
representative Weber
you agree
with a slightly different
formulation of the authority of jalcar
which is that I believe that the review
is whether or not the decision they are
taking
is one that has been
one that is within the powers that have
been appropriatedly
appropriately delegated to them by
Statute
so the review is in this case
is would be very limited because
the legislature currently has delegated
a fairly broad authority to the
commissioner whereas in other statutes
we have limited it much more
and it's not necessarily a review
about every other Statute in
the Canon thank you for the question
that that is actually my understanding
is that it it is not gel car's
um responsibility to review every
administrative rule
um and whether it conforms to the entire
body of of revised statutes
but rather does it conform to the
authority delegated in this specific
instance and in this case being the
authority delegated under 141c20
what's that representative
are you all set okay
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair
and thank you representative Koval
taking the question it's would you be
willing to amend this so that
the oversight committee for DHHS before
it goes to rulemaking weighs in on the
rule itself
I am I am concerned about watering down
the intent of this bill the intent of
this bill is that the legislature the
people's Representatives as a body not
as a small subset of the body but as a
body makes decisions of this gravity
um you know they're they're I'll leave
it at that
other questions
seeing no other questions thank you
representative thank you
I'm going to step out for a while and
I'm going to turn over the meeting to
representative Leon the vice chairman of
the committee
thank you next we will call Ryan tannian
and Dr Benjamin Chan from the Department
good afternoon Madam Vice chair Leon
representatives of the committee again
my name is Ryan Tanya and I'm a
registered pharmacist and chief of the
Bureau of Infectious Disease Control at
the division of Public Health Services
and the department of health human
health health and human services did you
bring the microphone a little bit closer
there's people watching at home I'm
joined with me today by Dr Benjamin Chan
an infectious disease physician and the
New Hampshire State epidemiologist and
we are here today to speak in opposition
to House Bill 557 which is stated is
relative to the rulemaking authority
regarding
point of order
um when the Departments come are they
supposed to give aren't they supposed to
be neutral and only offer technical
advice I don't believe they're supposed
to oppose or there is no such rule
they often choose to just come and give
us technical advice but they have a
right to Advocate and sometimes some
departments not the particularly this
one I have seen advocate in ways that I
think is far exceeding what I think
there should be Authority should be but
they have that right
um and and particularly as it pertains
to their particular
area of expertise and control
thank you
thank you so preventing the spread of
infectious disease in our schools and
child care settings is a important
Public Health function we believe that
New Hampshire children and communities
are best protected by keeping the
rule-making Authority for immunization
requirements for the attendance at
schools and child care agencies should
rest with the Commissioner of Health and
Human Services and the department as
defined in RSA 141c
there's currently a transparent process
to remove or add vaccines for school and
child care requirement requirements and
it also encourages input from all
stakeholders including the public and
the legislature
so the department not only engages with
clinical and infectious disease experts
but the public and policy makers from
start to finish during this process
first the administrative rules process
is transparent open to the public and it
considers the input of all stakeholders
and an example of this is in September
of 2022 we the department worked
collaboratively with stakeholders and
legislators on the joint legislative
committee on administrative rules or gel
car to develop a process and a new form
which actually reduces barriers for
parents and legal Guardians who are
seeking religious exemptions for
vaccinations for school or Child Care
attendance
second from the last legislative session
House Bill 1379 which is similar to this
bill that was referred to the Senate to
a study committee and that study
committee was titled the listing of
immunizations for children
and that committee was chaired by
Senator Kevin avard and the intent of
that committee was to review the list of
vaccinations for school and child care
attendance as a result that committee
was comprised of both members of the
Senate and the house and the final
report of that committee contained
recommendations from Individual
committee members however it did not
issue recommendations based on a
majority consensus after a thorough
review
and third another outcome of the
previous uh legislative session was the
passage of House Bill 1045 which as we
mentioned previously
establishes the ethics oversight
advisory committee and legislative
oversight was incorporated into the
structure of this committee and includes
members of both the House and Senate in
addition to a diverse group of
stakeholders
and should the commissioner consider
changes to the list of vaccinations that
are required for a school of child care
attendance the ethics oversight
committee would convene and review these
recommendations
and then the department does have a
comprehensive review process anytime a
new vaccine is added for school or Child
Care attendance these decisions are
uncommon and infrequent they're actually
only made after extensive discussion
including input and recommendations from
subject matter experts in the fields of
medicine and vaccine science and then
the last time for example a vaccine was
added to this list was in 2003 for
varicilla which actually came eight
years after FDA and ASAP approval
and then in addition to vaccine safety
and efficacy the department does take
into consideration consideration methods
of transmission likelihood of infection
and then we also take into account the
potential Health impacts for both
individuals and communities including
those who are most vulnerable and that
would also include persons where
immunizations May otherwise be
contraindicated due to medical reasons
which would place them at a higher risk
of adverse outcomes
and then we do oppose House Bill 557 due
to the removal of varicella hepatitis B
and haemophilus influenza type B
vaccinations when their listing expires
in June 2026 these diseases are highly
infectious in school-aged children and
in severe cases can result in permanent
death or disability I will hand that
over to Dr Benjamin Chan to discuss
further
thank you madam Vice chair and members
of the committee I will keep my remarks
short I just wanted to expand on what Dr
tanyan mentioned about uh these three
vaccines varicella Hepatitis B virus and
haemophilus influenza type B I I
understand from representative co-fulton
hearing his comments that the intent is
to give some time for the legislature to
potentially adopt these vaccines into
you know RSA 141c however I think our
concern here is that if no action is
taken and this uh house bill
um 557 passes that these three vaccines
will be dropped from the required list
and I don't want to go into a lot of
detail I think you have our testimony
there's some information on these three
vaccines
um sort of outlining details as to why
these vaccines remain on the required
vaccination list I will simply leave it
at saying that these are highly
effective vaccines with the primary
Series right so they don't require
repeated boosting and that these
diseases have the potential to either
cause large outbreaks or are highly
infectious person to person
or have significant and potentially
severe Health consequences for people
and so just as an example of that
varicella the virus that causes
chickenpox most people will develop a
febrile rash illness the chickenpox
illness and most people will develop a
mild illness and get better but this is
a virus particularly in people who are
immunocompromised but even in in
immunocompetent people this is a virus
that can cause serious disease central
nervous system infection meningitis
Encephalitis and actually before the
Advent of the vaccine it was estimated
that about one per 100
000 children who got varicella died from
their infection right so we don't see
severe disease much anymore and in large
part it's because of the implementation
and high vaccination rates amongst our
children and amongst our populations so
take a look at the testimony please
there's more detail sort of justifying
why these three vaccines in particular
are on the required list but I will
leave it at that and thank you for your
time and uh happy to take questions
thank you very much before we take
questions I do want to make an
announcement as many people are coming
back in from lunch the only food or
drink that is allowed in this room is
water because we have had some problems
before with coffee and other drinks
spilling so if anybody has those I'd
please ask them to take them out of the
room and now we'll take questions
representative McLean
uh thank you madam chair and thank you
uh for taking my question gentlemen so
um you testified uh two quick questions
so you testified about the transparency
of the rulemaking process and it does
sound like it's very transparent but I
think the legislature in addition to
being transparent there's a certain
amount of accountability there you know
just ask anybody who's had to kind of
stand at the polls so I would just kind
of you know follow up on the question
that I asked to the prime sponsor what
was the driver to kind of move it into
the administrative rules role and the
second question would just be
um understanding that
um would you support the bill if um the
the three immunizations listed for um
song setting in 2026 were moved into the
Bill thank you
thank you
sure thank you for the question so if I
am following correct the first question
uh is surrounding the the rulemaking
process exactly what was the Genesis
because it used to be statues and so
there was a migration sure uh so
in full transparency that was something
that did happen uh prior to my time but
from talking with other members within
the department as representative
colfault had mentioned
um one concern that the department does
have is if we do have to respond to an
emerging or imminent threat related to a
communicable disease so the
by having it out of Statute and in the
administrative rules process and having
the commissioner have this Authority it
does make our department we have the
ability to act more nimbly and swiftly
in these cases
and I'll just add that it was also
before my time as as you heard Dr tanian
mentioned the last vaccine that was
added to the requirement list was in
2003 which was you know a good decade
before I started at the state but my
understanding also is that it was added
to provide more flexibility particularly
of vaccine recommendations change which
they periodically do to be able to more
readily add vaccines or remove vaccines
from from the list I think an answer to
your second question
um you know moving those three vaccines
from the rules into the into the
legislation you know I think I think
that that depends on what happens with
this bill and the Authority for for rule
making you know certainly if this
proposed legislation passes that we
would you know support that move into
full legislation
um but the process as it is now
um I I'm not I don't I don't know that
there's a huge difference to having with
the current process to having those
vaccines listed in the in the current
rulemaking process versus the you know
RSA 141c but there may be you know
technical experts that are more familiar
with the differences between you know
the rules and the and the RS uh the um
the law thanks
representative Merchant
thank you madam chair and also thank you
again for taking my question
what I heard was the last time we added
a vaccine was 2000 2003
varicella
so that's almost 20 years ago
so if we were to lock down and say these
are the last vaccine that can be added
without legislative approval would that
be acceptable to the agency given the
fact that we don't do it so often to
begin with
thank you for the question
representative Merchant so
um
any proposed amendments or changes to
this is something that we would probably
take under advisement internally at the
department we would consult with other
subject matter experts we would you know
engage the legislature or our other
stakeholders and then we would also look
to the ethics oversight committee on
that topic as well follow-up follow-up
thank you madam chair
the other part with rulemaking
many times I would say many times but
there are times in which the CDC will
change the frequency in which a vaccine
is given not so much the requirement for
the vaccine but the way it's
administered so would you be
commenting if you will if we type take
rulemaking away completely then that
means that the agency wouldn't have the
ability to change the rules to adapt to
what's going on with CDC guidelines
yeah I I believe that's correct and
that's one of the benefits I think to
keeping and one of the intents between
why some vaccines are in the rule making
process versus in RSA 141c it's exactly
for the point that you outline the
flexibility to be able to change when
vaccine recommendations change right so
so we're not necessarily changing which
vaccines are added or removed but there
may be a change in the frequency of
vaccination
um and the rule making process as it is
now allows I believe that that
flexibility is my understanding
representative Weber
thank you madam chair because whoever is
presiding under our custom and usage is
referred to as the chair
um and thank you very much for taking my
question
um I just want to be clear
it's true is it not that
we've been we've been talking about the
gel car process which is Byzantine and
confusing but prior to the gel car
process and prior to a rule being
adopted in the first place by the
commissioner
is the commissioner not required to not
only hold public hearings on the
adoption of the rule before it's adopted
but
is that hearing and notice of that
hearing not given in a publication that
the department puts out regularly that
anybody may look up what their what the
hearings coming up are
thank you for the question so
to answer simply yes okay that is
correct
if you know do they hold more than one
hearing or just one hearing I know we
are at the legislature hold only one
it's one hearing okay so we're on the
same plane there and could I have one
follow-up Madam chair yes
um
I noticed that you emailed testimony
today uh
did you hand in a written copy or did
you file it online did somebody file it
online because our rule is that
testimony that's merely emailed doesn't
become part of the record and the online
testimony or that which is handed in on
paper
is our testimony so have you filed one
of those other ways yes we do have
written testimony that we will provide
okay thank you
representative mazur thank you madam
chair thanks for taking my question
um so the CDC has recently implemented
the Cova vaccine into their schedule for
children correct
yes that's correct and but you have not
in New Hampshire is that correct
that is correct can you tell me why
sure
so uh I will start with that thank you
for the question Dr Chan will follow up
um so the department has said in
multiple different testimonies that we
do not intend to require the kova 19
vaccine or the influenza vaccine as part
of child care or School requirements the
reasons for that I will let Dr Chan
explain
yeah so I will just say that um the so
thank you for the question
um and I just want to be clear that we
have no intent of adding the kova 19
vaccine to the required list of vaccines
for um schools or Child Care entry
um and the reason for that is very
similar exactly that actually the same
reason why we don't add the info the
annual influenza vaccine
um every year as a requirement for uh
child care or School entry
um and that's because uh it's looking
like the kova 19 vaccine will become
likely and again this isn't set in stone
but likely an annual booster vaccine
so there are a number of things we look
at when deciding on whether or not to
add a vaccine to the required list
um all of the vaccines that are on the
list now are for diseases that are
easily transmissible person to person
able to cause large outbreaks have
potential potentially severe
complications for people that get
infected not everybody but certainly a
proportion of people that get infected
will have severe complications but
importantly the vaccines also are highly
effective and have very long lasting
protection
against infection against disease
with just a primary series that does not
apply to the kova 19 vaccine as we
stated I think in earlier testimony
protection against infection and disease
wanes over time it Remains the covid-19
vaccine remains protective against more
severe outcomes of disease and that's
the primary goal now of covid-19
vaccination but because it's looking
like the covid-19 vaccine is moving
towards an annual booster similar to why
we don't recommend or require the flu
vaccine every year we do recommend the
flu vaccine everywhere we don't require
it for school or child entry similar
reasons we have no plans on on adding
the kova 19 vaccine
quick follow-up
follow-up I say this in just but can I
get that in writing
I I mean it's it's in the um
it's in the committee uh the study
committees
report that was filed the one uh chaired
by senator avard
it actually specifically mentions by
name too I guess
thank you representative
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question uh you you mentioned
the immunocompromised and varicella uh
can you tell me what the main mechanism
of protecting
immunocompromised for example in case of
Federal cell is it that vaccine gives
immunity to immuno compromised or is it
more like a herd immunity that other
people want transmit it because it stop
transmission
yeah so thanks for the question I think
I think your question is about how how
the particularly the varicella vaccine
Works
um I I will say that uh that the purpose
of um vaccination is for both protection
of the individual and also preventing
transmission and creating herd herd
immunity
um
the I mean the varicella virus the
chickenpox virus is one of those virus
that is a true Airborne virus and if you
look at data on what we call secondary
attack rates that's the the rate of
transmission in a susceptible population
like a household for example if you have
a person introduced varicella or
chickenpox into a household and the
people in the household are not
protected not immune
um you know the the attack rate is
upwards of like 60 to 100 percent and so
that applies also to situations like
Child Care settings schools where you
have because it's an Airborne virus it
has the potential for
large transmission events large
outbreaks and so the purpose of
vaccination is to not only protect the
individual particularly you know
including immunocompromised people
against severe complications of disease
but also preventing outbreaks like we
can see with chickenpox
um thank you that's Public Health then
has to investigate and respond to
um and I have a question for you as well
um are the only vaccines that are
offered by the state um those that are
on this list or is there some other
program that um recommends them and is
there any sort of encouragement by the
state for that other list
thank you for the question Madam chair
so the as Dr Chan said this is a
small list of the vaccines that are when
you look at asip as a whole there's 17
different vaccines that are recommended
for the this age group and population
we're discussing there are nine for
school age kids that are a requirement
for school and child care attendance and
then there are 10 for the younger age in
the uh specifically the child care and
preschool settings so not all ASAP
recommended vaccines are required for
school
however as part of our vaccines for
children program which is a mechanism to
purchase these vaccines and provide to
New Hampshire providers
that when vaccines are approved have an
ASAP recommendation and then we discuss
it and agree internally
at the state if we choose to offer this
to New Hampshire providers then that
would be another mechanism
thank you and then as follow-up are
there any repercussions on the providers
if they have patients who choose not to
take those recommended vaccines
no so I I think it's important to um
differentiate so so the vaccines for
children program the vfc program is an
access program
and it has cost implications
um but there's no like repercussions if
something like somebody can choose to
get vaccinated or not under the vfc
program the vfc program simply is a
program by which
um state government can purchase vaccine
at a reduced rate from the federal
government on federal government
contract and then give it to Providers
to administer if the patient chooses to
uh free of charge essentially meaning
the vaccine is free of charge there's no
cost to the person for that vaccine
there may be an administration fee for
you know Health Care Personnel time for
example but there's no charge for That
vaccine or somebody can get the vaccine
essentially for free and so it's it's a
cost access program it has really
nothing to do with whether or not
somebody chooses to get vaccinated or
not and I was under the impression that
providers who have unvaccinated patients
from that list are financially
accountable for that through lower rates
or through otherwise having to pay for
it when it's done used is there are
there financial implications for
pediatricians that have unvaccinated
patients on that list
thank you for the question so
specifically through the vaccines for
children program no
um
however I can't speak to the Managed
Care contracts that physicians may have
independently with managed care or
accountable care organizations thank you
nope another question from
representative palazzov thank you madam
chair thank you for taking my other
question uh can you tell a little bit
more uh about uh process of adding or
removing vaccines from this list uh you
mentioned some criteria that you use but
I wonder like what vaccine is closest to
be added to the list and also like what
you see in any perceivable future some
of this vaccines been dropped for
example let's for the sake of argument
say that poly militis will be I'm almost
teledicated worldwide would it be some
risk benefit analysis that might be it's
time to develop this vaccinations here
if we don't see this disease around
anymore thank you
um
so if I understand your question
correctly it's about adding and removing
vaccines and what I will say is that
there are not any vaccines that I'm
aware of that we are actively discussing
adding to this list
and in terms of removal there are no
vaccines listed here that we would
support removal of you mentioned
poliomyelitis and I'll just point to the
situation occurring outside of New York
City right now where they have
identified local transmission of polio
for the first time in you know decades
in the U.S and so you know there's a
saying you know disease anywhere is
disease everywhere so you know polio is
still a problem in other parts of the
world
um and the risk for importation
um either from other areas of the globe
or from other areas of the U.S the risk
for importation of um many of these
diseases remains
seeing no further questions thank you
very much
next we'll call The Honorable Jerry
knurk
who I had the pleasure of serving on
that study committee with representative
kenark Senator avard and representative
kofault this summer
and I'll remind you we're doing three
minutes so we'll see how close we get
yes and for the record Jerry canerkin
yes I did serve in the SB 288 Senate uh
so study subcommittee and I'm actually
here to oppose HB 557 their current
system in place in DHHS for determining
required immunizations is appropriate
and cautious the decision is not made
lightheartedly it requires uh when
you're going to change it by rule you
have the CDC ASAP recommendations and
you have to be approved by gel Carr with
a public hearing but the point is the
department weighs the medical risks of a
given disease with regard to its
communicability the seriousness of
infection and the risks of immunization
the department takes into account also
the burdens on child care providers and
schools to comply
all required vaccinations are highly
effective in preventing disease and
serious outcomes and there are clear
mechanisms for children to be Exempted
from vaccine requirement for other
medical reasons or religious exemption
immunization again really important to
keep understanding this that
immunization has done not just to
protect the child being immunized but
the other members of the community this
is particularly important to protect
children who are unable to be immunized
or cannot mount a protective response to
immunization either due to the fact they
have cancer they're immunosuppressed
and an infected child in the classroom
can easily infect those vulnerable
children or probably most at risk of
getting complications of the disease
rubella is especially a problem a child
infected at school can bring it home in
fact their mother their pregnant mother
leading to her infection and then severe
damage to the fetus from congenital
rubella syndrome and that is a real
problem we don't see much because of
vaccination a lot of the checks the
vaccination or childhood diseases are
indeed rare and it's because of
vaccination which is why you don't take
them off scattered outbreaks still occur
in pockets of immunization that are low
in order to prevent an outbreak you have
to have a high level of immunization and
representative Koval just noted when he
made his introduction that making
immunizations required rather than the
recommended didn't make a big impact
because it only increased the rate from
about 80 to 90 percent but actually that
is important a loss of just a few
percent makes a difference and during
covid with the decrease in people coming
in to see their doctor
um and uh there there was a big
difference of just three percent in the
vaccination rate in Minnesota and they
saw an outbreak of measles so it's
sensitive you have to keep a high level
and it does make a difference whether
it's just 80 percent or 90 percent
consideration to include a vaccination
includes not just the health of the
child and the others with whom the child
may come in contact but also the health
of the school
some diseases require a child to be
quarantined for a period of time if
they're exposed leading to many children
then needing to be out of the classroom
if somebody comes in with a communicable
disease you don't have to do that if
they're immunized so that's another
important point
and as the department has said they have
no interest in adding coveted vaccine
for the very reasons that were
recommended or stated and that is that
it's going to appear to be perhaps like
the flu vaccine compliance and
documentation would be difficult for the
schools and child cares and that's why
it's not there
I disagree with removing the language in
lines four and five which would take
away the power of the commissioner to
add other immunizations by rule when
necessary
the department should retain that power
to implement an immunization requirement
under rule in order to deal with a
sudden unexpected outbreak of a
communicable disease we never know
what's going to be coming down the road
the legislative process is too slow to
respond in a Nimble process now in a
Nimble fashion I should say
Gathering the legislature in a special
session in the situation of an outbreak
of a communicable disease would be
medically unwise and it would require a
two-thirds majority vote to enact a
change leaving the department without
one of its most important tools to use
in dealing with an outbreak we should
not tie the hands of our Public Health
officials leaving them unable to
effectively respond to a public health
emergency representative kovalt also
discussed using a public health
emergency to address this but you know
we kind of saw that during covid the
Declaration of Public Health Emergency
wasn't exactly welcomed with open arms
that's not necessarily well received
either so in summary Matt oh
sorry
I was going to say that in in having
objected before when somebody was going
over I felt it was impelling to object
but if you're summarizing I mean I saw
where he was when it dinged in summary
the current decision-making process uh
adding immunization requirements by rule
is appropriate to protect children
protect the community and maximize the
ability of children to stay in school
while still respecting parental rights
thank you and I'll take questions if you
haven't representative Shapiro
thank you madam chair and thank you for
taking my question I'll ask you the same
question I asked the sponsor of the bill
which is
um
it seems to me that essentially where
the legislature currently is delegating
the responsibility to Public Health
officials and medical officials to make
these or at least to facilitate making
these decisions I understand that
there's a growing distrust of
of medical people and Public Health
um but I'll ask you the same question I
asked representative kofolt which is if
this legislation should pass and it
should fall to the legislature to make
these decisions
can you conceive of any way that these
decisions could be made with less
partisanship and less contentiousness
than is currently the atmosphere
not really um and I think that we should
not be legislating the practice of
medicine deciding what vaccinations you
know should be there is really basically
the practice of medicine Public Health
in this case rather than individual but
we should not be dictating that as a
group of legislators because well to be
perfectly blunt there's an enormous
amount of misinformation around which a
lot of people believe and it is a
problem because it makes it difficult to
make clear-eyed decisions
thank you
seeing no further questions thank you
very much thank you next we have Dr Nass
and uh we're going to try sticking to
that three minutes
I'll let this ring a little bit longer
for everybody since everybody seems to
be going a little bit long
honorable members and Senators my name
is Dr Merrill Nas and I'm testifying in
in favor of hb557
um by the way many states do adopt the
entire asip recommended schedule as a
requirement for attending school and
it's wonderful that New Hampshire does
not
why should decisions regarding
vaccination protocols be reserved to the
legislature it's claimed that the DHHS
has the experts but the department is
unelected not answerable to Citizens and
might not always act in their best
interests
um there are four things I want to point
out the health department takes its cues
and significant funding from the federal
CDC during the last three years the
federal CDC has shown itself to be both
politicized and unable to carry out its
mission
um I'll point out that the life
expectancy has fallen three years for
all Americans in that time
the headlines tell the story New York
Times wolensky citing botched pandemic
response calls for CDC reorganization
CNN CDC needs a reset requiring support
from the federal level new Think Tank
report fines
Daily Mail CDC is not fit for purpose
has lost the Public's trust and needs a
complete overhaul says report by
agency's former director if I can
interrupt you I appreciate those parts
of it you can submit those but we just
don't want to be going too much against
different agencies if you can go more to
the facts of this bill
yes um so federal agencies
have given large Financial grants to
State agencies to promote covid as well
as other vaccinations but particularly
covid five trillion dollars has been
spent on the federal pandemic response
by September of 2021.
um Financial incentives are likely to
result in rule making to mandate
vaccinations even of experimental and
inadequately tested vaccines and in
Maine rulemaking has recently added
mandates for both children and health
care workers of vaccines
third the CDC okay fourth the CDC just
added covid messenger RNA vaccines to
the childhood schedule only two weeks
ago encouraging states to promote or
mandate them no wonder New Hampshire
hasn't tried to add them because it was
only added by the Aesop two weeks ago
the bivalent boosters underwent no human
testing before their rollout this is the
first time CDC put an experimental
unlicensed product on the childhood
schedule ever
such irresponsible Behavior should not
be repeated at the state level and only
the legislature can be relied on to
prevent it we know the risk of covid
vaccine-induced myocarditis is high in
teenagers up to according to CDC up to
one diagnosed case per 5000 doses or 30
to 90 times the Baseline risk and I've
provided you with graphs from FDA and
CDC confirming this
yet last month children were being given
75 dollar gift cards to get vaccinated
in Amherst Massachusetts and the town
was paid two thousand dollars by the
state to host a vaccine clinic these are
vaccines for which the manufacturers
have and the state and the government
and the federal government have no
liability
so if you could wrap up your testimony
four months after an Amherst High School
student died during a track meet and it
was known that her autopsy showed her
death was due to myocarditis
and Amherst the Amherst schools hosted
this vaccine clinic after one of their
own students had died
hopefully New Hampshire will be more
careful there's never been a more
crucial time for you to protect the
citizens from overreach by federal and
state Executive offices thank you thank
you are there any questions
and if you could hand the testimony in
for our clerk so we can make that part
of the record
um I only have one copy but
um one copy is actually fine because he
puts it all into a record so people can
see this in the future super it's
actually quite fantastic
thank you next we have thank you very
much for the testimony next we have Lynn
Linda painter
hi and you have three minutes and you
need to push the button so your
microphone is on
no it needs to be okay oh it needs to be
read good morning my name is Lynn Lind
painter thank you very much for hearing
my testimony today I'm a retired doctor
I live here in Concord I practiced
medicine for nearly 40 years most
recently at Concord Hospital I'm here to
speak in opposition to House Bill 557
and bear with me my testimony begins
with a story about when I was a medical
student in 1983.
that was when I had the opportunity to
study and work in Bangladesh for two
months and at that time Bangladesh was
one of the very poorest nations in the
world that probably still is
there was essentially no Public Health
infrastructure in the country at that
time fewer than one in ten children
single digit rate of vaccinations was
available against communicable disease
at that time and it was very common
very common for children to die before
the age of five
think about that for a moment
in Bangladesh I witnessed children and
babies dying of preventable diseases
diseases like tetanus which we also call
lockjaw and that is a truly horrible way
to die I've never seen even one case in
my training
or in my practice in the United States
and I remember at the time so many years
ago suddenly realizing that gosh if
these kids had been living in the U.S
they would not be dying because they
would have been protected
um
that was my most Vivid lesson from that
entire interesting experience it was to
realize suddenly as a young doctor how
fortunate I was to have grown up in the
United States which was a country with
the resources the will and the public
health infrastructure and professionals
which are successful in protecting its
citizens
protecting me with vaccinations
there have been vaccine requirements in
this country ever since 1855 when
Massachusetts was the first required
state to require smallpox vaccinations
for school children we that are living
today and our children have been well
protected it's not surprising to me that
we've forgotten as a nation how serious
and dangerous these these infections are
and how serious they are in an
unvaccinated population as we've just
heard even a decrement of three percent
in a vaccine rate leads to outbreaks
um
at the same time we have recent memory
of an imperfect Public Health response
to a terrible epidemic pandemic we all
know bad it's present in our minds and
we want to do something about it and I
sense that this bill may have come out
of that wish which is legitimate but I
disagree with the means that are being
proposed
we want to be better prepared of course
when not if but when the next pandemic
occurs
and to me being more prepared now I'm
getting to the bill this means we need
to strengthen our Public Health System
not weaken it
it's been responsible for our successes
and we don't want to change horses in
Midstream and start legislating Medical
Care we've been successful Take the Long
View
this bill would weaken it by removing
the rulemaking authority of the
commissioner that we've already heard
quite a bit about I won't repeat that
if you could wrap up you're already past
three minutes please yes I just would
ask you
as elected officials to and continue to
entrust these scientific judgments to
the public health professionals and to
support their work in other ways thank
you very much I'll be happy to answer
any questions
thank you are there any questions
and if you have a copy of your written
testimony the clerk would love that
thank you so much
Dr Lynn painter I am so sorry that you
retired
it's a sad way to find out thank you
thank you next we have Laura Condon
and three minutes Laura
thank you
good afternoon my name is Laura Condon
I'm from Bedford and I'm here to support
House Bill 557 I'm the New Hampshire
director of advocacy it's a volunteer
position with the national vaccine
information center I've also served five
years as public member and the board of
directors of the New Hampshire vaccine
Association and very familiar with
vaccines at DHHS requires and purchases
and sells when the legislature gave the
commissioner authority to determine
vaccine requirements by rule there are
only seven vaccines listed in statute
and DHHS was not in the vaccine business
much has changed since then and Time Has
Come For The expansive inclusive
oversight the legislature to determine
any additional vaccine requirements
imposed on children to relieve the
commissioner of that Authority also
since that time DHHS has put in the
vaccine business per RSA 126q capturing
and fully controlling the entire Market
of vaccines targeted at children
per the New Hampshire vaccine
Association for fiscal year 2022 there's
expected vaccine participle the 33
million dollars what was once a two
million dollar vaccine purchase program
in 2000 and 2 has now become a big
business for DHHS this is an unchecked
unaccountable State vaccine business
there's no public input to vaccine
selections and more costly combo
vaccines are being purchased as a
combined three four five vaccines in one
shot all at once parents no longer have
the option of getting just one vaccine
at a time there's no reporting in any
measurable health benefits
DHHS purchases vaccines from the CDC and
is rewarded with grant money to run
their immunization division there now
exists a huge financial incentive to
mandate and sell as many vaccines as
possible this of course conflicts with
the duty of Public Health to protect
Public Health from harm one cannot
ethically be in the business of buying
and selling vaccines and also overseeing
Public Safety with regard to vaccine use
the commission should be relieved of
this terrible conflict of interest oh my
gosh how do we ever get to this many
doses many people think it's three or
four shots we got here because of
vaccine failure while many think that
vaccine failure is a new thing because
of the total failure of the coveted
shots to prevent infection illness or
spread vaccine failure has been with us
since the beginning of vaccine use the
vaccines you may have gotten 50 years
ago have long since been pulled for the
market for either vaccine failure or
harm or both give me again I'm going to
give you an example the Hepatitis B that
they've added the conflicts with it Dr
Chan's testimony the Hepatitis B is an
adult lifestyle illness caused mostly by
per the CDC Italy go IV drug abusers and
men who have sex with men it is not an
illness of childhood and should never
have been added as a daycare and school
requirement
something as serious the vaccines
requires a full and thorough review
before imposing requirements on children
or adults especially the new coveted
shots only the legislature is positioned
to provide the thorough and complete
evaluation of all possible need for
vaccines the benefits risk and failures
it is only in this venue that all people
can weigh in including doctors and
various other medical experts in
addition to the parents whose legal
responsibility and loving duties to care
for and protect their children from harm
there are many eyes and Minds involved
in this legislative process and there is
no process more thorough whereas the
rulemaking process allows I'm wrapping
up the commissioner to impose any and
all vaccine requirements that he desires
and I can tell you is one who's probably
attempted to to testify before gel carb
more than anybody else in the state it
is not an open process you often do not
have the opportunity to testify and
often or shut out
with DHHS now being in the vaccine
business it would be appropriate for the
legislature to remove the commissioner's
Authority and retake their legislative
Authority and duty to perform to
determine vaccine requirements I urge
House Bill 557 as ought to pass and if I
may representative land you asked a
couple of questions about
um so we can put that into questions for
you okay thank you that Dr Chan did not
provide you with answers for but I have
answers for you
do you have a question for me thank you
yes I have a question our providers uh
penalized if they do not provide the
vaccines and the vaccines for children
program in in fact providers um the DHHS
has taken captive the entire child
vaccine Market in New Hampshire doctors
are not allowed to purchase their own
vaccines and maintain their own
inventory they must take inventory from
DHHS in order to get that inventory they
must sign a contract as a vfc contract
and I'd provide you with a copy that
says that they shall take all vaccines
and promote all vaccines furthermore the
CDC requires that they are personally
liable for any wasted vaccine so a
couple of contracts they they must abide
by could you provide those to the
committee in writing I I certainly will
are there any other questions
thank you very much for wealth of
information as always yeah you would
also asked why the somebody had asked
why the coveted shots weren't required
and Dr Chan said that those are
anticipated
if we could call hold everybody to the
same standards yes we we held everybody
to that time if you'd like to add that
email to the committee with that extra
information about why it wasn't added
okay thank you
and if he could bring your testimony
we'd love to put that in the record
electronic access that that wasn't part
of the record that's also part of the
record this is also another way to
capture it to make sure that both the
digital and the in-person are
appropriately included and and just to
be clear I was only concerned about
somebody who had only emailed not the
people who submitted the testimony
electronically through that process and
I will also say that we do actually read
our emails and and so I often get
supplemental uh clarification from
people
yes and thank you next we have Dr
Jennifer Smith
three minutes
welcome back thank you um
Madam chair
um and members of the committee
um I do not have written testimony I
like the power of story and I hope there
are enough of you here to
deal with that and and keep it in mind
um
20 years ago almost I decided I really
wanted a public health degree in
addition to my medical degree and I
started working part-time at New
Hampshire hospital providing Medical
Care
for people with chronic
mental illness and I started studying
Public Health at Dartmouth
and very pleased with that education and
part way through that the the medical
director of New Hampshire hospital asked
me
to comment on the request he had for New
Hampshire hospital to do certain things
under a pandemic response
it was really eye-opening to see how
poorly things were being planned on
pandemic response and that's been true
and
compounded our difficulties in the early
stages of this pandemic
and we had probably a far greater loss
of people than we needed to have because
of that
and getting into that why that happened
is hard to say but just be aware
this is not the last pandemic that
younger people are likely to see and
maybe some of us old people too
this was not the pandemic that when I
was studying Public Health we expected
to see sometime soon and actually we've
been talking about it before I studied
Public Health
we expected another influenza pandemic
similar to 1819
00 18 1919
and that was truly a terrible
pandemic there was no chance of
immunization for that
and it actually didn't stop in two years
it took three years and people got so
much pandemic fatigue that people
started ignoring at the third year you
see I still have my mask on
I will continue to do that in places
where I just don't know enough about who
I'm with
because I think it's really serious and
that could happen again and when we see
that happen again if another major
pandemic influenza hits I think we need
the ability
to mandate a vaccine for children if
it's hitting them hard
and and some of the pandemic
strains we've seen which have not been
anything like the 1918-1919 have hit
children pretty hard
um and so I think that's important and
then if I have a little more time I'll
just comment
you're just at the end of your time
smallpox
was very controversial in terms of both
first the variolation which is an
immunization and then vaccination once
that became available the
commander-in-chief of the Continental
Army decided that everyone had to have
smallpox vaccination without that we
probably would have lost the
Revolutionary War it wasn't vaccination
excuse me very elation
thank you very much for your testimony
and that inoculation history
are there any questions no thank you
very much doctor next up we have William
Rogers
three minutes thank you
I can't talk for three minutes don't
worry
thank you last as always welcome I am
going to talk about vaccines I don't
know a thing about them
I know that we're as a country we're
very divided if you would listen to the
testimony of the people who want and I
support this bill
if you listen to the people who don't
want to support the bill who don't agree
with it you would it would seem like if
we don't if we pass this bill we're
going to go back to a third world
country and every vaccine is going to be
taken care of and it's going to be gloom
and doom and if you listen to the people
who do support it some of them make it
seem like
if like like the the way it is right now
that they're gonna you know they're
gonna jab us and we're all gonna become
zombies I don't believe either one but I
know it's been a rough three years it's
been a rough couple of years and I know
people don't trust the government
they especially don't trust
bureaucracies
and I think that you have an opportunity
to start to to mend that Rift because
it's it's not that people don't want to
trust people want to trust but we trust
what I trust more is this right here I
trust you I trust that you as a
committee to take everything into
consideration and make the best choice
best vote on your conscience and I think
putting this bill forward and having
that same legislation
doing the same thing is going to start
to build trust back up in the government
that we need to trust that's all
thank you very much
seeing no questions thank you can I help
yes yes you can
thank you next up we have um
somebody from new Futures will need to
put your name on this card as well
um you've asked for three to five
minutes for limiting people to three
minutes
okay okay
um it might be Kate Frey we do have
submitted testimony and I guess if she's
not in the room
okay next up we have uh Thomas McLeod
thank you
one minute we'd appreciate shorter than
three minute testimonies
thank you madam chair my name is Thomas
McLeod I resided in Mount Vernon and
support
HP 557 I'll be brief
and not take any questions I'm the chair
of health room New Hampshire a Statewide
advocacy organization
with over 3 000 members
um and supporters and the overwhelming
sense of our members
is That vaccine mandate decisions
are made by agencies that are frankly uh
beholden to Industry and to unelected
Global Health agencies
these are the same agencies that attempt
to limit discussion
by labeling those who disagree with them
as spreaders of misinformation
and to the concern about
partisan conflict uh quite frankly this
will happen
um
relative to vaccines whether this bill
passes or not but if it does pass
at least those partisan debate debates
will be held squarely where they belong
in the election cycle
thank you thank you very much
um I only have one name on this card um
Hannon from New Hampshire Public Health
Association
I see one to three minutes we always
appreciate brief testimony thank you
it's easier to absorb the written word
sometimes
foreign
some here on behalf of the New Hampshire
Public Health Association my name is
Hanan oh good afternoon Madam chairman
Madame chair and committee members
so my name is Hanan bedri I'm the
executive director for the New Hampshire
Public Health Association
and we are a Statewide membership
Association non-profit
um and our membership consists of public
health professionals over 300
organization and individual public
health professionals uh we're the
leading trusted New Hampshire Public
Health voice that empowers our members
and communities to achieve a healthier
New Hampshire
uh we're here to
um
to oppose House Bill 557 which is
relative to the Department of Health and
Human Services rule-making Authority
regarding immunization requirements this
bill is direm has dire ramification for
the health of New Hampshire residents
um
if past authority to choose what
vaccines are required for entry to
schools would be taken away from the the
State Health Department the department
current system
protects the public health and provides
a balanced choice for parents and
individuals it allows for legislative
and public input to protect the health
of all children the system is not broken
the department carefully reviews
childhood vaccines recommend
recommendations and key criteria
including vaccine efficacy
vaccine safety and the severity of
disease
likelihood of infection and method of
transmission in order to determine which
should be required for school and child
care and child care entry
um
from hearing from from hearing the
sponsor uh give an overview of
um of the proposed bill it seems like
the current system is not broken and
it's very inclusive it offers
legislative input it offers public input
and and the proposed system or proposed
structure it's more exclusive and it
puts the burden on the legislators so uh
that is a concern that there is no
public input there is no involvement
from the Department of Health and Human
Services
um
um which something that currently the
Department of Health and Human Services
offers so therefore we see that house
bill 557 furthers uh it furthers no
valid Public Health policy and we would
urge the committee to oppose the bill
thank you very much and just for your
clarification
um any changes in the future would need
a process oh sorry that was mine just
like this so if there were any future
changes we'd be back in this room with a
much larger crowd I'm sure are there any
questions
now say no more thank you very much next
we have representative Kelly patenza
I'll set the timer for three minutes but
I think you'll be faster than that
thank you committee and chair
um my name is representative Kelly
patenza I represent Stratford District
19 that's Rochester Awards one through
four and six
text of Article 2 in the New Hampshire
Constitution it says how the legislature
is constituted the Supreme legislature
power within the state shall be vested
in the senate in the House of
Representatives Each of which shall have
a negative on the other
rules are not laws DHS DHHS JL Carr
never had this authority to begin with
this is what our job is the legislature
the people of New Hampshire did not
elect DHHS the people of New Hampshire
did not give the authority to a subset
of the legislature which is JL Carr
basically politicians are the ones that
set policy not
um unelected bureaucrats thank you
thank you are there any questions no
thank you next we call Nancy bitterman
and I'll set the three minute timer when
you're up if you have copies of your
testimony um otherwise we'll take the
one copy for the record if you don't
mind and press the button so it's read
up here okay she didn't know she turned
it off
um I'm here as a parent of two children
that have chronic illnesses so I'm here
to support this uh Bill mainly because
both of them have been injured by
vaccines that were required and
um there is no recourse one of my
children has traumatic brain injury from
That vaccine and she will never be able
to fully realize the career that she
wanted to to do because of her vaccine
injury
there is no recourse for her or myself
or anyone else that gets injured by
these vaccines
and to sit there and keep adding more
and more we are now at
32 to almost 40 shots
when you think about each vaccine there
are two to three if not four doses of
each of those vaccines so we're up to 40
Shots by a time a child is about 17 18
years of age
and there are more on top of that and
that's not including the flu vaccine or
whatever they do with covid
and you say oh yeah go to your doctor or
go get you know exemptions for this well
since covid
I cannot get a doctor to exempt my child
medically and some places do not accept
the religious exemption especially when
you try to go to places outside of the
state because there are New England
states that are no longer allowing the
religious exemption so then my child is
stuck
and then you have to decide does she
want to take this vaccine to go and have
this other opportunity and risk having
more injury
and again no recourse to what she can or
can't do against anyone that made this
vaccine
um
this burden needs to be on the
legislature we elected you to take on
this burden this is your job
this is not the job of a few people that
were placed there and are very much
affected by whatever big Pharma and
whatever lobbyists are sitting there and
in their ear all day long because we
don't have access to them we have access
to you we don't have access to them
and um as far as you know what is
available and going to be brought at
school and whatnot I was a teacher for
12 years you know that risk going in
there I was pregnant
twice what I was teaching
you know fifth disease there is no
vaccine for that that is one of the most
harmful diseases that will happen to a
pregnant woman if they come and contact
it I knew that as a teacher going and I
took that risk
but I'm not going to sit there and
mandate a child has to have a vaccine if
they're going to get injured by it
finally what we need to start realizing
in the medical field is just because we
can do this doesn't mean we should
thank you
thank you and perfect timing that was
thank you very much
um next we have Melissa White
hi everyone thank you for being here
today
um I just I know you've
heard a lot of great testimony but um I
just want to acknowledge the um
the great number of lobbyists that are
here today and the very few number of
parents
um and the lobbyists are paid to be here
and I took the day off to be here and I
have a lot of friends who
could not take the day off either from
their jobs or being parents to be here
so I just want to make sure that um
Everybody reads the testimonies that are
coming in via email because it's really
important that you hear us like there
appeared to be they're getting paid we
just have to live with whatever you
decide so thank you
thank you very much
next we have the honorable Melissa
blazak
thank you madam chair members of the
committee uh
my name is Melissa blasik of Merrimack
I'm here representing rebuild New
Hampshire and we do support this bill
um just after hearing some of the other
testimony I want to say I don't think
that this is really a vaccine bill I
don't it doesn't argue the Merit of
vaccination the purpose of rules is to
technically enact the details of policy
set forth by politicians and this makes
sense politicians should be the only
people to set policy since they unlike
administrators are accountable to the
voters
adding a vaccine to the school schedule
is absolutely a policy decision and I
believe it has no place in the rule
making process
this shouldn't be a partisan issue in my
mind it is simply making sure that all
policy is set by politicians who are
accountable
legislative seasons are fairly short in
almost every state and I believe our
Founders limited the time available to
legislate to limit the size and scope of
government and having a small government
is something that many people in New
Hampshire are very proud of but when New
Hampshire was founded we did not have
the type of administrative state that we
have now who work year-round
and I understand that one of the reasons
why we have come to rely so heavily on
the administrative state is because
rules can be adopted in a faster process
however the legislature does have
emergency Powers built into the
constitution in form in the form of
special sessions this is what our
Founders Envision should an emergency
arise necessitating emergency action
however there is no history of such an
emergency appearing that required a
vaccine to be quickly added to the
school schedule so I find the likelihood
of this scenario very slim
we've seen other versions of this bill
in the past but as we all know sometimes
it takes time to find the best solution
to a problem and I believe that this
bill is the correct solution and I hope
that the committee willfully support
this Bill thank you
thank you very much for the testimony
are there any questions
that's all right thank you very much
um I wanted to check and see if the
representative from new Futures was back
in the room
and uh then just before I close this
hearing I'll just remind everybody no
clapping booing waves anything like that
so thank you very much and I'll hand the
chair back over to Chairman McDonald
oh thank you
um okay so there's no one else saying no
one else to testify on HP 557 I think
you already did that right I'm sorry
gotta get back in the swing of things
now uh I'm not I am now going to open
the public hearing on HB 408 and once
again recognize our very own Committee
Member representative Jim cofult for the
purposes of um giving opening testimony
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
committee I promise this is the last
time I'm going to be sitting down here
and you have to listen to me today
um
so House Bill 408 is kind of a
complicated situation
um it is illustrative of what can happen
however with administrative rule when
um
when we delegate lawmaking Authority
uh outside of the legislature and when
uh the the people who make
administrative rules turn around and
delegate or defer
to an outside party in this case to the
CDC and asip and others
um
so essentially here here's here's what
happened in how we got here um RSA 170e
section 34 addresses requirements for
foster care homes among other things
and there's a section of that that
states that for in of that of the rules
um sorry not of the statute but of the
rules authorized by the statute it says
or any foster parent seeking to provide
care to a child under six years old or a
child with special medical needs
all children who are household members
shall be up to date on immunizations
consistent with the recommendations of
the American Academy of Pediatrics the
advisory committee on immunization
practices that's asip of the Center for
Disease Control and prevention and the
American Academy of family physicians
unless the immunization is contrary to
the child's health as documented by a
licensed health care professional
so
what are the implications of this well
as we noted earlier
the state of New Hampshire only mandates
a subset of asip recommended vaccines
for all children living in the state
this rule however mandates all asip
recommended vaccines for certain
children in the state
which children
I want to point out that the the name of
the bill is actually
slightly misleading probably needs to be
corrected it says relative to foster
children and vaccinations this actually
does not affect foster children it
affects other children living in a
foster home in other words adopted or
natural born children or even children
who are
long-term guests perhaps in a foster
care home are subject to this mandate
um
the foster children themselves are not
subject to the Mandate because of a bill
we passed in the previous biennium that
exempts anyone essentially says you you
are not subject to a covid-19 mandate in
uh as a condition for receiving a
benefit from the state so I would
actually correct what I just said they
may be subject to
the entire asip recommended list minus
the covid-19 vaccine
um so so it gets into a rather sort of
complicated and difficult situation
um in which we're mandating the entire
asip recommended list for very specific
a very specific group of children and we
are not allowing them the same due
process that other children in the state
have because they do not have a right to
a religious exemption okay so under this
it's it says unless the immunization is
contrary to the child's health as
documented by a licensed Healthcare
professional so there is nothing here
that
um that exempts them from mandatory
vaccination outside of uh outside of a
medical exemption so that's another
concern with this bill
um
so you know I already spoke earlier to
my concerns about the fact that the CDC
is now putting vaccines on the
recommended list not because they are
recommended but because they can get
them paid for by doing that so
um you know I I think there there is a
um
a change in practices or a change in
philosophy at the CDC
that directly impacts a population of
children in the United States now their
to their credit I think DHHS has issued
an emergency rule back in November in
response to this and the emergency rule
states that
um and I was I apologize because I was
trying to look it up and I I've lost
track of it here but the the emergency
rule essentially states that
um the the covid-19
uh mandate or the covid-19 vaccine will
will be excluded from this list in other
words the the children who would be
affected under this are not required to
take the covid-19 vaccine and the reason
cited was that there is widespread
public concern about the covid-19
vaccine and that this would be
detrimental to the Foster Care Program
because there are a lot of people who do
not want to subject their children to
the covid-19 vaccine as a condition for
being foster care parents so
you know I think that there is a a
broader concern here about
um the fact that we are nevertheless
mandating the rest of the list of
um of asip recommended vaccines without
um you know without an explicit reason
to do so
um
I guess I I also wanted to
point out that the emergency
rule is in effect I believe for 120 days
presumably it can be renewed I have to
confess I am not
so familiar with that that I would would
be able to tell you definitively whether
it could be renewed but
um I do have
um
I I do have some concerns about the fact
that that is just a uh at this point a
temporary change
um what this bill would do is to
essentially say that there is no
vaccination requirement for the affected
children that I've just in the group
that I've described that goes beyond
what is required for any other child in
the state I do want to let you know that
I have asked OLS to provide to to draft
an amendment
and unfortunately that amendment was not
ready as of the beginning of this
hearing I will get it to the committee
as soon as possible I would say that it
it is
it is substantively the same which is
the intended effect of that language is
to ensure that children who would
currently be affected by this mandate
will not be subjected to additional
immunization requirements I would say
that the the phrasing of that language
is different it was called it was
brought to my attention that the the the
statute that that
under which these rules were written may
not actually authorize
DHHS to impose vaccination requirements
on Foster family homes
and that as written this might imply
that they do
therefore I have asked for some new
language that would just very clearly
state that there shall not be any
vaccination requirements for uh for
imposed on Foster Homes outside of those
which are already imposed on the the
population at large and that all
exemptions that are available to the
population at large also be available to
to people living in foster family
households
with that I'm finished with my testimony
and I will take questions thank you
representative Koval representative
Weber
thank you and so for clarification what
we're really looking at here is not the
foster children but the choices of the
parents who are foster parents for those
other children living in their home
under or under their care is that right
that is correct in in one person with
whom I discussed this
um made the point that those foster
parents could therefore decide that they
are not going to participate in the
program right and that is true
nevertheless that has a detrimental
effect on the Foster Care Program
um as I think DHHS has acknowledged with
their emergency role and and may I have
a follow-up Mr chairman follow-up
um I wonder
what the effect would be
um if
instead of stating it as you have which
is sort of a negative or maybe even a
double negative uh one just stated and
this is just a drafting it's not whether
or not I agree with it uh that we make
either direct reference to the statute
where the other requirements are
or put in the actual list
with the language of the other ones
right so as as we're speaking I received
the draft copy from OLS so I can email
that to the committee it is relatively
short if the committee would like me to
read it I can do that otherwise if it's
your preference I can email it
uh if it's really short go ahead okay uh
inserting insert after section 27A the
following new section immunization
requirements Foster family homes there
shall be no vaccination or immunization
requirements required of any children
residing in a foster home that exceeds
any vaccination or immunization
requirements as required by RSA
141c20a which is the one we discussed on
the last bill either in type of
vaccination or quantity of doses all
children residing in a foster home or
household shall have the same rights to
claim any exemption from a vaccination
or immunization requirement as any other
child in the state
and the exemptions under 141c20c shall
apply to Children of any age whose
parents desire them irrespective of
whether or not they're admitted or
enrolled in any public or private school
or Child Care Agency no provisions of
this subdivision and no rule adopted by
the department governing the licensing
of a foster family home shall impose any
vaccination or immunization requirements
on any adults residing in a foster
family home or household
okay
other questions representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking this question
um
could you give us some indication it
doesn't have to be exact but what the
you know comparative numbers of
vaccinations in in that are required for
schools in New Hampshire versus these
other lists
I actually tried to
find out what the asip recommended list
is and and I counted 32 however
there may have been some there that were
not
recommended or not do don't fall under
this requirement so I have to apologize
that I was having trouble coming to a
definitive number in part because there
there are different lists for different
age ranges so I think that some of the
representatives from DHHS may be in a
better position to answer that question
follow up follow up I think the
important thing is that it's
significantly different correct but um
second question or follow-up is
do you have any sense of what the
justification was for
um having this increased coverage for
children who were living in the foster
homes does it was it indicative of a
vulnerability for
many foster children or maybe you don't
know why it is well so the the
the rule states that it applies to any
situation which there is a foster child
under six or a foster child with
special medical needs so I think that
the
um
I think the justification for it was
well let's just do everything
um so I I I don't know for sure
um again DHHS may be able to speak to
that I also want to point out that you
know I think DHHS acted very promptly
and very responsibly in when this issue
was raised especially with respect to
the covid-19 vaccine so I I just want to
acknowledge that and thank the people
who are responsible for that emergency
rule having said that I I think there's
a number you know we need to address the
the problem in its entirety and that's
why I brought the bill forward thank you
other questions
seeing no other questions okay thank you
also signed up to speak is Beth Marjan
from the dcif
you you have five minutes ma'am I think
but we've been asking people to hold the
three so I will try
um Mr chair thank you Mr chair Madam
Vice chair members of the committee of
the division uh appreciates the
opportunity to speak here today on this
bill so as to representative kovalt's a
question about the temporary rule making
with respect to the covet vaccine that
will be a permanent rule in about six
months or so uh the reason being that I
guess Dr Chan had testified the division
is going to be in coordination with uh
uh vaccination requirements for
school-aged children and that it is a
recommended but not required vaccination
just like the flu vaccination so the
coveted vaccine will be permanently uh
Exempted from the rule in six months the
other issue we do want to bring to the
uh committee's attention is that the
division already carves out vaccine
station requirements for children over
six and Foster homes under six we do
require vaccinations because children
are seem to be more vulnerable at that
point the other issue we'd like to bring
to the attention of the committee is
that the national the national model
Foster him I'm sorry National model
Foster Family Home licensing standards
uh was issued by the in 2019 by the
federal government which actually was
mandating the vaccines since then we
have done the carve out for the um and
this was prior to the covet vaccine but
we have done the carve out for the covid
vaccine we have done the carve out for
exempting children over the age of six
from uh from vaccination requirements
um and so our concern is that
um
if we continue to carve out exemptions
from these national standards that we
may be at loss of risk of losing our 40
funding and that is a concern for the
division I do want to note that our
foster families are very dedicated
um and uh wonderful people who often
accept more stringent requirements for
in you know issues in their home perhaps
fire code and other things and so they
do volunteer to be our foster parents
and they do this knowing all of the
requirements that we that we require of
them both from a state and a federal
standard
and I'll take any questions if anyone
has any thank you representative Leon
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question
um a lot of my concern around this is
that there may be families who are
willing to foster but they don't want to
have that forward requirement on their
children do you know if we currently
have an oversupply of foster families in
the state we do not
um we have had uh we have had less
foster care applications we attribute
that to the pandemic however we are
actually getting uh we have a now robust
very foster care outreach program and we
are starting to get more foster care
foster families online follow-up and as
a follow-up generally do you have more
trouble placing the younger foster kids
or is that easier just because people
like puppies and babies I I think so I
mean I don't have any data just my
anecdotal observations that from being
working for dcy I think it is easier to
to place younger children
representative Weber and then
representative Shapiro
my first question would be uh are you
aware of families who have dropped out
of the foster care specifically because
of these requirements I am not now okay
thank you and may I have a follow-up Mr
chairman
um
so what I'm interested in exploring is
that
I get that there are some national
standards but
here we're balancing
actually I think you may have actually
answered that question when you said
that we require a lot of things of
foster families that we don't rip that
they wouldn't have as requirements if
they were just making decisions for
their own kids so I think I've answered
my own question thank you thank you
representative Shapiro
yes
um thank you Mr chairman and thank you
for
um responding to my question I think
alarms go off for many people in our
committee when we hear that um
that's some medical
procedure is going to be required
because we might lose money
um and so I'll ask you the same question
which is what is the medical
justification for adding a greater list
for the children of foster or parents
um what is what are the protective
factors that we're trying to cover here
Nation requirements sir I can't answer
that I would defer
deferred health
thank you
other questions
seeing none thank you okay thank you so
much
I'm sorry representative Weber
no I think I'll withdraw that one too I
I I'm still trying to formulate what I'm
trying to get at but I think it's
probably best left to Executive session
okay representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question uh you mentioned uh worrying
about if we do any more carve outs from
these Federal standards that uh we may
be at risk of losing any funding
um but it seems that it's already been
done twice have has there been any loss
of funding there hasn't we've been
working closely with the federal
government on those two current carve
outs that we've had for them
follow up so is it does it follow
logically then that you could continue
working with the federal government
regarding this if we pass this bill
I don't know again that was something I
would defer to Public Health about
because this is a broader range of
vaccination requirements
um than what the federal government had
approved in 2019. thank you
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman
um just following up on the potential
loss of funds we've heard from other
divisions in other departments that when
it were out of compliance they don't
immediately withdraw the funds there's a
remediation process have you ever had
the experience where the funds have
automatic have immediately been revoked
I do not know the answer to that
question thank you sorry
other questions
seeing no other questions okay thank you
thank you very much
also signed up to speak is
representative Kelly Potenza from
Rochester
foreign
thank you chair uh representative
Potenza Stratford District 19.
so this kind of piggybacks on what I had
said before
um in regards with a subset making
decisions but
this was passed June 5th of 2020 and
there's many of us that were screaming
very loudly about this this is truly
discrimination
no question about it so we're going to
have rules
for some in different rules for others
and to answer the question of
Representative Weber I will give you
five names of families that decided that
they were not going to Foster and
actually a family that did Foster that
moved
um out of state
because of this when it passed and it
was so heart-wrenching
and everybody was so confused by it they
thought it was going to be affecting
this the children that were coming in it
wasn't
it was a you know Wonderful giving kind
loving families that wanted to take
children
into their homes
that they were going to have to to
include the parents go all the way back
to a schedule so
it was just unbelievable that there
would be no exemptions for those
families
and that the children coming in would
have to be up to date wouldn't have to
be up to date on any schedule they could
have an exemption
this is truly common sense to me so when
JL Carr passed this
it was a vote of seven to three
how many people fall in our legislature
400.
I I can't believe here we are in 2023
and we're finally getting rid of this
this is not this is this is not a
partisan
um Bill this is the right thing to do
for something very wrong that happened
and uh I'm really passionate about it so
there's going to be someone else that's
going to come up to speak that got me
really passionate about it so if you
have any questions
any questions yes representative King
thank you chairman McDonald and thank
you for being here today
um
I don't fully understand everything
about the foster care system is there is
it is it strictly government run or is
there a private alternative that people
can be a part of that has different
standards because I mean it makes sense
to me that if the government is running
it that there's they're going to make
the standards on what is required I mean
you don't want to send poor foster
children that have no control over their
own lives into like a really bad living
situation
um and so it makes sense at least
logically that you know you're going to
make sure that they're not sent into a
disease-ridden home or something like
that
um so but but the thing is is that I
also understand that you know we have
different values in this country and
there might be some people who have a
more hands-off approach to vaccines and
some people who are much more stringent
about it and that if there was some
choice in the matter that would that
would be really nice so can you just
clue me in is there choice right now for
there is no choice that's the difference
it's mandate just for that specific
group that subset that's just
discriminatory it's appalling to be
honest that this ever went through
other questions
saying no other questions thank you
also signed up to speak is Laura Condon
from Bedford
I promise thank you but I can tell you
this is my file from have attending gel
Carr I went through the process of these
Foster family Rules
foreign
my name is my name is Laura Condon I'm
from Bedford and I'm here in support of
House Bill 508 as amended with the
amendment that representative colfault
presented
um I do want to mention first that
contrary to Dr Chan's claim that DHHS
does not mandate covet and flu shots
because
he said that they are you know annual
shots in fact it was dhhs's rule that
imposes covet and flu shots on Foster
family so in fact they do do exactly
what he said they don't do
the Foster family rule
hac-6446 sets into law authority to the
CDC to set State vaccine requirements
that include the entire vaccine schedule
they recommend today and in the future
without any state oversight review
anytime the CDC has additional doses to
vaccines automatically that's imposed on
children and Foster Family households
um
there and and correct some information
here
um they're they're the requirements are
in children of all ages the age six is
just that when there is a foster child
in the family who is six years and older
then the rules change
um but they don't change on the the the
um the children in the household so when
um in situations where there's a
biological child who's not in daycare a
public private school there's no
exemptions for them because they're only
allowed the school vaccine exemptions
state law
excuse me please be mindful that the
Foster family Rules also impose vaccine
requirements on adults for the first
time ever with the pertussis and flu
shot mandates where there's a foster
infant and a foster child with special
medical needs they all have special
medical needs there is no exemption to
these mandates on adults other than
medical there's no exemptions for
pregnant women prior adverse reactions
religious beliefs or beliefs of
conscience DHHS did not have to adopt
such aggressive rules and I testified to
that fact and provided evidence they
will claim they needed to impose these
mandates to receive federal money that
is not true
they needed only to recommend all these
vaccines in all situations not require
them and we've seen other states do it
just make a recommendation
a recommendation that rule would have
put them in compliance with the strings
attached to Federal money they chose not
to make it a recommendation they had
chose to impose requirements that's
because if I testified earlier DHHS is
in the vaccine business having taken
over the purchase and sailed all
vaccines targeted children
and is fully funded by the CDC for their
High vaccine purchases DHHS seeks every
opportunity to increase these vaccine
sales and this is a huge conflict of
interest
um and and yes the the bill you have
before you inadvertently gives authority
to DHHS to impose these vaccine
requirements and I urge you to strongly
consider I'm repping up the the
amendment
um as a replace for this bill I think
that is does appropriate worded to
protect not just the foster children but
the other children in the household
happy to take any questions thank you
questions
seeing no questions
great thank you thank you
last person who has signed up to testify
in this bill is Dr Merrill Nass
thank you
I'm testifying in favor of HB 408 and I
believe the last person also meant they
were testifying in favor of 408 not 508
the the cdc's advisory committee on
immunization practices is a group of
about a dozen vaccine scientists who've
been appointed by the CDC and this group
is asked to sign off on CDC vaccine
recommendations and invariably always
does so
um the asip
has issued recommendations for 26
vaccine different vaccines
and at least 15 different vaccines are
recommended for healthy children in the
U.S
there are two groups of consumer
products for which manufacturer
liability is waived in the U.S the first
group includes every vaccine that is
recommended by the acip for the
childhood schedule
in other words that's how you get your
liability waived is by getting your
vaccine placed on the childhood schedule
and all it requires is a vote by the
asip
the second group contains vaccines and
drugs designated as covered
countermeasures for pandemics or
biological warfare and this group
includes all coveted vaccines
all ASAP recommended childhood vaccines
have no liability
avoiding product liability for their
vaccines is obviously a huge financial
Boon for the industry and therefore
great pressure has been applied to
expand the vaccines recommended for the
childhood schedule in fact in 2016 a law
was passed by Congress saying that every
vaccine recommended for pregnant women
would also get this liability waiver
turning vaccines during pregnancy into a
gold rush
thus the ACP acip recommendations have
become commercialized and should never
be adopted wholesale by the states
but in New Hampshire they are yet only
for the non-fostered children of foster
parents
please fix this anomaly bypassing hb408
okay thank you
questions
yes representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman thank you again for testifying
um so what it sounds like here is there
is some Financial incentive to get
vaccines onto under this coverage this
liability shield and
so for that to happen it would mean that
this board the AI acip would members of
it may be compromised and have some
conflicts of interest do you know of any
um mem any evidence or or yes I I do so
um representative Dan Burton who was the
head of the committee on government
reform in the house in 2000 2001
investigated this and at that time found
that about half the members on the acip
had Financial conflicts of interest with
the vaccine industry and subsequent to
that there have been papers published
showing that members of federal advisory
committees have
forward and backward conflicts so many
of them can be assured they will get
contracts or jobs after they finish
their service on a federal advisory
committee
other questions
I'm seeing none okay thank you
thank you
also signed up to speak is
representative Timothy Harrigan
it's 408
oh thank you very much I'm president
Timothy Horrigan from Stratford County
district 10. and look I was mostly here
for another bill sponsoring that's
coming in much later than this but
I just think it's a simple common sense
that uh that's the chill that children
who are placed in foster care
um
should be uh they should be uh subject
to subject to like the uh should be
vaccinated um I don't uh and the and
that should apply also to the
Foster families other children since the
vaccines uh don't really care whether or
not you're a foster child they're not
aware of that it's a uh
it's an inanimate object that just wants
to reproduce itself so it like doesn't
know who's to foster child and who's not
so and I um
and I also think the uh
I also believe the vaccines are not
perfect but they were thoroughly tested
they're thoroughly safe and of course
this comes into context
of the covid-19 pandemic which is still
going on even though we've now moved on
to worrying about worrying about other
things it has killed 250 000 people just
in the last year
um about 1.15 million uh since we first
discovered it three years ago so that's
that's a very major catastrophe major
cause of death it's uh
worse than a lot of other things that we
worry about a lot more at the moment so
I would uh
so so I would say this bill uh and
Austin bills also it's kind of
it's confusing and badly written anyways
I think for those I think so I think
first of all
making sure the families Foster family's
own children are vaccinated is not an
unreasonable requirement in my in my
opinion and there may be valid
exceptions for that um
and bear in mind they are paid a
significant amount of even though no
one's doing it to get rich they are you
know the state is finished a different
amount of money to care for the children
and also uh
and then also this bill aside from that
too it's I think it appears to be poorly
drafted so that's the second reason not
to pass it so I would urge you to to itl
it so thank you and thank you uh
questions uh representative Leon thank
you thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for speaking
um my question is this applies to those
children who are opening up their home
and their parents to other kids who are
in need do you think that those kids who
are already sacrificing so much don't
deserve the same protections as other
kids in the state
um well that's uh that's fair enough
that the uh the family should be subject
to the same requirement yeah but there
should be a requirement for uh for
foster families they certainly uh the
Foster family is doing a very Noble deed
but that doesn't necessarily give them
the right to endanger the foster
children and so
thanks other questions
representative Missouri thank you Mr
chair thanks for taking my question and
maybe this was asked earlier I'm sorry I
came in a little bit late but so our
foster parents required to be vaccinated
right now
that's that's a good question I do not
know I mean there's a very
detailed list of uh requirements for the
home and that would I mean that would
not be an unreasonable unreasonable
requirement and there could be
exemptions for religious or health
reasons so that you that's a question
you have to direct at someone else I'm
afraid so I can try to find out if you
want to but thanks
other questions
seeing none thank you representative
also signed up to speak is
representative Emily Phillips
only Phillips representing Rockingham 7
Fremont New Hampshire I wasn't
originally going to speak on this but I
thought it was very important to
um point out that this is just
discrimination we're treating Children
and Families differently if they're in
the Foster system and there's
um
from what I do understand is that they
are required the foster parents and
Foster families are required to do the
full CDC schedule all of it so I just
don't even understand why this law even
exists discriminatory and like someone
else said we have a shortage of foster
families um I myself would love to
welcome a foster child but I'm not
willing to comply with the requirement
so why would we be deterring people from
opening their homes to children I just
don't understand it I'll answer
questions but
representative King
thank you chairman McDonald thank you
for taking questions
um I'm glad that you noted that there
are an under supply of foster homes
where are children who would be in the
foster care system where where are they
currently if they're not where we want
them to be which is in foster home what
happens to them do you know I am I am no
Foster expert I don't know but I would
assume I I would assume they're in other
foster homes that maybe don't have their
own maybe someone else can answer that
question but
doesn't
nobody has the answer but we have we
definitely have kids who need homes
other questions
saying no other questions thank you
awesome one more
also signed up to testify is Melissa
white from Peterborough
hi thank you again um I do support this
bill I think I forgot to say that the
last time I spoke but um so I'm I'm a
mom I'm not a doctor but um I can read
and I can understand conversations with
doctors
um I just want to say that
vaccination does not equal immunization
so I've heard kind of hopefully it was a
joke but um someone suggested that
children who are unvaccinated are
disease ridden and the gentleman a
couple
testimonies before suggested that
um you know the the children that were
we would be endangering children by
allowing them to be around unvaccinated
children
um but I I really want to suggest to the
to the
committee that um
you know there's a couple great studies
out there comparing unvaccinated
children to vaccinated children and
partially partially vaccinated and fully
vaccinated and the children who are
unvaccinated are exponentially healthier
than the children who are vaccinated I
know that's not the purpose of this
hearing today but um it's something that
we need to take into consideration and
um
if you look around at today's children
they're very very ill they're
chronically ill not not sick with
measles but they have everything else so
I'm sorry again if I'm
stepping out outside the bounds of the
hearing but I just needed to to say that
thank you
also signed up to testify is Ann Marie
McCurry from the Department of Health
and Human Services
Mr chair my name is Abby Rogers I'm the
legislative liaison for the division of
Public Health Services I'm here with
Anne-Marie Mercury who's a section chief
for immunization we're here to support
our colleague from dcyf with any
vaccination immunization related
questions that the kid midi may have
speak specifically on those immunization
questions if the committee if we can be
a resource on any questions that were
unanswered previously
okay
okay uh representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman I've asked a few
people this but I feel like I haven't
gotten an answer I'm I'm wondering what
the medical we've heard a lot about
losing money we've heard a lot about how
unfair this is but I still have don't
think I've heard anything about the
medical Public Health protective
um intention of
um having the children of foster parents
have a greater number of vaccinations
what do what do we
what are we trying to do
hello for the record in Murray McCurry
immunization section chief thank you
very much for the question
um so we do want to be clear that um the
Department of Public Health does not
have the oversight of the administrative
rules that are required for dcyf so um I
do have a limited understanding it would
rely on my dcif counterparts to answer
some of these questions however you know
as far as a medical necessity these are
from what my understanding is is that is
based on federal standards and National
guidelines based on protecting the
children who are coming into the Foster
families these children do oftentimes
have a lot more special needs medical
conditions and offering a higher level
of protection where they live is a
rationale for why that would be I also
wanted to be able to provide a little
bit of clarification on some of the
questions you posed earlier as far as
the acip recommended vaccines there are
17 acip recommended vaccines are in
schedule for children up to age 18 for
school immunization requirements which
is what Dr Ben Chan was referring to
earlier that do not include covet and
influenza that covers 10 of the 17 acip
recommended vaccines so there is a
difference between what we see for what
New Hampshire has in place for school
immunization requirements versus the
dcyf requirements
follow up so
this may be outside of your area of
expertise but
could you give an example of
what a under six-year-old or a young
child with special Health needs
might be specifically more vulnerable to
than
um than other kids that this vaccination
would um
sure would protect them from sure I can
speak a little bit to that um sometimes
I can just speak to some children have
seizure disorders which is
contraindicated for them to have for
example pertussis which is part of the
DPT that can exacerbate seizure
disorders so many times and kids with
children with seizure disorders the
neurologist might say we'll give you the
D and the T but leave the P out because
that exacerbates
that condition in in children some
children who are being treated with
cancer contraindicated to have certain
vaccinations while undergoing treatment
and you know mostly I think it's
children that are affected with certain
neurologic disorders but I I certainly
don't have that much information but
those are the two that I can provide I
would also say that it's my
understanding that some children and
Beth can certainly clarify but some
children do come to a foster family home
mostly I think the goal is to be fully
vaccinated but the only people that can
make decisions on vaccination for the
foster child are the parent and legal
guardian and then sometimes perhaps
those children are under vaccinated so
having the Foster family had those
vaccination Services of protection for
that child if that child should be under
vaccinated
other questions thank you representative
Weber
and isn't it true I know this is not
your specific area of
practice or expertise but isn't it true
that we require all sorts of extra
precautions
of families who are fostering other
people's children
for safety and other reasons we talk
about fire exits we talk about all kinds
of different safety measures in the home
before somebody becomes licensed to be a
foster care home
um and this is strictly speaking because
the first of all they're fostering
somebody else's kid
and secondly because
um if something goes wrong in that home
and we have seen that happen
occasionally uh when the department gets
it wrong whether with respect to a
natural parent or a foster family or
anybody else the consequences are very
severe
yes I would agree that and certainly um
as sort of the the state agency
um that would would take basically over
oversight over someone else's child has
the responsibility to make sure that
environment that they're placed in is
meeting all the safety standards and
that child is protected within that
system
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you very much for
coming up
um I have a question about the public
health benefit of requiring just these
children who are sharing their home to
be vaccinated against rotavirus HPV and
Dengue Fever especially when rotavirus
is a third world disease that was
included for financial reasons in our
schedule
I think that's where we would rely on
our dcy F counterparts to have these
carve outs obviously there are things
where especially where you say Dengue it
we're not in an endemic state it is on
the acip recommended it would make sense
for these carve routes to take place
where it's applicable
thank you
other questions representative King
thank you chairman McDonald thank you
for taking questions I know you were
here mostly to talk about vaccines
um
I wish I had asked my question a long
time ago to somebody else but I'm still
hoping I can get an answer um do you
know what happens to children that you
know we're trying to get into a foster
home but there's there's not enough
Supply where where are they where are
they living what's happening to them
where what kind of situation are they
currently in thank you
I can ask my colleague Beth marginson to
come back up and answer that question if
that's appropriate that's out of not an
under our purview
would that be okay with the committee
okay okay
thank you
thank you for the question
um I mean we are we are making do as we
can right now with the foster care with
the foster home supply that we have but
um obviously we're looking to expand the
number of foster homes that we have
follow up follow up can you just be a
little bit more specific on what you
mean by making do does that mean that
the children are with their biological
parents still and and we're trying to
get them out of there or does that mean
that they are living in another foster
home a foster home that maybe you only
wanted to have two foster children and
now they've got five is that what you
mean by making do or are they in like
like a state like a state-run like
facility I don't know what you mean by
making do they're not at a state-run
facility
um they're not with their biological
children if it has been determined that
is necessary for them to remove them our
foster homes are allowed to have six are
allowed to have six children in it
representative McLean
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so
um we talk a lot about uh the deficit of
foster families so I question you know
given that situation you know is it
necessarily good public policy to have a
blanket vaccination instead of uh you
know maybe certain people would maybe
certain people wouldn't if this
legislation were to pass
um would there be anything that would
prevent uh the department from saying
you know because we have these children
specifically in their immunocompromised
in this area
we would need those foster families to
be immunized here or there
um you know but not such a blanket
approach if this was to pass yes there's
so in the in the national standards for
instance
um medically needy children cannot be
with unvaccinated adults against
whooping cough so that would be that
would be uh something that would concern
at the end of that we could not place a
child in a home
follow up
so just to clarify so if this was to
pass you would still have flexibility
for those children in our
immunocompromise to still be able to go
to those parents and say yes we do
require this in your case no we couldn't
because as I just read the amendment
it's saying that nobody no there shall
be no requirements of any adults in the
home and currently I don't believe I'm a
little at lost because the the foster
care sort of expert had pre-approved
leave today so she couldn't be here so
you know we will certainly take
follow-up questions by email if that's
appropriate but
um the uh
just kind of lost with my train of
thought sorry about that but the um
if the amended version of this bill
would re would uh mandate that no adult
in the home would require to be
vaccinated if that were to pass then we
would not be able to require any any
adults to be vaccinated against whooping
cough and we would have a problem with
placing medically needy children
representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman and uh thank you
for coming up uh can a child be placed
with extended family if like in a
temporary foster situation if those
family members and the children in that
home are not vaccinated on the CDC
schedule does that does the rule
currently in place prevent that no it
does not and in fact the division first
looks to family members to place
children prior to putting putting them
in the foster home follow-up follow-up
so just just clarify so extended family
are exempt from this requirement yes
because they're not licensed foster
homes thank you
representative Weber
thank you and to go back to the very
beginning when we were talking about
making do
isn't
part of what we're talking about when
we're talking about making do
is that what we would want for our
foster children
is to match the needs of that foster
child as closely as we possibly can
including things like
keeping them in their same school
district keeping them close to where
their friends are and that that is one
of the things that with the lack of
foster parents sometimes a child who
came into the Foster system from Keene
is placed with somebody very far away in
the state yes that can't happen thank
you representative Leon thank you very
much Mr chairman thank you right over
here
that the definition of medically needed
child do you know specifically what that
is because that might be an important
touch Point here and if you don't would
you mind sending that to us I don't um
it may be I think perhaps the public
health people might be able to answer
that but I cannot answer that now thank
you yeah keeping these kids as close to
home and in their schools is good
absolutely thank you any other questions
representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question we heard earlier at
least I thought he did about the impact
this has had on Foster families
and then exiting if you will providing
that kind of care
is this going to bypassing this all of a
sudden open the floodgates are going to
have lots of people who want to be
foster parents because they don't have
to worry about vaccines or basically are
we just looking at something that really
doesn't exist
so in other words a solution to a
problem or something my guess my
question yes is is this a solution to a
problem that exists or a problem looking
for a solution we have not I have not
extensively with our foster care
licensing program but I am not aware
that the vaccination requirements for uh
for our foster homes are problematic
did I see another hand up down here
any other questions
seeing none thank you very much okay
thank you very much
no one else has signed up to testify on
this bill uh House Bill 408 has anyone
else wish to testify
seeing no one I'm going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 408 and
open the public hearing on 217 and
recognize representative Schmidt who is
the Prime sponsor
thank you very much Mr chairman for the
record my name is Peter Schmidt I
represent Dover award one
Stratford Stratford County 14.
um so uh I appreciate the opportunity to
be before Health and Human Services
committee which is a rare opportunity
for me but but this is a matter that I
am not a newly arrived at uh I first um
encountered the subject of water
fluoridation probably something like 50
years ago when I read an article in a in
a some kind of a journal that prompt me
to think at some point I'm going to have
to look into this because I found it
quite troubling
um
and that opportunity presented itself
about 18 years ago when I was on the
municipal and Colony government
committee and there was a bill uh that
involved permitting the city of
Manchester to re-uh uh conduct a
plebiscite involving the city of
Manchester's water supply but was also
water supply for the surrounding collar
communities of it if you will and there
had been a lawsuit challenging the
plebiscite that had been held previously
which had narrowly permitted water
fluoridation for the city of Manchester
and the suit said but you didn't include
a question or election or plebiscite for
the surrounding communities and
therefore they're being supplied water
with uh that's fluoridated and they
didn't have any say in that so the court
decided they were correct and there had
to be a a new plebiscite and involving
all the people who were consuming the
city of Manchester Water
and the people who came in to testify on
that bill were men most of them were
very passionately opposed to water
fluoridation
I I didn't know anything really about
the subject at the time except what the
average citizen does and uh so I saw a
lot of people who had a lot of
information and I started reading up on
it I'm still very troubled by the idea
of water fluoridation in terms of its
possible impact on people's health and
its efficacy and its safety
so uh I've I've brought you this bill
because there are several new studies
that are of high value as I understand
it's uh they are funded by the EPA and
so forth I'm not going to talk about
that because we I have people here who
are very much more knowledgeable and
some of them have even been involved I
believe but I'll conclude my remarks
with one final thing and that is that
um
yep
the perfect Bill senior moment has just
struck uh that that's what happens when
you get to be my age sometimes you're
lucky if you can find certain body parts
in the morning uh so uh the thing is
that
um that this this this question is one
of considerable urgency uh and and I
hope you will look at it carefully and
and ask questions oh I remember what I
was going to tell you I believe that the
committee has been provided a wealth of
information by email uh that you should
have all received quite recently that
that I urge you to read I I've read some
of it and I find it equally troubling so
if there are any questions I'll try to
answer but I think it's much better to
hear from the experts behind me
yeah yes representative Cushman
Mr chairman thank you representative for
bringing this bill
um on the subject of infants and
children if I recall correctly because I
brought a bill about fluoride before
um if I recall correctly there there was
something in New Hampshire statute that
required a warning on municipality
website if they had Municipal Water
advising parents not to reconstitute for
baby formula with fluoride due to the
health issues associated do you remember
that I do not
thank you
other questions
yes representative navel thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
um this seems like a very big issue
um that should not have escaped study in
other states so there are other states
other places that have looked at this
issue
uh I would believe there are but I'm not
Authority I've served 20 years in this
legislature but I don't know that much
about the rest of the nation
representative
representative Shapiro thank you Mr
chairman
um representative
um I know this is putting the cart
before the horse because we're going to
study this but I think the idea of these
committees is frequently that
legislation will be recommended so I'm
wondering
legislation I just want to make sure I'm
here okay another one of the defects of
old age
um
what What legislation do you think might
come out of this
well I don't want to project What
legislation might come out of it but but
I think if you look at lines uh 10
through 20 the the the the bill which is
very straightforward and simple which
mostly said just sets up the study
committee but it it's specifically that
directs that the committee shall study
the effects of fluoride exposure
including neurotoxicity and other
potential side effects on fetuses
Children and adolescents and then it
gives some some additional specifics uh
and and I think that whatever
legislation might come out of it should
be dictated by what the what the latest
and best science uh would uh would
suggest that that we do with regard to
the fact that water fluoridation I I I
let me just say one thing there's a lot
of fluoride available in fluoride
toothpaste
uh their people are consciously deciding
to to topically apply and hopefully
carefully because the package says do
not swallow
if you swallow contact the Poison
Control Center
um so or if you go to a dentist and have
the fluoride topically applied then
you're also not going to be ingesting it
when you're drinking fluoridated water
depending on how much water you drink
um and how much you uh cook with with
with water and so forth you're going to
get way differing rates of exposure to
fluoridated water uh but but the the
basic answer to your question is let's
find out what the latest science
suggests the the best current knowledge
is and act accordingly
representative follow up
um
so
I I assume that one eventual result way
down the line is that maybe there would
be a Prohibition against municipalities
um using fluoride in their in their
um
public drinking water
um so my question really is have you
thought about whether this should be
addressed on the state level versus the
local level for example in Keene
um we've made the decision to not have
fluoridated water so
I guess I'm just wondering if you've
given consideration to whether this
should be a local decision or a
Statewide issue
I certainly have considered all kinds of
things but what I'm suggesting to the
this committee into the legislature is
that we
take a new look at water fluoridation
and its impact especially on children
either in utero
or in uh no that are young toddlers who
are being either breastfed or with with
formula because I think that is
something that it would be very
troubling water fluoridation the science
of water fluoridation you know is quite
old I mean I think it's been around for
something like 80 years
uh I think some of the original
scientific beliefs have been uh have
been disproven uh over time and there
are these recent studies as I say that
that I really think the the state of New
Hampshire has an obligation to look at
and then then you in the first instance
but the legislator legislature as a
whole subsequently should look at these
and decide whether science dictates or
suggests a different course of action
than we currently have in New Hampshire
at the moment and based on that either I
if I'm still around uh or someone else
in the future should draw the
consequences and the conclusions that
would would arise out of the kind of
study that this bill requests
yeah representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
with the number of committees we have
and the people on this one would you be
willing to serve on this if we were to
move forward and help find others I'm
still around I I would love to to have
the opportunity well I'm almost 85. uh I
I'll be 87 at the end of this term
I'm not sure I want to do this for two
more years after that oh that's all
right the report's due by November 1st
of this year
okay so I hope you're around much longer
than that
other questions not doing bad for 85 but
uh but the the
degenerative process accelerates in some
cases I'm saying no other questions
okay thank you representative thank you
Mr chairman and members of the committee
also signed up to speak is Dr Brenda
Berkel from the New Hampshire Dental
Society
you have three minutes ma'am
thank you yeah thank you Mr chair and
members of the committee
for the record I am Brenda berkal I am
president of the New Hampshire Dental
Society
we represent dentists Dental team
members and our patients
it's on behalf of the latter group our
patients which hopefully includes all of
you
um that I appear before you today in
opposition to hb217 as most of you know
last year
after Decades of intensive bipartisan
work
the general court passed and the
governor signed a Medicaid bill for
adult benefits
like the children's benefit
that's currently in place the new law
will help thousands of New Hampshire
residents who otherwise haven't been
able to access Dental Care
um
and that affects their overall health
uh that age thing
um many of those at this very table
helped Champion that very important work
using reliable economic and scientific
studies as the basis for your work our
residents will thank you for that
approach as do I
unfortunately this bill is
representative of a desire to move away
from a scientifically proven benefit for
the public oral health
hb217 would give air to those who would
use faulty and unfounded studies to
bring an end to community water
fluoridation
that safely and equitably protect the
health of all of New Hampshire's
children including those within the
Medicaid population
young children who don't know how to
spit out yet cannot use fluoride
toothpaste
so um they need to ingest the fluoride
to help their teeth develop
I have a patient
he's been with me for about a dozen
years he's in his mid 70s
for all the time I had known him
he might have had a filling wear out but
he never had cavities about a month ago
he came into my practice with half a
dozen brand new cavities on the roots of
his teeth which is a really bad spot to
get a cavity and we were talking to try
and figure out what had happened and his
wife had decided that they should start
using a toothpaste with no fluoride
within the last year and it had a major
drastic effect on his oral health
as a dentist and health care
practitioner I constantly examine the
latest data that comes from
evidence-based studies on the best way
to protect oral and overall health
I like my dentist colleagues am
committed to a strict code of ethics and
professional conduct
as well as the Hippocratic Oath both of
which demand that we dedicate our
professional lives to safeguarding the
health of our patients and do them no
harm
hb217 however encourages the Embrace of
misinformation in an effort to violate
my ethical codes
so it is for these reasons that I
um hope that you will vote 217 in
expedient to legislate
okay thank you representative King
are you taking questions ma'am or yes
thank you chairman McDonald thank you
for taking questions
um I take it you've read this bill and
the way I see it that there's going to
be four members of the House of
Representatives and one member of the
Senate it doesn't say in this bill that
these five members are going to be of
the crackpot wing of you know of the
anti-science Brigade
um it could very well end up being that
uh they find out that fluoride is like
the best thing ever and then you get
cities like Keene that Implement uh you
know fluoride in their drinking water
um why is it that you're afraid that
it's why are you so convinced that it's
going to come out negative
um yeah there has been massive
public study of fluoride over the last
80 years basically
when fluoridation was first started
there were towns that had it next to
towns that didn't have it and they
compared the demographics
and they studied the populations of both
towns and there were no ill effects in
the fluoridated towns so I do not think
that any bad effects would be found the
World Health Organization has declared
that public water fluoridation is the
most cost effective Public Health
measure ever
um so I'm just hoping that the house
doesn't waste time follow up follow up
so yes I understand what your position
is but it could very well be that the
committee comes to your conclusion and
and I it just seems to me like you've
already got this uh preconceived notion
that they're going to come to the
opposite conclusion and if they were to
come to your conclusion it could result
in more cities Florida in their water so
I just again I don't understand why
you're automatically thinking that this
committee is going to come to the
conclusion that's opposite of you thank
you Mr chairman could I remind all of us
that we don't question what's in other
people's minds or or inquiring to them
they're they're allowed to give their
testimony without being examined or
having motives or thoughts attributed to
them
thank you thank you any other questions
representative Merchant
I definitely need a longer hand thank
you Mr chairman thank you for my
question
I I do support the committee in partner
with rationale to doing that when I
looked at a study that came out of
Canada in 2019
what it references in the US we have 66
percent of residents covered with
fluorinated water
in Canada it's only 38 in Europe is
three percent and I'd like to understand
why there's such variance between
countries and I think this would be a
way for the committee to begin to
understand why we have such a variance
throughout the world given what you
talked about again with who so therefore
would you be in support of this because
there is tremendous variance in how
countries utilize foreign Nation
I am not very well informed about why
various locations have or don't have
fluoridation
some of it may be
like areas with Wells but I don't really
feel that I can speak
clearly on that other questions
seeing no other questions thank you
also signed up to speak is Katie lajoy
from Charlestown New Hampshire
foreign
good afternoon my name is Katie lajoy
I'm a nurse I live in Charlestown I'm
here just today to support house bill
217.
uh New Hampshire law currently allows
for the addition of fluoridation
chemicals to the public water supplies
of about a dozen communities in the
state the legislature however has not
independently looked at the latest
science on how the practice can impact
citizens
I support such a fact-finding mission
because according to lamphere at Al in
2020 the debate on the fluoridation of
drinking water has been reignited as new
studies find that fluoride is toxic to
the developing brain and this occurs at
levels routinely found in the general
population
I'm here today as a private citizen but
for many years I worked as a public
health nurse with a childhood lead
poisoning prevention program and I
understand about lead being neurotoxic
and affecting children's growth and
development
I also understand that in the United
States there was pushback from the lead
industry with regard to regulations and
bans on lead-based paint according to
Rosner and Markowitz since the 1920s the
lead industry had organized to fight
bans restrictions even warnings on paint
can labels it had marketed the deadly
product to children and parents
spreading the lie that lead paint is
safe it was safe we want to write Bill
Mr chairman yeah but again it's about
fluoride not about lead paint man I'm
making the connection oh honestly I beg
your pardon it's okay with regard to
water flow Edition we must avoid the
nature and extent of the denial seen in
the past with childhood lead poisoning
and I see a really big similarity in the
history of fluoride in the history of
lead in terms of the denial
according to lamphereadau mounting
evidence suggests fluoride may be hand
um hampering brain development and
reducing kids IQ the U.S needs to
rethink this exposure for pregnant women
and children
consider the following an important
research study concerning the
association between maternal fluoride
exposure during pregnancy and lower IQs
and Offspring appeared in the Journal of
the American Medical Association in 2019
Jama this is a very prestigious journal
the study States fluoride exposure
during pregnancy may be associated with
adverse effects on child intellectual
development indicating the possible need
to reduce fluoride intake during
pregnancy
three of the authors said our studies is
consistent with other high quality
research it's not a standalone study
more than 50 Studies have shown an
association between high or fluoride
exposure and IQ lower IQ Basha Shadel
also found IQ decrements in children
exposed to fluoride and utero they
report in this study higher prenatal
fluoride exposure in the general range
of exposures reported for other general
population samples of pregnant women and
non-pregnant adults was associated with
lower scores on tests of cognitive
function in The Offspring at age four
and age 6 to 12 years
riddle it all found that higher tap
water fluoride levels and fluoridation
of Municipal Water Supplies were
associated with a higher risk of an ADHD
diagnosis as well as increased symptoms
of hyperactivity and inattention
especially among adolescents this points
to a potential cumulative effect of
fluoride exposure and highlights the
need for further investigation of the
potential for fluoride mediated
developmental neurotoxicity in
populations with water fluoridation
tillidal found exposure to increasingly
wrapping up please pardon me please stop
wrapping up your testimony I'm just well
could you start concluding you had three
minutes ma'am okay
um I I will send you this by uh email
and there's a couple other studies
showing the direct link between
fluoridation and um
uh lower IQs
um according to till at L uh mounting
scientific evidence showing a consistent
pattern of lower IQ associated with
early if exposure to fluoride she asked
how much more information is needed
before we raise concern at least for a
particular subset of the population she
cautions that failure to act could
amount to enormous costs at the
population level
um
okay thank you ma'am and um your support
will help for this bill will help
increase our understanding of fluoride's
risk to the developing brain and will
inform policies going forward regarding
dental care for our children thank you
any questions
saying no questions thank you I'll get
this to you by uh electronically
yeah okay thank you
all right thank you
also signed up to speak is
representative Emily Phillips
hello Emily Phillips Rockingham 7
Fremont New Hampshire I want to thank
the sponsor for bringing this bill
forward uh as it suggests in the
language fluoride is a neurotoxin
um there's nothing in the the bill the
legislation to say anything against
Dental practices I don't see that as a
threat right now there are many sources
of fluoride drinking water toothpaste
topical varnishes I think we're talking
about cumulative exposure being the
concern and something worth studying my
parental motto is To Know Better do
better so let's find out
um I don't believe I want to thank rep
King for his question we are not wasting
time by forming this committee what are
we so afraid of is it the truth
that's it
any questions
see no questions thank you
also signed up to speak is Abby Rogers
from the Department of Health and Human
Services
thank you Mr chair for the record my
name is Abby Rogers I'm the legislative
liaison for the division of Public
Health Services I'll make it very short
the department does not take its
position on the bill but has I'm here
representing Dr Sarah Finney who is the
dental director at DHHS as well as the
dental uh the oral health program at the
division of Public Health Services as I
said no position on the bill but we
would be happy to be at the study
committee if the bill was enacted to
discuss the benefits of fluoride in
regards to oral health thank you
thank you questions
seeing no questions thank you
yeah
okay I may not pronounce this correctly
Joseph Asante from Northeast Delta
Dental
well we don't know if it's pretty good
yet I want to hear
oh he waits how's the pronunciation
it's all right but it's erante actually
okay I'm sorry that's all right uh don't
worry about it it's not the first time
it's been mispronounced that's for sure
um I'm here representing Northeast Delta
Dental I am a dentist Mickey speaking to
the mic please I'm sorry
is that better
you can just pull it towards you
okay great thank you
um so I'm Joseph orante and I work for
Northeast Delta Dental I'm a dentist as
well uh practice for about 20 years in
uh in Tucson Arizona which is the
largest metropolitan area in the country
in the world actually that's totally on
Subterranean water or it used to be it's
now got uh
above ground water as well but and we
did have some communities on the edges
of Tucson metropolitan area that had
very high concentrations of fluoride in
the water and the floridosis the
fluorosis that I found was uh minimal
and it was really you could only see it
with uh with the dental light and dry
tooth and so it was a pretty nominal
issue and I guess my concern in my read
of the bill is not so much worried about
what new science is out there but it's
more about it seemed like my read of the
bill
indicates that it's going to be focused
on the ill effects and not so much on
all of the effects and I think that
there's been uh many years at least 50
years of my time in since in dentistry
where it's been demonstrated to be uh at
least beneficial when it comes to
carries or tooth decay and prevention
and so I just want to make sure that if
it goes forward that there's that we're
not just considering the ill effects
we're considering all of the effects and
making a balanced decision about that
uh that the science is pretty much
settled in my view at least and uh and
so I I just kind of was
responding to the representative King's
uh question about
um about what are we afraid of we're not
really afraid of anything if there's new
science out there and there's new uh
demonstrations of uh ill effects that's
great but we just want to make sure that
we understand all the effects of it
and we're supporting we're not
supporting the bill as written and that
we don't really see why we're going
through this process again it seems like
every other year or so we go through
this process with a anti-water
fluoridation process
thank you thank you questions
representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman
um you mentioned water fluoridation I I
didn't I don't know that I saw anything
about water fluoridation and if whether
the committee should
look at that it doesn't that seems like
it may be outside the scope of this it
looks like it's just talking about
fluoride in general and its health
effects can you clarify
well I think as we heard earlier the it
seems like the the uh the bill the
legislation that might come out of a
committee a recommendation for
committee might be
leveled at water fluoridation and that's
why I connected the two
other questions
anyone else no okay thank you thank you
also signed up to speak is Stuart Cooper
from the fluoride Action Network
foreign
asking everybody to stay at three or you
know start wrapping up at least at three
I'll keep it as brief as possible my
name is Stuart Cooper I live in Sutton
New Hampshire and I'm the executive
director of the charitable non-profit
known as the fluoride Action Network
we're a public health environmental
Watchdog group with over 55 medical and
scientific professionals working to
protect citizens from overexposure to
fluoride our organization supports this
legislation which has bipartisan
sponsorship and support and the last
time was before this committee was in
2012 when I came here to urge you to
look at the dental fluorosis rates and
the cdc's own data on it and at the time
the dental fluorosis rates were at 41
percent of our adolescents had Dental
fluorosis Dental fluorosis is a
biomarker of overexposure ingesting too
much fluoride in infancy you see it in
the white and brown splotches on the
teeth the same people that opposed that
bill are here today posing this bill for
these very same reasons you and your
wisdom looked at the cdc's own data and
decided wait a minute Stuart and fan are
correct we are over exposing our systems
and you pass a bill that now is codified
into law which warns citizens not to
reconstitute infant formula with
fluoridated water so what we're doing
now is since 2017 there have been about
10 nih-funded studies looking at
fluoride and in Florida communities
primarily in North America and the link
to developmental neurotoxicity guess
what every single one of them has found
a link to developmental neurotoxicity
every single one and I think you've sent
you've seen some of that I've provided
that data I also provide you an op-ed
from the former director of the national
toxicology program Linda Birnbaum saying
I hope policy makers take notice of this
and do something about it and I'd urge
you to read that that person's uh op-ed
I only have three minutes but this bill
does nothing to change fluoridation
policy it's a study and I trust you with
looking at the data I'm not saying don't
look at the data trust me I'm saying no
I trust you look at the data to please I
think you'll be shocked at what you find
and it may end up in saying hey maybe we
need a commission of scientists or
something to study it or maybe we just
need to have a warning for pregnant
women so the IQ has dropped doesn't
necessarily mean or maybe we love
fluoridation and everybody should do it
I leave that in your hands I think my
job is just provide the studies to you
all of them not just cherry pick them
but all of them and leave it in your
hands why is this important right now
well guess what in a couple weeks the
national toxicology program is about to
publish their final draft of a word
study they've done for many years you
haven't heard about it I'm shocked that
the bureaucrats here in New Hampshire
haven't brought this to your attention
but they've studied Developmental
neurotoxicity and this research that
they funded over the years and let's
just say the drafts that they've
supplied to the public have have said
it's a presumed developmental neurotoxin
the fact that this hasn't been brought
to your attention already is abysmal and
you should be concerned that it hasn't
brought to you attention as well as now
the dental fluorosis rate when I came in
2012 it was at 41 the CDC now says it's
at 70 percent 70 percent of our
adolescents now have dental fluorosis
you guys have had 20 years to act and we
can't wait for the federal government to
do it and we can't wait several more
years for other people that promoted the
practice for 75 years to get on board
that's why we're giving you you the data
we're hoping that researchers will reach
out to you and you can ask them
questions not special interests not
lobbyists but actual the authors of
these studies and I think it'll be
rarely informative to uh for all of you
um it's not wrapping up okay uh I guess
I'll just say I've supplied the
information I've supplied the studies
I'm going to be sending you an email
with video presentations all short from
some of these authors as well as the
former ntp director and I urge you to
please watch these videos don't trust me
don't trust them you know look at the
data yourself you guys are wise enough
thank you and I support the this and
open up questions thank you our
representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman you read my mind I
didn't write in my hand but you would
wait a moment ago
I was just telling you about the time
um oh I'm sorry that's okay I do have a
question uh is that
um do you know if that statute requiring
the warning for pregnant women is that
in uh and reconstituting baby formulas
that's still in effect oh yeah yep it's
still a law here in New Hampshire has to
be on the water Consumer Reports the
ghost all water consumers and Florida
communities thank you which are 12 of
here in New Hampshire representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chairman and just
quickly
um is there fluoride in water naturally
as well as in um introduced into
Municipal Water Systems yep typically
groundwater is about 0.1 part per
million and when we introduce it
chemically it increases at 700 percent
to about 0.7 there are some about it's
about I don't know less than five
percent of the communities like Grantham
for instance that has natural phosphorus
you know bedrock and stuff and they have
levels naturally about one and there are
some communities up in the mountains
smaller that have higher levels like 0.2
or pardon me 2.0 or four so these this
bill would affect those people as well
thank you yep other questions
you have another one representative
Coachman uh someone had asked and I
wanted to hear the answer but um no one
had given it so thank you for uh
indulging me is uh are there other are
there parts of the country that are
looking at this issue like
municipalities or states or anything
like that that are that are re
reevaluating based on these safety
concerns yes there's a I mean just
legislatively there's a bill in Oklahoma
to prohibit fluoridation there's a bill
in a Hawaii
to prohibit fluoridation State College
PA their water authority is made up of
seven phds from Penn State and they just
voted after years of research to end
fluoridation and just so yes it's we're
seeing a Groundswell and we're now
hearing because the ntp report of state
epidemiologists now
having major concerns and no longer
endorsing the practice because of the
government-funded studies yep
representative King thank you chairman
McDonald thank you for taking questions
is it your understanding that this
really isn't a partisan issue and that
there are both blue and red states that
have either stopped or never were taking
uh or fluoridating their water thank you
yeah this is absolutely nonpartisan
whatsoever I mean the makeup of our
organization we have people on all sides
um right now Senator gabbard a democrat
in Hawaii has a bill
bipartisan support in Kentucky for a
bill there to prohibit fluoridation
bipartisan support here on our bill we
have Republicans and Democrats this is
not political
um and we have people on both sides of
the vaccine issue you probably don't
want to hear about but it's like this is
a water issue this is a water safety
issue has nothing to do with politics
from our perspective thank you other
questions
yes representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question
um the dental issue is a huge issue
um in terms of Public Health and and our
introduction of fluoridation one way or
another has dramatically improved Dental
Health in this country and health in
general I'm just curious these other
places what strategies they use to make
sure that that public health measure
doesn't go away
that's a good thank you yeah that's a
good question so probably a good example
uh well here in the United States what's
what they're utilizing are school-based
programs School ceiling programs topical
fluoride programs School seal and
screening programs we've also seen the
usage of mid-level providers see it's
about getting access to dental care it's
about using topical fluoride it's not
about ingesting fluoride uh so and and
one of the probably one of the countries
Scotland had reduced their childhood
decay in school by 70 percent they don't
use fluoridated water they use a
school-based program
yep other questions
so you know other questions thank you
thank you
also signed up to speak is Dr Laurie
Rosado from the New Hampshire Dental
Society
thank you Mr chair we have a three
minutes ma'am please okay my name is
Lori Rosado I'm a practicing dentist
here in Concord New Hampshire I've been
practicing almost 30 years I also am a
supervising dentist at 10 public schools
in the Concord area where we treat
hundreds of children every year
um
I'm a proponent yeah
okay did I repeat what I just said okay
I'm a practicing dentist I've been
practicing for almost 30 years I'm also
a supervising dentist for 10 public
schools in the area of the Concord area
and it's surrounding towns I'm a
proponent for fluoride in safe levels
like we have it currently in our in our
water systems I understand that this
this bill is for a study
um just hearing what everybody's saying
today I just want to reflectively say
it's not that we're against a study I'm
for every part of Education possible I
love to see people read I encourage all
the kids I see in schools to read and I
want you guys to read everything you can
as well we're not against a study in any
way shape or form what we want though is
that you're looking at the proper proper
studies the proper material I've been
testifying here some of you may
recognize me I've been testifying here
for almost six or seven years and one
year that I came I said I want to see
the opposition's information that
they're presenting I want to read it so
for a couple nights prior to coming I
read about 80 pages is and as a mother
as a teacher and as a professional in
the community
if I didn't have my science background I
might have walked in here that day and
said I'm scared of having fluoride in
the water
because those studies could lead you to
be to think bad why did I think
different as I read those studies
because I have a science background and
I know you need to have double-blind
studies that are cross-sectional you
can't use anecdotal situations and much
of those 80 pages that I read were that
so in going forward if you do decide to
go through with a study which I do think
is a waste of time just honestly but I
would never discard you from doing that
I what I want most is that you read the
proper materials and bring in the proper
professionals the proper scientists the
proper researchers because I can tell
you honestly in this room as much
knowledge as I as I have I don't have
the studies memorized and I'm not the
person that should just sit here and
speak to you if you're going to make the
decision to remove fluoride out of the
water I can only tell you what I've seen
over my 30 years of practice and what I
know and what should what I think should
be done based on the studies I've read
but you should have a professional and
and that's what you would need in that
study bring the right people in and you
know there there are studies that are
even currently as in as in 2020 that
will explain the what fluoride does for
children yes fluorosis is a fact do you
want one little pitiflarosis like I have
on on my front tooth that none of you
can probably see I would be one in that
study and that 70 percent that it's gone
up to that little pit on my front tooth
would put me into that study but I'd
much rather that little pit on my front
tooth and a big hole in my back tooth
that requires a root canal crown and
extraction or an implant I don't want to
see children go through the pain and
suffering that we've seen children go
through for many many years because they
didn't have fluoride or currently still
don't have fluoride that's what I want
to prevent I want to make it safe for
all the children and prevent the pain
and suffering that they don't need to
have based on the science and research
that we have today
thank you questions representative King
thank you chairman McDonald
um you mentioned that and thank you for
taking questions uh you mentioned that
you want us to look at the proper
studies and I'm just curious if you
would consider uh the National Institute
of Health the Journal of the American
Medical Association and the national
toxicology program to be valid studies
thank you I'd have to see the study
myself and I'd want to read through it
but yeah those are valid resources
other questions just representative
Palmer
so what was brought up a little while
ago was the application of fluoride on
teeth and my question is if we start
looking at Alternatives what's the Gap
now if if you took all the fluoride out
of water and you just said we're going
to just apply it how how big a project
is that and how many kids are being
missed or would be missed well
absolutely many children would be missed
um you know if I look at the schools
that I see a lot of underserved children
in I won't speak from my private
practice because these are mostly
families that are coming in that have
regular dental care so if I speak to the
school programs that I'm seeing a lot of
these children don't even have a
toothbrush in their home many times we
give them a toothbrush and they say do I
continue to share this with everyone
they're sharing one toothbrush with five
children sometimes so they don't have
access to care they don't have access to
care in their own home so without
fluoride in the water many of them are
not going to have toothpaste at home to
use it's it's still happening today so
many people think this is something of
the 60s and 70s it's not it's happening
today
other questions
representative Nagel thank you Mr
chairman thanks for taking my question I
have to say when we started this process
I kind of shared your cynicism we just
did an entertaining literature search
here and it became convinced that
there's two separate potential Public
Health crises here and it's not the mark
and the tooth but the developmental
disabilities and in the children's a big
issue um what I'm wondering about maybe
I'm trying to convince you of something
um
we may not be talking about you know an
amount fluoride in the water but a
certain amount that's important and I
think we do have to have a discussion at
a public level about that or alternative
strategies to get and I'm curious what
your thoughts are about that and if that
changes your point of view on whether
this committee is important
are you referencing
um like changing the amount from the 0.7
milligrams per liter or yeah
that are alternative strategies to get
Florida on kids I guess what the only
thing I could say is the 0.7 milligrams
per liter that's been studied has been
shown to be very safe and effective
especially in a state like New Hampshire
where it's not a hot area like there's
been studies in places like Sudan where
the climate's very very hot and they
might drink a far more excessive amounts
of water than a place like New Hampshire
and as I noticed a question came up
earlier today about different areas and
and you know it's climate and Geographic
and geologic uh based on you know what's
in the water you know in terms of rock
beds and things like that but am I
helping answering a lot I learned a lot
about Flora in the last 20 minutes okay
representative
would you believe from the quick
research I just did only 22 towns in New
Hampshire have fluoride in their water
and 199 do not I do believe that I know
the number and it saddens me I will say
that I've practiced in Chicago Rhode
Island and New Hampshire and I started
practicing when I first came to New
Hampshire in Bedford on the border of
Manchester and when I saw the number of
children with cavities I I was confused
I I'd never seen this many cavities in
children's mouths and so I asked that
gentleman that I was practicing with I
said I've only been out of school for
five years so it was Chicago and Rhode
Island but I feel like I'm in a third
world country and he said well there's
no Floyd in the Manchester Water and
there's no fluoride in many of their
homes because they're on well water and
unless we educate them to be on fluoride
tablets and educate them on what's
happening this is why you're seeing that
and I didn't see that in inner city
Chicago I didn't see the Decay that I
was seeing in a private practice and on
the Bedford Manchester line
other questions
representative Cushman thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
um what you said just conflicted with
the previous testimony or from the
introduction
um it's my understanding that Manchester
Water Works and the every town that that
um serves does have Florida apparently
fluoridated okay so when at that time
right when I first came yeah okay and
have you seen
um in in that area have you seen the
rates decrease since then I don't
practice there I practice in Concord now
it's just when I first had moved here
thank you other questions
seeing none thank you thank you and
thank you for your service to all of you
thank you
also signed up to speak is Chris nurrath
from the American environmental health
studies project
you've asked for eight minutes sir I'd
really appreciate it I've been cutting
it down as we go
um thank you my name is Chris new wrath
I'm the research director for the
American environmental health studies
organization project
um
the um
oh yeah all right I'll have to hold this
I'll have to hold this so I can read it
and uh talk into it
um the handout that's being given to you
is a packet of scientific papers and
it's just the first pages and I can
supply the whole papers and any other
papers
um for any anybody who's interested on
the committee
um I'm giving you these because Dental
organizations and government Health
departments claim there are thousands of
studies proving the safety of
fluoridation but that is a false
statement now it's true that there's
been thousands of studies of the adverse
effects of fluoride but it is false to
say that they that those that collection
of uh many studies could conceivably be
said to prove
uh that see that it proves fluoride is
safe the national research Council
reviewed over a thousand of them in 2006
in the only comprehensive review of the
adverse health effects of fluoride ever
done and the majority of them found
there were adverse health effects and
some at exposures experienced by people
in the USA
very few of them found no adverse effect
um there is uh one specific adverse
effect which has been the focus of
intense scientific research just in the
past five or ten years and that's the
low Arena of IQ of children from early
life exposure a systematic review by the
national toxicology program has now
identified over a hundred of these
studies and over 95 percent of them find
lowering of IQ
the ntp report on fluoride neurotics
toxicity was scheduled to be released
released last May but was blocked by
political reasons but as Stuart Cooper
mentioned it is now a court decision has
arranged for it to be released within a
month
the dry air is getting to my eyes I'm
gonna just
allergies
um
so the New Hampshire
legislature will have a chance to see
for themselves what the ntp has found
unfiltered by those who try to say this
five-year long systematic review is
invalid and can be ignored
several of the most recent and strongest
studies
have been funded with NIH grants and
have been conducted by the preeminent
environmental epidemiologists and
specialists in neurotoxicity these
experts include scientists who've
conducted studies on lead Mercury
perfluorinated compounds
and their work has helped
the CDC and the EPA set regulations on
lead and Mercury
um
they have turned their attention to
fluoride and have found fluoride is also
neurotoxic and can lower IQ
but don't take my word for it the bill
before you would establish a study
committee where you can look at the
evidence yourself
um
and I'd like to quote from uh again this
is this is not don't have to take it
from me uh the the chief editors of Jama
the Journal of the American Medical
Association I had a podcast where they
discussed that paper and the idea and
I'm just going to do a few quotes from
them
Dr Rivera the paper is about fluoride
and maternal fluoride exposure during
pregnancy and its effects upon IQ scores
of children which in itself is like a
shocking title because I had never known
that there was even any concern that
maternal fluoride use might affect
children's IQ Dr christakis yeah please
wrap up I will the traditional teaching
when I was going on was that fluoride
was completely safe so when I first saw
this title my initial inclination was
what the hell
um
a one milligram per liter increase in
maternal urinary fluoride was associated
with a five-point lower skin and I'm
going to add my concern to yours we have
limited strictly other people one minute
one minute sorry we were strictly
limited other people and you have gone
over time and it's not fair okay to them
a final final sentence
um
so if mothers now come into their
doctor's offices and ask the
pediatrician what to do what are you
going to say I think I would advise them
to drink bottled water or filtered water
okay thank you sir those are the editors
of Jama Pediatrics and Tama online thank
you so much I'd be happy to answer any
questions
I'm saying no question thank you thank
you
also signed up to testify and I don't
think I can pronounce this last name so
I'm not going to try Dr Christine from
Guilford New Hampshire
um
you know who you are it's my husband's
last name I took it I apologize for not
being able to read it but hi I'm Chris
Blackwelder I'm a general dentist in
Tilton
um I'm a general dentist but I only see
children in the elderly the the bookends
um I don't want to be redundant again
you have three minutes yes of course I
don't want to be redundant of my
colleagues but I do want to highlight a
couple
um questions that I've heard so far
today so I want to take a moment and
talk about systemic versus topical
fluoride so systemic fluoride for the
children is what we need is a building
block to create that stronger enamel
Matrix topical fluoride is what you and
I use on our teeth to prevent Decay day
to day but our our Matrix is already
formed so the topical fluoride from a
Fluoride Varnish or a dentrifice would
come topically of course and then the
systemic the systemic fluoride is
typically in community water as we've
heard already today we have very few
communities in our in our state I
practice in The Lakes Region and when I
see a child from Laconia I take a little
sigh of relief because I know that
child's got like one check in the in the
Pro box
um
so I wanted to highlight that we should
know that Dental caries is the most
common chronic disease of childhood and
it's the number one cause of missing
school hours I think that's significant
to highlight and I say this to my
patients you know I'm a mother as well I
I live on well water and I had to
examine what the Baseline of our well
water is we have to be prescriptive in
how we use this
this mineral so we have to look at what
the Baseline is on a well water or a
community and prescribe accordingly
vitamin C you can overdose on and get
severe diarrhea and vomiting so too much
of a good thing can be a bad thing
um
foreign
again I I'm not fearful of a study I I
welcome all information but as Dr Rosado
said I think we just need to be
conscientious of of the source
um making sure that you know it's a
double-blind study and we'll leave you
today with a robust meta-analysis of of
current I saw on our bibliography today
2023 the current information
okay thank you questions
representative Cushman
thank you Mr chairman for taking my
question
um and thank you for taking my I mean
thank you and thank you uh so my
question is related to diet because all
I'm hearing a lot about you need
fluoride
um for infants and small children who
can't yet spit out topical fluoride but
haven't heard much about diet and I know
the Western A price foundation has done
extensive research on
um different uh populations around the
world and their dental health and how
their diets related to that and what was
in common and they found that vitamin
sufficient vitamin D organ Meats animal
fats and proteins were vital to
establish
um you know good oral health from the
beginning
um and I I know that sugar is especially
detrimental to dental health and as well
as an imbalance in the microbiome of the
mouth so I'm just wondering how much of
you know what you're seeing where you
see tooth decay in children how much of
that is related to fluoride and how much
is really diet related and how can you
differentiate between that this is my
love language I'm getting all excited
okay so we need to start with a a strong
foundation so you have a tooth and if
it's been exposed to fluoride it has
this strong enamel Matrix but if it's
not then it's it can be more compromised
so you bring in our diet our Western
diet which is totally carbohydrate based
we are getting more cavities these days
not from sugar not from soda from
goldfish any fermentable carbohydrate a
potato chip a Wheat Thin it can be a
whole grain and that's still feeding the
bad bacteria and to your point right we
all have ten thousand I'm getting all
excited 10 000 different kinds of
bacteria in our mouth and we have good
bacteria and we have bad bacteria so now
the science knows that we are feeding
those bad bacteria all of those
fermentable carbohydrate and then not
adequately removing them at night so I
had one other thought oh we can't we do
have science to combat those or I'm
sorry to combat the bad bacteria and
promote the good bacteria through like
Xylitol and more night
um like basic type foods so you're
getting more than you need but eggs nuts
and cheeses and all those things that
help promote those Basic Foods will
certainly help so it is so complicated
it's it's the the structure it's the
diet and it's removing the Schmutz
does that end to your question more than
representative Palazzo thank you Mr Chen
thank you for taking my question so
first I want to understand if a kid
plays with uh to play two space to
explore early then accidentally consumes
it does it becomes systemic fluoride and
also like what age do you want this
systemic fluoride
for adolescent
um obviously you say it needs to form
this tooth tissue but before they have
cheese or when the fetuses do they still
need it or can we cut off some
exemptions for young ages before two
spin from okay so your first question
was about ingesting a tube or toothpaste
and yes too much of a good thing is a
bad thing not good would want them to
not ingest the tube of toothpaste and to
your second Point
um
so we I advocate for my patients to be
on systemic fluoride until about 16 and
then they're fully mineralized and for
my pregnant patients who are on well
water or in a community with no fluoride
in their water I recommend that they
then drink the nursery water it's a it's
a jug of water that has the perfect
amount of fluoride added back to it was
there another
concept representative Nagel did you
have your hand up
answered my question
um I I really struggle with
epidemiologic studies on complex social
um physical things
Association doesn't necessarily mean
cause
with that said
um we have had a number of papers that
implied that there is an association of
neonatal problems with fluoride and
water and I'm curious what you recommend
to your patients which I think
yeah I I supplement my children not your
children but a pregnant woman oh so same
um I I have her uh drink drinking the
nursery water so that has the added
fluoride in it yes I do
other questions
representative King
thank you chairman McDonald I feel like
the committee that we're trying to
establish is almost happening right now
as we speak I I failed to I failed to
catch whether or not you were in favor
or against having this committee sorry I
I'm against I just think that you're
you're wise enough to be able to process
the information we're leaving with you
and and make an informed decision
other questions
seeing none thank you very much I
appreciate your time
and the final person signed up to
testify today is Michael Abra back from
the New Hampshire Dental Society
did I did I butcher it
okay
it's better than I sometimes do
again three minutes sir
thank you Mr chairman and the three
years to the members and uh I do have a
missive here but uh I'm just going to
send this to you separately
um as part of the collection of
legitimate studies uh and comments on
such studies that we've heard previously
about the ntp and uh other factors that
were disregarded uh when discussing
fluorides and it's so-called
neurotoxicity uh when it's added to the
water my name is Michael Auerbach I'm
the executive director of the New
Hampshire Dental Society on behalf of
our nearly 1100 member dentists some of
whom you've just heard just today
hygienists assistance and office staff I
am speaking to you today in opposition
to HB 217. we've been here before uh in
the last uh well I've been here for
eight years I've testified against
efforts to ban Community water
fluoridation based on flawed studies
four times during those eight years
and each time the Health and Human
Services committee has chimed in with
questions just like you've had
I will not go into the motivations
beyond the fact that the effort is to
create some sort of scientific uh
Foundation or perceived scientific
foundation for Banning fluoride
when every legitimate scientific source
that we've seen including those that
you've just seen that were in the last
month would tell you otherwise
but the question that was asked several
times here was why are we afraid of a
committee why are we forming a committee
it's because you don't need a committee
everybody here at this table everybody
here behind me
has already the answers at their
disposal ask a dentist they have no
personal gain financial gain from giving
you the best health information possible
they read the studies they hear the the
information
they attend CES Community commit
continuing education on a monthly basis
and are required to do so for their
licensure they have all the information
that you need
so rather than waste your time
and waste your resources everybody here
I encourage you
talk to these four
that are behind me talk to your own
dentist because they're going to give
you the information you need I ask that
you vote this bill in expedient to
legislate and I ask I'm happy to answer
any questions
thank you questions from the committee
seeing no questions thank you sir thank
you
okay I have no other uh individual side
I have no one else signed up to speak
today does anyone else wish to speak on
House Bill 217 if not I am going to
close the public hearing on House Bill
217 and open the Committee hearing on
House Bill 342 and this time I'll
recognize the prime sponsor
representative Murphy
thank you
uh
I don't think so no
big choice right
okay
thank you
okay good afternoon good afternoon chair
McDonald members of the committee for
the record I'm Nancy Murphy representing
Hillsboro 12 the town of Merrimack I'm
here as Prime sponsor of HB 342 relative
to lead testing in children
in the interest of time his expertise
and his work on this uh prior I'd ask
that I honorable Dr Jerry knurk former
HHS Community Committee Member be
afforded the opportunity to use my time
to introduce it thank you Mr chair thank
you representative
foreign
good afternoon yes good afternoon thank
you very much so yes this uh this bill
is identical to the amended version of
HB 1642 from 2022 uh which this
committee recommended otpa with a vote
of 20 to 1 and I managed that bill
through the house and was asked by the
sponsor to introduce this bill
this bill establishes a blood level
testing lead level sorry testing
requirement for children entering day
care and public schools requiring the
completed test to be documented on
Children's Health assessment forms the
goal is to improve compliance with lead
testing by serving as a reminder at a
common point of contact with children
now important to understand there is no
safe level for lead lead is a neurotoxin
which is particularly damaging to the
brain during development this one is not
controversial the previous we had a lot
of controversy that has been well
accepted to be a problem
so it's really very dangerous to young
children because their brain is
developing even low levels of lead in
the blood will negatively affect a
child's ability to learn and behave and
these effects may be permanent it's
estimated that about one in five cases
of attention deficit disorder are due to
lead exposure but if you catch it early
there are things parents can do to
prevent further exposure and reduce
damage to their child's health in
addition there is a multiplier effect as
the interventions you do to reduce the
lead exposure for that child will
protect the health of that child's
siblings in the home who are also at
risk
there are many sources of lead with the
most common being the presence of lead
paint in the home
lead was not prohibited in paint until
1978 but New Hampshire has the oldest
housing stock in the nation with 63
percent of the stock built prior to 78
and therefore at risk the most common
exposure to lead exposure most common
reason for lead exposure is the lead
dust from the friction of paint surfaces
when opening Windows and Doors it's not
because they nibble on the door door
frames the dust gets on the floor then
it gets on toys pacifiers and fingers
and all of your parents know those
things all go in the mouth in addition
to lead dust in the home lead levels may
be high in the soil of the drip Zone
around the house due to leaching of lead
from exterior house paint which was
before the 70s and in soil adjacent to
highways secondary to Persistence of
lead in gas prior to the 1970s and in
water from lead pipes
now
sb147 was passed into law in 2018 and
that was the result of a study
Commission on lead poisoning that is the
bill that established a requirement for
bullet blood lead level testing in
children by age one
and again by age two this bill does not
establish that it builds on that
was then in order to identify children
who have been poisoned and also then
therefore identify unsafe housing
however compliance with this testing
requirement has been low testing peaked
in 2019 prior to the pandemic but still
only 64 percent of one-year-olds and 75
percent of two-year-olds had been tested
by 2021 secondary to decrease visits
during covet and some recall on testing
supplies the testing rates dropped by 20
percent to 51 and 60 respectively
states that have implemented a
requirement to document lead testing
upon admission to child care and school
have seen increased rates of compliance
Maryland's rate increased Maryland when
it did it increased compliance by 61
percent
now in order that a child would not be
kept out of school or that a parent
would not lose a valuable daycare slot
if you look at lines 9 to 11 and 23 to
24 provision is made to Grant a
six-month grace period to remedy the
deficiency but do notice the typo in
line 10 which should read granted not
grated
parents have the right to exempt their
child from lead testing under
rsa-130a5c that's already existed in law
an HB 342 does not interfere with their
ability to exercise that right exemption
of testing would not serve as a barrier
to being admitted to school or child
care
now in 2022 HB 1642 passed through the
house initially but in finance concern
was raised about the administrative
burden on the schools and that would
cause kids to be turned away from child
care in school
but as I just noted it will not turn
kids away from child care in school you
can still be Exempted that's not a
problem
in addition the burden on schools and
child care will really be extremely
small
schools and child care facilities
already must maintain a health form on
each child Which documents the
immunization status the New Hampshire
Early Childhood Health form which is
currently in use in many schools and
child care facilities for documentation
of immunizations already includes a
place to document blood lead level
testing results Dartmouth just added a
space for documentation of the lead
level to their health form that they
automatically generate from the EHR for
the immunization history
as a result the documentation of the
lead level in the school should probably
add less than a minute because you're
already looking at the form you just
check that the lead level has been
reported as well probably less than a
minute per child and if the school
documentation requirement helps just
catch one child per year with lead
poisoning who can then be appropriately
treated to prevent learning disabilities
that school would save much more money
on their special ed costs than would
ever be expended on the administrative
work of compliance for the whole school
for a year
now I've also been informed though that
some stakeholders have concern about the
lack of an age limit in this bill and it
probably is not necessary for older
children who were in after school
programs to be included this is not in
my written testimony
um because I just became aware of that
you know one could place an age limit in
this bill that would only apply to ages
nine months to six years old so that a
kid who's in middle school that was
going to an after school doesn't have to
comply with this that would certainly be
very reasonable because the focus is on
kids six and under the reason for saying
nine months is that some kids go into
Child Care earlier than nine months and
it's not routine to be testing before
nine months it's the requirement is by a
year and as when your checks usually go
on between about nine months and 12
months
um
the other thing is and I just became
aware one came in here that you guys
were given a memorandum from house
committee services that talks about the
legislative history of 1642 and it was
also mentioned that uh the by the report
from Jess Edwards and the one Finance
handled the bill that the DHHS should
have a public education program they
already do they have a board book they
have posters they have all kinds of
stuff so they are already doing that
so in summary the goal of this bill is
to improve compliance with blood lead
level testing of our children when they
are very young to allow early
intervention and to identify unsafe
housing it's time to get the let out so
I'll be glad to take questions about how
the bill is constructed it's really
pretty simple and short but I begot to
take questions
thank you Mr chairman and also thank you
honorable doctor
um Jerry Conner
it's good to see you again yeah
um as we discussed last year when we saw
either this bill or a similar one the
the testing really isn't in my mind
isn't really the issue and how easily
you can document all this the real
problem comes when you actually Discover
it and then what happens to the
landlords that own the property or uh or
the homeowner that owns the property and
we live in a state that has some really
old buildings so how do we how do we
deal with the getting the lead out
okay well that she I knew you'd like
that
um okay that gets a little more
complicated that's what a lot of uh
sp147 in 2018 dealt with there are funds
available for remediation first of all
it's uh at the hearing last year
somebody made a comment well why don't
we just remediate all the buildings
that's been estimated to cost about 1
billion with the B dollars and I don't
think we want to increase our budget by
eight percent so I don't think that's
going to happen this year but the bottom
line is that's why one identifies the
at-risk houses so for example
um if uh I'm I'm I happen to be in a
somewhat newer house but if we're in an
older house it's not going to be a big
deal because I don't have kids there I
do have grandkids but we still you know
don't have to worry about it but the
thing is that you there are different
levels uh different times when there are
action levels like if you're over if
you're three you have to give I hope I
got these correct you have to give
information to the parents about it and
then there are higher levels when you're
over six and so on and so forth that
action has to be taken and Remediation
needs to happen but there are also our
funds to help with that as well
so the goal of this is again to try to
prevent and it's not something which
is going to be impossible to it's not
like the person has to then move out of
that housing and become homeless that's
not the issue we try to help the the the
department tries to help them to deal
with it and there are a lot of resources
and actually okay this is somewhat
personal for me
um we have a two year and three month
old grandson who's being raised in Eaton
and it lives in a 1830 house and
um I found that there was some lead I
did a bunch of soil testing around it's
in the drip Zone and so on and so forth
It's been partially remediated but in
spite of that he still tested out with a
blood double test of three and now
unfortunately even his was a little bit
delayed because of the problem with the
testing supplies but being in a high
risk house they should have just
proceeded to the Venus test immediately
because that's what you do you can do as
well in any case
um at two years and three months he's
just finally beginning to use some words
but the uh the school actually his child
care actually uh helped facilitate
getting some Speech Pathology work for
him because it's not we can't know it's
from the lead but there's certainly a
reason to believe it is because that is
one of the cause one of the side effects
so the goal is to you know improve
that's why you want to identify the
unsafe housing in addition to that
particular kit
another question yeah representative
Shapiro thank you
thank you Mr chairman and um excuse me
um if I'm missing something here but it
seems like in the first part when
children go to school the mechanism by
which this gets a lead test gets
recorded is because there has to be a a
child's physical prior to entering
School
but it doesn't say anything about that
in regard to a child entering take a
daycare agency it just says that it will
um
Health form she'll include it so is is
the mechanism the same does it does do
the does there need to be a physical
before they go to daycare as well that's
in section two section one is a physical
examination of pupils and that is uh
prior to first entry into a public
school system section two beginning of
line 14 that is about child care
residential care and child placing
agencies and that is that every each
child care agency so that's going to be
like your local daycare she'll maintain
the same records so that's that is
covered in both of those
follow up follow up but it doesn't say
anything about requiring a physical
before you go actually no you're right
because it's slightly different what
they do in the child care is they
maintain records because they still have
to uh document the immunization and so
usually what happens is apparent you
know so it goes to their Dock and they
get the health form that has
immunizations and would have the blood
test on it as well so it's not adding a
requirement to parents who because they
would have to get come with medical
records anyway as best I understand the
child care licensing people can answer
that probably more precisely than I yeah
and actually I would add one thing too
for representative King's comment when
it does identify to it there's also
things one can do as I said to lessen
the exposure things like frequent wiping
down a surface is using a HEPA vacuum to
make sure that the dust gets tracked in
from the drip Zone gets cleaned up you
know all those kind of things washing
the kids hands before they eat and
trying to you can't keep stuff out of
kids mouths so that's hopeless
representative Palazzo
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question so you testified that
uh testing peaked in 2019 and I'm
looking into this uh lead exposure in
New Hampshire that I believe it shows
that uh it peaked in 2019 but actually
the number of positive tests positive
results were going down uh since two
years before which tells me that
situation may be improving and with us
using new technology it looks like this
situation will be improving in the
future so could it be that it eventually
solved itself and as you said we can't
like replace all the pipe lead pipes and
the lead paint this year but maybe we
can put some Sunset Amendment maybe in
five or ten years we don't need this
testing anymore what are you thought
thank you and actually the testing rate
is dropped but if we look at figure
three I think we're looking at the same
thing the number of children 72 months
or younger above the Action level that's
actually increased in 21 significantly
um
at least that's my understanding so the
bottom line is the lead isn't going to
go away in 10 years in our housing stock
or our our
um water and actually in water varies a
great deal obviously I mean a lot of the
houses don't have any lead water problem
anyway I'm in an area where almost
everything's in a well you don't have
Municipal supplies usually but the house
may have an old lead Supply but if it's
clean it's clean but as far as the lead
until we get until all of our old houses
fall down and are replaced it's going to
continue to be a problem
so I don't see any reason to Sunset it
because it's a highly significant risk
uh other questions
see no other questions
good thank you sure thing thank you very
much
and I don't think they'll be bothering
you for a little while yet now
also signed up to testify I'm Michelle
obers and Beverly drouin from the New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services
can you hear me okay okay I can uh good
afternoon members of the committee for
the record my name is Michelle Roberge
and I'm the administrator of the Bureau
of Public Health protection within the
DHHS division of Public Health Services
and with me today is Beverly drouin who
is the divisions healthy homes and
environment section administrator
the department would like to thank the
sponsors of this bill for their interest
in supporting our vulnerable populations
bloodlet testing is critically important
to ensure the health of children in New
Hampshire as the only way to know if a
child is poisoned by lead is through a
blood lead test any amount of lead in a
child's body is dangerous and can cause
Health cognitive impairment and
behavioral problems these health effects
are more harmful to young children
because their bodies are developing and
growing young children often put hands
and other objects that may be
contaminated with lead dust into their
mouths so they are more likely to be
directly impacted by lead than older
children
by testing at ages 1 and 2 parents and
health care providers can learn if
mitigation strategies are needed to
reduce further exposure prior to
negative health effects under state law
currently all children in New Hampshire
are required to have a blood lead level
test at ages 1 and a second test at age
two the department also recommends blood
lead testing for all children ages three
to six who have not been tested at one
or two
according to the Centers for Disease
Control and prevention similar lead
testing requirements exist for all
children enrolled in Medicaid and the
American Academy of Pediatrics
recommends that providers test
asymptomatic children for elevated blood
lead concentrations according to federal
state and local requirements
as noted in the Department's most recent
lead exposure data brief which I believe
we're passing around now
in 2021
5360 fewer children had blood lead level
tests since 2019. in large part this was
due to the covid-19 pandemic and a
nationwide recall in the in-office blood
lead testing supplies this represents a
25 percent drop in the number of
children tested in New Hampshire for
blood lead levels since 2019.
as introduced HP 342 is well intended
but the requirements for blood lead test
for entry into public schools and child
day care facilities is Broad it appears
that the text would require children of
all ages not just young children to
provide blood tests prior to entry to
public school
in addition the same requirement could
apply to Children older than six
attending a licensed after-school
program
while the department is very supportive
of innovative ways to promote lead
testing we recognize that some of these
requirements could place additional
burden on school and child care
administrators the department feels that
HB 342 could be strengthened by focusing
on younger children ages one to six
years of age which I believe the sponsor
of the bill mentioned in the testimony I
do begin wrapping up your testimony I'd
just like to note that similar efforts
have been established in the City of
Claremont The Claremont School Board
instituted a policy in 2017 that
required both the one and two-year-old
blood lead level test be documented on
the physical examination form for entry
into pre-K in kindergarten thank you for
the opportunity to provide this
testimony today we would certainly be
willing to work with the sponsor on any
revisions to the language and we'd be
happy to answer any questions
representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
there had already been mention of
changing the child Child Care section
would you be in favor in the school
entry to say Exempted under RSA 130 a5c
or entering after age six
so the language would focus on I'm sorry
this is for the school entry one yeah
which you're intending to catch that
nine month through six year old yes if
that language because you're worried
about casting too broad a net in the
school system said unexempted under this
RSA or entering after age six yes we
could I think that would be so it would
be really focusing on years one to six
for those for those tests yeah thank you
other questions
any other questions
representative
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question help me understand uh
Does it include use
new requirements for Destiny is it just
making sure that previous requirements
for testing are followed
so no it doesn't require any new testing
So currently in state law RSA 130a
does require tests be done at ages one
and two
um and uh there is an exemption parents
there is an exemption that currently
exists in that law as well so there's no
additional testing requirements in this
thank you any other questions
okay thank you very much thank you
also signed up to speak is
representative Emily Phillips
I had no idea I'd have such relevant
testimony all day so I'm sorry I'll be
quick
um so my brother's 34 he was lead pain
poisoned when he was two years old in
Massachusetts my uh parents were told uh
we had to evacuate like leave our home
that my dad bought this bunny pit of a
Victorian long story short he was
sanding he poisoned my brother and we
were basically homeless for six months
my dad went and got licensed to become a
licensed the letter to fix his dream
home because it was too expensive for
him to take on the cost to remove the
lead or hire it out I should say I know
that was
you know 20 32 years ago now so um
hopefully that's not the situation now
my concern with this bill is that it
um there needs to be clear consequences
of what happens when a child tests High
I know that in the bill it says if a
child has not had a blood level test at
the time of admission they shall be
granted six months to remedy the
deficiency what happens then are there
legal ramifications for the parents who
don't get the blood test
um and then I'm just not a fan of
mandates requirements versus
recommendations so I just want to make
sure that the committee takes into
consideration what happens if a child
tests High what happens to those parents
what happens to that child what are the
expectations
thank you questions
being none thank you
also signed up to speak is Henry vayu
for the New Hampshire Alliance of YMCAs
good late afternoon uh members of the
committee
um I'll be very brief Henry vayu on
behalf of the New Hampshire Alliance of
YMCAs we have child care programs all
around the state we are happy to be part
of the solution to getting a kids more
kids tested but here's the one concern
that we have with the approach that the
bill is taking
so it basically this is the form that
needs to be supplied by the parents to
enter into the program and it does have
a section in here for the results of
lead test
uh but what this law will do is it says
you have uh you have to have the results
of the test on the form
a supply you know filled out by The
Physician and if you don't within six
months
um these are well these These are the
repercussions um we asked in the
department last year when the bill uh
was in play and this was the response
um should this law pass my initial
interpretation is that parents must
Supply the testing result and the date
of the test or the information that they
have opted out of testing
should it not be provided initially then
parents have six months to provide the
information
when child care licensing reviews the
forms on file with the provider
we would review whether or not the
programs have the information as we do
for immunizations so if the test result
is not on here we would cite the program
for the missing information and the
program would need to provide a
corrective action plan that includes the
required information
so we already know that the testing
rates are going down they're the
department reported recently that the
testing rates have gone down so the
providers the the child care providers
are not just going to be asking the
parents to provide the forms they're
basically going to be telling some
parents you've got to go get the test
and provide the form and I can guarantee
you that there are going to be some
parents after six months that will not
have supplied that and if in the form if
in the file of the provider there's
either not the result test or something
signed by the parent that says they are
opting out then the provider the child
care provider gets cited and has to so
that's the concern that the providers
have
right now uh working in a Child Care
Agency is Pretty Tough there's staffing
issues I try to do the best we can
and we are happy to be part of the
solution it just seems when the primary
care physician is filling out the form
maybe that's the appropriate time to say
you got to get the test done uh the
providers don't have all the information
about lead testing and we're not
Physicians to be able to talk with the
parent in the office we're happy to
remind them if this is more of an
approach you need to remind the parent
and we're fine to have them sign the
form and that says we've been reminded
by the provider the child care provider
that we should get this test we're happy
with doing that but it just penalizes
the provider with this approach by
saying if they if the parent doesn't
provide the information you get cited so
that's that's the problem that we have
with the approach that this takes thank
you any questions yes representative
Nagel thank you for taking or thank you
Mr chairman thanks for taking my
question
um is this legislation fixable
you know again we are happy to be part
of the solution
if the proponents have said we just want
you to be the reminder and we're happy
to be the reminder like I said if if
over the course of six months
you have them sign the sheet again yes
we've been reminded we need to get this
done we've been reminded so our our duty
will be to remind the parent you got to
get this done but don't penalize the
provider if the parent doesn't get it in
other questions
saying no other questions okay thank you
thank you
and the final person who signed up to
speak today and I have the bill down is
324 I'm assuming it's for 342. William
Rogers from Winchester
you do you did mean you did mean 342
right
this one okay yeah
my name is William Rogers Winchester
again thank you this I can talk a little
bit knowledgeably about I held my lead
abatement license and asbestos abatement
license in the state of Rhode Island for
many years I'm since retired of course
but um one of the representatives asked
about the cost uh and uh
possible
cost to landlords I think he was going
at fortunately lead mitigation is is not
that expensive as the sponsor said most
of the lead poisoning comes from the
windows where they rub together and go
up and down and they continue to rub
that's where most of the toxicity comes
from some from the Baseline the the drip
line outside but simply replacing the
windows and painting the inside of the
windows the interior wood frame is going
to knock out probably 95 percent of the
toxins in a home it's the rubbing that
does it it's the dust it's not the paint
once you cover the lead paint which most
of it's been covered so that's not the
problem but the windows continue to go
up and down so it's not it's not a huge
huge process it's not hundreds of
thousands of dollars to get rid of a
lead and keep the child that that if
this law passes
you'll you'll recognize it and it's not
from The Next Step of course would be to
mitigate it and it's not that daunting a
situation really that's all I wanted to
say thank you questions representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr
Rogers so you're saying if I paint paint
latex paint over my the wooden parts of
my windows that's
better than nothing over in particular
if you think of your window like think
of a typical double Hall window the
sashes that go up and down yep every
place inside there where they rub up and
down and the the wood that's the potting
stop that's generally in between those
would need to be replaced what I'm
saying is if the interior the frame
where your curtains hang from and the
sill that can be painted over and that
encaps encapsulates the lead okay unless
you take a hammer to it or a child
starts chewing on it that lead is
encapsulated and is not going to be a
threat to anyone thank you very much of
course in the event of a fire or
something that would disturb that then
the lead could again have a a chance to
come out but yeah Mr Rogers
other questions
seeing none thank you sir thank you
could I ask Mr Senator Bland sorry thank
you could I ask Mr velu I forgot to ask
you to send that letter that you had
about what would happen with the child
care agencies that would be informative
for us thank you very much
that's fine I have no one else signed up
to testify on House Bill 342 does
anybody else wish to
but yes
I need a print card from you okay
foreign
my name is Danielle warboys I'm a
legislative liaison for DHHS okay you
have three minutes ma'am okay I work um
I work in the child care licensing unit
and this um what was cited to earlier is
they do have to provide a health
assessment form and
um it can be in lieu of a physical
examination but they can also opt out of
this our child care licensing is to keep
child children safe it's not to penalize
the providers and I just want to make
that clarification that there is a form
available where they can opt out or they
can provide documentation of a physician
examination great thank you any
questions
representative Leon um thank you if you
could give us some information on that
process by emailing it to the committee
that would be helpful absolutely thank
you
another questions
thank you and please fill out that pink
card for us
okay if I no one else wishes to testify
on House Bill 342 I am going to close
the public hearing on House Bill 342 and
open the public hearing on House Bill
425 and recognize the prime sponsor
representative Timothy Horrigan
foreign
don't know that many people here
you think after
I think after two hours I'd be ready to
start instantaneously but but no anyway
so I'm president Timothy Horrigan I'm
from Trafford County District
10 which is the town of Durham
and I'm here to introduce HB 425 and
it's uh
huh doesn't have the most enticing time
to repeal the statue relative to Medical
freedom and immunizations and of course
uh
I guess not everybody's in favor of
immunizations but he wasn't in favor of
medical freedom but um
and uh
and this was uh actually it's a repeat
of a bill that was uh introduced in this
committee uh last year and there's
actually I think this was the one where
I had the Music Experience where I had
to Sprint all the way from
the farthest corner of the lob to reps
Hall and I was like severely out of
breath by God and I thought it was
ironically if I drop dead they would
have blamed it on the vaccine or some
people would have blamed it on covid but
I was fine I caught my breath today I
had plenty more a couple hours to rest
up
first of all there is no legal natural
legal or constitutional right to spread
any communical disease especially not a
respiratory virus like covid-19 which
has killed over 1.14 million Americans
a little bit to plant tend to make it
slow down a little since I
introduced the earlier Bill almost
exactly a year ago I think I think maybe
it was a year ago to the day when the
death toll stood around 900 000. so only
a quarter of a million have died in the
last 52 weeks
but even a quarter of a million is a
horrific loss of life this pandemic is
the worst catastrophe in U.S history in
terms of loss of life even worse than
the Civil War and of course that's
probably more shocking when you consider
that medicine was much better now than
it was back then roadway death toll last
I checked which is yesterday 6.78
million and Counting
and I know the vaccines are not 100
effective they're not 100 safe but
they're very good
there's a lot we still don't know about
the virus but we do know for sure that
it's extraordinarily contagious and it's
still dangerous people are still getting
sick people some people are still dying
we're not
um there's some treatments for it but we
still haven't found a cure
and then uh
everything on NPR this morning they're
driving down and they've identified a
new technology for debt for identifying
respiratory viruses unfortunately now
they're going to be finding
a lot more of them because they're
actually like checking
uh they're not taking samples from
humans who are actually sick rather than
taking animal samples and uh then trying
to see if they're replicated in humans
but that's uh
and I represent Durham as I said that's
the whole of unh and UNH took a very
aggressive approach to fighting the
pandemic beginning with masking up and
social distancing and continuing with
testing for the virus and I guess
another factor in Durham too although
there's a lot fewer of them now due to
the political events that have
transpired since then but they had a
large number of Chinese exchange
students especially grad students and so
the
Chinese students at UNH being probably
smarter than the average person
um and of course being in touch with
their family and friends back home and
do new Nuvo was up with that pandemic
maybe before before uh we did those of
us who have to rely on uh you know the
U.S media
anyway and um anyway they're very
aggressive in dealing with the virus
um and rightly so they're a close-knit
community when the coveted vaccines
became available which was exactly two
years ago UNH did everything in its
power to
to get make sure everybody in the
student body as well as the faculty
staff got immunized and uh Phoenix's
private school it could have enacted a
rule acquiring everyone in campus who
can be vaccinated um not everybody can
be but the vast majority of people can
be vaccinated
to get vaccinated ever since UNH was a
public institution uh
RSA 141 c1a the so-called uh medical
freedom and immunization act which I
have to admit is a very nice title so
whoever wrote that was pretty smart
um anyway UNH was forbidden from taking
that step and that makes no sense to me
even though I agree that was a snazzy
title the law account
and the public our public College
University the same responsibilities any
other institution educational or
otherwise public or private from
protecting their uh people from covid-19
so I believe they should have the right
to require vaccination is if that's
what's needed and um that also applies
to a non-educational government
institutions as well so uh
so I urge you to uh
I urge you to uh repeal this unwise law
by passing HB 425 and if maybe he's an
offense too I might notice the even
though the pandemic is still raging
we'll probably have more pandemics the
our awareness of this one seems to faded
a little bit so it's not quite the
Forefront of people's things thank you
representative uh questions
yeah representative Leon
um thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative
um I I guess first this this is only
about covid-19 I believe right well uh
and that's what the statute is I mean
there's something important I forgot to
bring to me what the bill says or faster
into covid-19 pandemic but I think it
was more General than that that's sorry
someone probably
I can pull it up on my on my device if
you want to okay yeah the statute you're
referring to is only the covid-19
vaccination so my question was does the
covid-19 vaccination prevent
transmission so is this a matter where
somebody who's vaccinated could still
spreads covid-19 to somebody else well I
was I was vaccinated and I
in fact I was vaccinated and multiply
boosted and I caught covet I know other
people who did I don't know if I pass it
on to anyone else but you know as I said
the vaccine is not 100 effective but uh
it's
a lot better than just doing nothing
which is what some people would have
wanted us to do that didn't work very
well where it was tried you know then
I mean there there may be I mean some
countries may have gone to Extremes in
the other direction but uh yeah so it
was it was a very dangerous vaccine
still around and possibly uh and was
very much for that one and of course it
was for that if I believe it was for the
one vaccine that makes sense because it
was a new vaccine the actual all else it
came along when there's a lot of
distrust and
both governmental and other institutions
and this was something very new they
came along to people didn't understand
and the vaccines uh
vaccines I think they were tested very
thoroughly um I think they were but they
were tested rather quickly I think there
were some I think you could say I think
it's because there were some similar
diseases they're already working on but
also they put aside a lot of the
pharmaceutical providers put aside a lot
of other projects that develop you know
do sort of like a moon shot or crash
course or whatever program to develop
the coveted vaccine and it was a
my mind was remarkably successful I know
not everybody agrees and you know thank
you nothing's ever 100 effective and of
course you're always going to have
unexplained deaths and right now there's
some people blame every unexplained
deaths that's happened since the last
two years on the vaccine which thank you
thank you representative Hogan any other
questions
representative Shapiro
yes thank you Mr chairman my my memory
of the bill was that there was some kind
of ruling that it only applied to
covid-19 at one point after the bill was
passed so my question is that
since the illness has evolved the
treatments have evolved time has passed
if we repeal this bill which was I was
dead set against when we passed it
if we repealed it
concretely what would be different now
than if we didn't repeal it well we it
still hasn't uh still hasn't gone away
it's still peaking
peeking in some places at a big
China
yeah China took a very much more
aggressive they took probably was an
unworkable approach although they did
manage to keep it going for about two
years and then they kind of went in the
opposite direction and they're having
like a lot of spread at the moment but
and it might even though viruses
uh viruses tend to become uh well
viruses do to him a little bit more like
we might call virulent over the time
because killing the host is usually a
really bad strategy for the virus you
know but also um
and also I think we could still get a
dangerous uh dangerous outbreak and
people are still getting sick and even
dying you know there's uh we even had
members of this legislature have lost
time from work because they're they
caught covet
thank you other questions
Mr representative Missouri
thank you representative for taking my
question
um in the um
thank you very much in the statute
actually there was there were there's a
schedule of fines for violating uh the
statute in place do you know if there
were any violations that were recorded
during since that was implemented why
would I I would I would hope not I mean
I'm
I've always I've never criminalizing any
uh medical procedures almost always a
bad idea I think I I do not know of
anybody anybody was actually prosecuted
or fined as a result of that but that
would that was certainly not a good
feature of the bill
thank you other questions
seeing no other questions okay great
thank you representative thanks
also signed up to speak is former
representative Melissa blasik for
rebuild New Hampshire
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee yes Melissa blasik from
Merrimack I'm here representing rebuild
New Hampshire and we are opposing this
bill I will keep it very short and it's
been a long day
um when this law unanimously passed this
committee on the consent calendar two
years ago it actually applied to every
vaccine but it was reduced to only
applying to the covid-19 vaccine in the
Senate
um I'm struggling to find any valid
reason for repealing this law it's
simply a proactive protection of the
right to bodily autonomy and in fact the
only policy that I know of that was
prevented to be enacted because of this
law was the coveted vaccine mandates in
public universities and
as a result of that lack of mandate
absolutely nothing bad happened so there
you go
um I please vote to itl this Bill thank
you
thank you any questions for Mrs boys I
guess representative Palazzo
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
is previous speakers that we had to do
something that's why we needed this
vaccine that doesn't effectively
stop the transmission or would you
rather agree that there was a need for
now or unhealthy push for emergency use
socialization so some other alternative
treatments will actually pushed aside
and not allowed to be developed because
to get emergency use socialization my
understanding is it has to be the only
treatment right available so yes for a
vaccine to get emergency use
authorization there cannot be any known
treatment for the disease that's the
Benchmark for emergency use
authorization so it yes that's a
possibility that perhaps treatments were
not developed because we were pushing
for a vaccine to have eua I would also
add that
um the covid vaccines were never tested
originally in the primary endpoint of
the original trial was not transmission
so when
other Representatives say that you know
we have to have mandates I mean I never
believe in a vaccine mandate because I
believe in the right to bodily autonomy
but hypothetically if you were going to
justify one it would have to be because
there's a community benefit of stopping
transmission we actually never even knew
that that was the case to begin with
because the primary endpoint of the
original study was
um symptomatic infection not
transmission
other questions
seeing no other questions thank you
thank you
also signed up to speak is Daniel
warboys from Department of Health and
Human Services
she's still here
okay
also signed up to speak is Dr Merrill
Nass
she's also gone okay
also signed up to speak is William
Rogers from Winchester
we've we've been listening to you Sarah
hey
I'm William Rogers from Winchester
um
the president himself has said that the
pandemic is over
his own words and a a national
to all of us he said it's over
um what's not over
is that there are still questions about
what happened during the pandemic about
government overreaches things that have
been done wrong so much so that that we
know that there's been calls for amnesty
for things to be done to repeal this
bill does no good it's it's it's it's
just ludicrous that's all we know
there's more questions now than there's
ever been we know that more stuff
happened this shouldn't have happened
and I do take offense to the saying that
nobody has the right to a force of
communicable disease or spread a
communical disease on anybody else but
that's never what this was about
um they they had admitted from the very
first that it wasn't about stopping
transmission so so that's an insult to
anybody who ever opposed this vaccine or
whoever opposed any of the stuff the
government has done which is now coming
out that there was a lot of malfeasance
done very high places in this government
thank you very much not this government
that government okay thank you sir
I have no one else signed up to testify
does anyone else wish to testify on
House Bill 425 seeing no one I'm going
to close the public hearing on House
Bill 425 those are all of the bills we
had noticed for hearings today we are
now adjourned thank you very much